order a lot
um
the public order emergency commission is
now in session over
hey good morning bonjour
another
exciting week
um so I think we're continuing uh with
former Chief uh slowly if he's uh
up to it
good morning
okay the first up I believe is the uh
Ottawa Police Service
uh good morning commissioner good
morning Mr slowly uh as you know my name
is David mijikovski and I appear for the
Ottawa Police Service how are you good
morning sir thank you very much
[Applause]
um I wonder uh uh Mr clerk if we could
call up uh Ops 14454
page 176
I want to start by asking you some
questions about the Hendon reports
so I'll just wait for the
and it's page 176.
thank you just to situate you for where
we are in time it's February 12th and
then um if we could just turn to the
next page
thank you
and so you'll see
um Mr slowly that on February 12th uh
you've just gotten off of a Call of the
Big 12 services
do you recall that yes sir
and on page
um 177 uh you'll see if you just stay at
the top please
um
you raised a concern uh with the opp
that Ops was being compared to Toronto
and the suggestion that Ops wasn't
prepared and you wanted to address that
situation and commissioner Carrick asked
that you go offline uh to have that
discussion in a professional manner you
recall that yes sir
and so you
you raised um concerns about the Toronto
situation and you
um also want to discuss the uh assertion
that Ops was not prepared and I want to
read a passage just below uh Mr Solly
and asks you to confirm whether that's
accurate and so if you can just scroll
up a bit please
thank you uh
uh Chief uh can't continue to compare
Ottawa to Toronto also we had a blunt
also we had a blind spot Ottawa was not
soft uh or something sold on civil
disobedience or I'm not sure what that
word is uh commissioner Carrick says
don't disagree with you
um and uh then says never any suggestion
that the Toronto situation is like
Ottawa this situation was not caused by
OPP and if we could keep scrolling
please
um the second bullet you indicate to
commissioner Carrick it sounds like
Ottawa got caught off guard we need a
collective understanding of what we did
good and bad want the message to be we
didn't have the Intel and couldn't
prepare and have a message going forward
and then underneath that superintendent
West's Morris says Hendon report not
perfect this type of activity is novel
uh April 2020 saw messaging
re-vaccination talk against if we could
continue please to the next page again
January 2022 first heard on the specific
event so this is um superintendent
Morris speaking discussed it on January
21 22 and sent out via and worked
closely with Ops we underestimated and
as we learned more we tried to collect
the information and work closely with
Ops don't know how Ottawa could have
been prevented Toronto was completely
different and we learned from Ottawa the
Strategic intelligence would not have
would not have provided a key to
prevention Chief
um
asked and this is you asks Pat tomchuck
that's what needs to be told more
broadly and to the intelligence and to
the politicians that intelligence update
needs to be
done needs to be done done judging the
various police services against each
other people are second guessing me I
can't point fingers at RCMP and OPP I
need someone that is credible objective
to speak out not someone fighting for
their job and you'll see commissioner
Carrick says Fair comment we do provide
Hendon to government can ask Pat which I
assume is Pat Morris
um to include a summary to include in
the next end and we can make sure it's
clearly articulated in the Hendon
reports and does that in fact reflect
the conversation that you had with
superintendent Morris and commissioner
Carrick yes sir thank you
um and although um your witness
statement
um did not say so I understand that in
fact you only reviewed the hand in
reports sometime after February 10 uh
2000 and uh 2022 is that correct no sir
okay and I'm going to suggest to you
that it was only after you reviewed the
Hendon reports
sometime after uh February 10th that um
that you formed the conclusion that you
just reached absolutely not sir okay and
I'm also going to suggest to you that
none of the Hendon reports were ever
forwarded by you to either deputy chief
Bell or deputy chief Ferguson my
recollection is that I did but I stand
corrected if there's no actual uh
evidence of that regardless the
discussions of the Henry reports took
place at literally every briefing right
I understand you couldn't find any
record of that
and you read over the witness statement
of deputy chief Bell yes or acting Chief
Bell
and you're aware from his testimony and
his witness statement that he learned of
the Hendon report sometime in the week
of January 24th through discussion with
superintendent Patterson who was the
superintendent in intelligence and then
began to receive the reports on January
27th you understand that correct I
understand that's a statement sir yes
and you understand from deputy chief
Ferguson that she only started to get
those reports in the week of um February
4th again that's her statement sir
and you have no evidence to the contrary
correct
except that the hen reports were being
discussed well before those days so I
have no other evidence other than that
um and
deputy chief Bell noted in his witness
statement and in his testimony that you
began to receive the Hendon reports on
January 13.
and that you personally received if was
that a question for me yes uh do you
recall that yes I received a Henry
report in regards to the Convoy in
January 13th I believe I was on the
distribution for the Hendon reports
prior to that
right
um and I um Kevin Maloney is your
executive officer or was your executive
officer is that right yes inspector
Miller yes and you worked very closely
with him as my executive officer yes
um Mr clerk if we could please turn up
um Ops
uh four zeros nine five five four
and if we could just scroll down to the
bottom of the page
uh you'll see um is it um inspector or
superintendent Maloney
it's inspector Maloney inspector uh
inspector Maloney
um sends an email to Jamie Dunlop
um to superintendent Dunlop and he says
and um
hi Jamie there is apparently an
operation Hendon being run by OPP or
RCMP this is an intelligence-based
operation that has apparently been
producing daily briefings since the end
of January a couple of questions from
the chief are you aware of this
operation do we have an Ops
representative is it integrated into our
ICS model do we have copies of all
briefing notes especially from 5 and 9
February the chief would like a copy of
all briefing notes passed and going
forward sent to him and Christian you
know and so he made inquiries on your
behalf about what the Hendon reports
were yeah no I I don't recall this email
being asked to be sent I do recall
asking for not specifically through my
executive officer but for all previous
copies of Hendon reports the rest of the
bullet points I'm not sure where they
would have come from but they were not
my directions okay so he sent this on
his own he may have been looking for a
background on his own I don't know the
like stent the inspector would have been
briefed up on all these matters so he
says a couple of questions from the
chief you were the chief at the time so
I assumed he was talking on your behalf
I don't recall asking for these things
in a way that they were asked for he's
tried to do his best to get that
information but I obviously knew all of
those answers already what I was looking
for was all the copies of the hand in
reports okay um can we scroll up to the
top please thank you
and so superintendent Dunlop replies hi
Kevin hope you are getting some rest I
am aware of project tendon it's a
provincial project of summary of
intelligence across the province and
National Partners in regard to the
Convoy I have not received any updates
in the few days I've been assigned
intelligence as it related to this
occupation but we'll make sure to
forward everyone to the Chief and
through this email will ensure inspector
Bryden sends directly from source and
not through the chain of command that
may delay sharing I personally have not
received most of them I started to
receive them in November from Robert
Drummond and I note the chief is on the
mailing list I have a gap through the
month of December and January as I'm not
directly in Intel but started to receive
a few from Mark in February I'll forward
those now I've asked I asked Ken Bryden
to have all reports forwarded to you
dating from the first one and you are in
fact copied on that email correct yes
sir
and so we heard
um from the opp Witnesses and
specifically superintendent uh Morris
that he found it very odd that they were
getting requests uh from your office for
copies of the Hendon report when they
had gone directly to you from January
13th onward you heard that testimony and
I can understand why my request was to
my own folks to get past copies of the
Hidden reports technically we should
have been able to get them from our own
intelligence directorate as you can see
by the email from Mr Dunlop for some
reason they weren't my staff were able
to get them from our own folks and so I
guess the request went on from there I
was not aware that we had sent a formal
letter to inspector superintendent
Morris for all these reports we should
have been able to get them from our own
intelligence archives but you had them
they all went were sent to you they were
addressed too slowly yes sir and I don't
manage my email inbox I have an EA that
supports that and for whatever
combination of reasons it wasn't
available to my EA and so a request went
through to the intelligence directorate
and subsequent to that for reasons I'm
not fully aware of it went over to
superintendent Morris the point is
you're right they were available in
inside the Ottawa Police Service and my
request was to the audible Police
Service produced the Heinen report so I
could start to have an archive of them
and look through them myself I I'm not
understanding how you needed an archive
when every single one was addressed to
you and in your inbox I often deleted
reports that I wasn't actually using
anymore and so I wouldn't have a
complete access to them myself and so
I'd have to get assistance from my EA
sometimes from I.T to get past documents
for a wide variety of issues
so your evidence is that you did receive
them and you did read them at the time
no actually my evidence was I read most
of them at the time in terms of line by
line some of them I skimmed through and
some of them I would have forwarded onto
different people for actioning items and
if I suggested to you that not only did
you have them they were unopened in your
inbox what would your response be to
that it is possible that some of them
were unopened depending on the day and
how much I had going on I might not have
been able to read everything that came
into my inbox and so when
um your executive officer inspector
Maloney sent that request to the opp he
did so without your Authority no he has
my authority to do a wide variety of
things including extending to seek
information in order to accomplish his
purpose I don't give him directions and
details on every aspect of what he does
as the executive officer I'm going to
suggest um to you Mr slowly that once
you receive that email this one here
um you at some point decided that you
could blame deputy chief Bell at the
time for not planning for this event
that is absolutely incorrect sir and I
really take offense to that notion thank
you okay um if we could please turn up
Ops four zeros nine five six five
um if we could scroll to the bottom
you'll see um then there's an yes if you
could scroll all the way to the bottom
please
uh just uh go up I'm sorry okay so
you'll see above that email the next
email
in the chain
uh which we just saw and then if we can
go above that
uh you'll then see superintendent
Patterson and you're copied on that says
thanks Jamie further to that all of the
Hendon reports were submitted to DC Bell
for the intelligence briefings that were
provided on a daily basis Ops members in
attendance have been myself prior to the
mic role inspector Bryden and sic
members yes it is integrated into our
model The Briefing notes from February 5
to 9 were supplied by D.C Bell and then
we see above that so now you um believe
that uh deputy chief Bell at the time
had received the Hendon reports
and then you uh indicate on February
10th to your general counsel FYI and for
your records this could become very
important in any I assume that's a typo
post event inquiries uh backslash uh
inquests Peter slowly right
well there was a massive amount of
information in there including the
information about deputy chief Bell
obviously this has actually become very
important in an inquest so yes
and so even though the opp found it odd
that you were your office was
specifically making inquiries about what
these ending reports were and even
though deputy chief Bell's evidence
which was not contradicted was that he
only began to receive them at the end of
January you're now saying uh this could
become important and could it become
important Mr slowly because it will
indicate that you received the Hendon
reports or the deputy chief Bell
received the Hendon reports it's
important sir because it provides a
history of what the Ottawa Police
Service received and reports and what
they did with them in totality
okay okay and so you don't have any
response I take it to um superintendent
Morris who was really quite puzzled by
why you were asking for Hendon reports I
could I could appreciate why
superintendent Morris and the opp would
be puzzled about it
um I want to talk about um deputy chief
Ferguson and um deputy chief Bell at the
time and you've testified on Friday that
there was a period of time when you lost
confidence in your two deputies now I
testified that the trust Factor had
taken a hit but that I had not lost
confidence in my two deputies if I had
lost confidence my two deputies I would
have taken a much more firm and direct
course of action okay and so you lost uh
trust and that must have been very some
level of trust sir thank you and that
must have been very hard for you I think
that's hard for anybody sir and you
decided that because you couldn't trust
them you needed to do certain things
yourself again just to correct it wasn't
because I could not trust them meaning I
had zero trust but yes I would have to
then take some course of action to deal
with that until efforts were made on all
parties to rebuild that trust and I
stated that efforts were made thank you
and you also didn't trust superintendent
Dunlop as the event Commander that they
had chosen sin no superintendent Dunlop
was still part of a review that was
going on for the panda games events and
it would not have been fair for him to
be in that position until that review
was completed and so several of your
most senior officers you had trust
issues with
I had a momentary trust issue with
deputy chief spell and Ferguson as a
result of the decision to put
superintendent Patterson sorry Dunlop
into the position of event Commander
without letting me know about it and
superintendent rayom you told us had
been replaced as event Commander by
superintendent Dunlop
and you indicated you were very angry
about that and you spoke to deputies
sorry I did not indicate any such thing
about my emotions sir okay uh you uh
were not pleased with that decision I
was concerned because I was not made
aware of the decision and you spoke to
deputy chief Bell and Ferguson about it
yes sir and then you consulted with them
about who should replace uh
superintendent uh Dunlop because you
said you didn't want him in the position
because it wasn't suitable for him to be
in the position given that he was still
under review yes sir uh but you did not
suggest putting superintendent rayon
back in as the event Commander I asked
them for their opinions his name was not
offered back to me okay so there's
another one of your superintendents that
you may have had some trusting no sir
that's not at all correct
um commissioner commissioner
thank you my friend Mr majakovsky has
more than one occasion this morning not
stated the witness's evidence correctly
and I would be grateful if if my friend
could could listen more closely and not
and not
suggested the evidence is something
other than it is
I'm I'm doing the best I can if I have
misstated a word please correct me I've
actually repeatedly misstated the words
so I appreciate it wait
I'm I'm gonna have to
interrupt I think you should be very
careful you have on a couple of
occasions done it it happens but please
be cautious I I will and I I'm not doing
it intentionally but there's a lot of
information and if I've gotten something
wrong and I haven't picked up on it
please do I certainly feel your pain
there's a lot of information
um you've also I believe
um told us about not wanting to give too
much information to the board because
you didn't entirely trust them to keep
things confidential again that's
incorrect sir
that's not what you said that's not what
I said you had concerns about sharing
certain information because of
confidentiality there were instances
where the board was documented in terms
board members were documented in terms
of leaking information service
information board information that
includes in-camera information
and we've also heard evidence about your
perception that there wasn't political
support to get the resources uh to you
and that they wanted to see you fail
I've talked about the concerns I had
from comments and actions by various
levels of government yes sir
and superintendent party you'll recall
from the opp testified that you told him
there were people in the ministry who
wanted you to fail and that you had
sources telling you that I'm sorry can
you repeat that please sir
superintendent
um
party from the opp testified that there
were people that you said at a meeting
he was at that there were people in the
ministry who wanted you to fail and that
you had sources telling you that it's
not exactly right but I was aware from
people in the ministry that had made
those suggestions over the course of my
tenure as chief of police and you
expressed that to um superintendent
party correct that's correct sir
and so I take it from that that there
were also people you could not trust in
the ministry no sir
that's not correct
um let's talk about the change in
Incident Commander from superintendent
uh rayon from to superintendent
um dunlaw and um I I want to begin by
talking about your comments about
superintendent uh dunlaw what I
understood you to say on Friday and
perhaps I've written it down uh
incorrectly was you did not want him in
the position because he had been The
Incident Commander in the panda game no
sir he was not The Incident Commander in
the panda game but he was the
superintendent overseeing actually the
acting deputy chief overseeing the area
that was responsible for event planning
and the event plan implementation on the
day of the panda game in 2021. my
understanding was that you referred to
him as The Incident Commander or the
event commander and so I've got that
wrong he was not The Incident Commander
and I don't know if there was a major
event Incident Commander or event
Commander but he was overseeing that
operation he was part of the briefings
in regard charge those operations he was
with me when we briefed board and
council members in regards to his
operations so he had a very active
involvement in the planning and the
overseeing of the implementation of that
plan my understanding was that The
Incident Commander of that was inspector
Michelle Mara and there was no event
Commander for that you have probably
more accurate information recollection
at this point than I did and in terms of
superintendent dunlop's experience I
understand that he had been the
logistics and Staffing lead in 2016 for
the North American leaders Summit and he
was a joint part of a joint planning and
Communications Group with the RCMP
he was also the lead planner in the past
for the presidential visit and was
extremely well qualified for the
position but that you had some personal
issues with him uh but first of all I'm
not aware of his CV so I can't comment
on the accuracy of it your last comment
I don't know where you've got that from
sir but that's not accurate and then
last but not least planning and
logistics for the panda game was not the
problem it was decisions made around
removing the ESU prior to that the time
where the traditional public order and
disorder issues took place and I still
at that point in January February of
2022 had not had a report back that that
explained why our public order were
removed prior to what we knew to be the
high risk period of the panda game
just he was just finishing his answers
planning and legit thank you sir
planning and Logistics had nothing to do
it it was an operational decision that
was made at some level to remove the
vast majority of our resources including
our public order resources literally at
the moment that the troubles would have
begun you're not disputing that he was
extremely well qualified for that
position of event coordinator I but he
was not an event coordinator for the uh
sorry if my question wasn't clear event
Commander for the protest
I don't know what a CV I didn't know at
that time what his CV was okay
um and you indicated that the event
Commander was changed you said on
February 1st 2022
that was your evidence on Friday that
was my understanding although I don't
know when the actual change took place
okay
um on Friday you said it was the first I
believe it was around the first but I
don't know the exact date and you
understand that deputy chief Ferguson
testified that superintendent rayon was
the event Commander until February 4th
in the evening
that was her evidence in her witness
statement and it was also her evidence
uh in the transcript I'm sorry did you
say that superintendent Rio was the
event Commander until the fourth until
February 4th in the evening that that
was her evidence that does not
um
that's not aligned to what I understood
and no one challenged that evidence when
she gave it you heard that correct I
don't recall any challenges and on the
institutional report that Ottawa Police
filed and that came in through her
evidence uh and that uh institutional
report had a chronology of dates and
said that uh Depp said that
superintendent rayon was the event
Commander up until February 4th and
nobody challenged that either I haven't
read that report sir
and you're aware that deputy chief
Ferguson testified that superintendent
rayon had asked for some time off on the
weekend which was the weekend of
February 5th and that's why she said he
had been replaced by superintendent
Dunlop my recollection is that Deputy
Ferguson told me somewhere around
February 1st that inspector Lucas and
asked for time off and that he was being
replaced to allow to go home apparently
all that information wasn't correct and
to this date I am still not sure what
happened between February 1st and
February 5th when I was finally made
aware that superintendent Dunlop was the
event Commander okay so you indicated on
Friday that you did not believe that
statement when she said that he had
asked for time off that weekend and
that's why he had been replaced again um
it's not a matter of belief my
recollection independent and to the
state is that inspector Lucas was asking
for time off somewhere around February
1st
acting Deputy Ferguson provided that
time off and replaced him with somebody
I wasn't sure who that was I assumed
that was a decision was just temporary
for 24 to 48 hours so I wasn't
particularly concerned about it I became
concerned about things on Saturday
February 5th when I kept asking for Who
The Incident Commander was event
Commander was and I was then told at the
end of that meeting on February 5th that
it was superintendent Dunlop but until
that time I had no understanding of that
sir
um can I ask um uh please Mr clerk to
turn up
Ops three zeros
14454 page 142
foreign
was the commander Chris whose notes were
these sorry these are the same notes
that we looked at before miss you knows
notes okay and what's the date for this
uh February 10th Chris rayon was the
commander
Chris rayom he needs time uh he need
time off decision to ask Jamie be there
on Friday Friday would be February 4th
uh on Saturday superintendent rayon
asked if Jamie uh that would be Jamie
Dunlop should just stay in their
decision to just keep thank you
I have no idea what the context of this
telephone call that miss you know had
with uh deputy chief Bell on February
10th so that does not those are not
notes that she was taking on my behalf
those are notes she was taking on her
behalf and I have no understanding of
the context and if that is correct
then what that would mean no it's not
correct sir from my understanding if
that was correct that's not correct from
my understanding if I could ask my
question please if it was correct that
would mean that on February 4th in the
evening
superintendent rayon was
um asked for time off and was given it
and superintendent Dunlop became the
event commander on the fifth if that was
correct then that would completely
discount the fact that superintendent
Dunlop presented himself on two
occasions on Thursday February 3rd to
present the public order unit subplan
that I had asked for and that acting
deputy chief Ferguson was responsible
for coordinating in her major incident
command role and so none of this makes
sense sir okay and what also doesn't
make sense if we could please turn
um up Ops three zeros uh one four four
eight four
uh page 10.
um so this is your uh typed note
um I don't know when you type those
notes
um but you'll see uh it uh I advise this
is on the February 5th in the morning
it's nine o'clock it says I advise that
I had only just officially heard that
superintendent Dunlop had replaced
inspector Lucas as The Incident
Commander at the previous briefing
deputy chief Bell advised he was the new
Incident Commander installed this week
that can't be accurate Mr slowly I
suggest because The Incident Commander
from the beginning of this event to the
end was inspector Lucas throughout
correct
What's Happening Here is there's an
interchange of terms between Incident
Commander and event Commander event
Commander is not of vernacular that I
was used to from my time in Toronto
Police Service we didn't have such a
designation but you'd like to you'd like
an explanation sir I'm trying to provide
that to you
so in terms of terminology already
doesn't make sense but I go back to it
on or around February 1st I believe it
was February 1st but I stand to be
corrected if there's other documentation
I was advised by acting deputy chief
Ferguson that inspector Lucas was tired
that he was involved in planning prior
to the arrival of the convoys had worked
through the weekend under intense
pressure that inspector Lucas needed
time off and that he was being replaced
I don't recall whether or not she told
me who he was being replaced by but I
accepted that then I was waiting for a
briefing from
staff sergeant Mike Stoll on the public
order unit plan that I requested on
February 1st
superintendent Dunlop showed up on
Thursday February 3rd on two separate
occasions presenting that plan and that
caused Great confusion for me and it
also meant that we couldn't actually get
the presentation when finally we started
talking about it again on February 5th I
was then told that superintendent Dunlop
had been The Incident Commander that's
my recollection and that's why I wrote
my notes as such and I've been replaced
had replaced inspector Lucas as The
Incident Commander and that's why I
wrote my notes as such these these are
not notes that you prepared at the time
of the decision these are
contemporaneous notes yes sir and I
suggest to you that you've got it wrong
there because what you were told on
February 5th in the morning was that
superintendent rayon had asked for some
time off no sir just you have to let me
finish Mr slowly and had been replaced
by a superintendent Dunlop and in your
notes you've written that it's inspector
Lucas who was replaced by superintendent
Dunlop as The Incident Commander thank
you for your statement you're inaccurate
that's not true
and so we are in agreement however that
inspector Lucas was never replaced
I'm still under the impression that he
took time off but I've heard his
testimony that he never had days off but
up until that point I was advised and
still believe that well I was advised
that inspector Lucas had requested time
off it turns out it was superintendent
real I stand corrected and you're asking
us to accept that for the period of
February 1st to February 5th you were
under a misapprehension of who the event
Commander was yes sir
if in fact the change was made on
February 4th in the evening
as we've heard from the evidence
that would mean you were uninformed from
the evening of the fourth until the
morning of the fifth correct no I was
uninformed from the first until the
fifth commissioner commissioner may I
interject the game forgive me please
my my I'm not trying to follow my
friends questions if this suggestion
that my friend is making to the
witnesses of the evidence before you
is that inspector rayon
left on the fourth then my friend should
recall that commission Council led the
evidence on Friday of Inspector rayon's
note
that showed that he was
placed as the I think an event commander
on
the evening of February 1st 1930 hours
commission Council LED that note from
inspector rayon this is quite proper
cross-examination if my friend wants to
raise that in re-examination he can
superintendent rayon was not called as a
witness two different notebooks from him
were put in we knew nothing about that
so my friend can certainly pursue that
in re-examination but I submit this is
proper cross-examination I'm not sure if
I may just may I just add one I'm
concerned about my time I'm I'm I'll be
very brief it's a matter of some
significance my friend cannot say on
behalf of the entity the Ops that he can
pick and choose through which notebook
he likes commission Council LED that
notebook my friend just has to take
account of it is all my my point is he's
not being fair to the witness thank you
um
well I think a lot of this is
re-examination if need be there is
conflicting material and I think given
the short timeline that we're we have
there's a certain amount of Liberty but
if you could as much as possible
put everything in context without
necessarily citing everything sure I
understand that you know that's the
narrative I'm challenging that narrative
and my friend is certainly open to
explore it but I'm going to move on from
that point
um you would agree with me that as the
major Incident Commander deputy chief
Ferguson operates at a strategic level
for the most part so yes and below her
would be inspector Lucas at the
operational level
nobody below her would be the event
Commander I'm sorry the event commander
and below the event Commander would be
inspector Lucas as the um operational at
the operational level
well
to get too far off track but then what
is the role of the event Commander okay
and strategy at the major Incident
Commander would be at a very high level
correct no sir okay and I don't see
anywhere in the record any instructions
that prohibited the major Incident
Commander from choosing who should be
the event commander who reports to her
and there are no instructions in that
regards and there certainly were no
instructions that I gave in that regard
either and it's her decision is it not
yes but as a strategy level uh contact
in the direct contact to me that I would
expect such decisions would be
communicated to me with an explanation
that I could understand in a timely
manner and when you raised it with her
on the fifth you in fact told her that
it was her decision to either keep
superintendent Dunlop in that role if
she wanted to yes and she'd be
accountable for it given that I'd raise
my concerns yes so obviously she had
that right to make a decision as to who
she she wanted as the event command yes
sir and I retain the right of chief of
police to make a decision if I felt that
it was going in the wrong direction but
you also warned her that she'd be
accountable for the decision to put
superintendent Dunlop into that position
I explicitly did so because it was such
an important decision to make yes sir
but it's implicit in everything and you
would agree with me that it's somewhat
of a threat that if things go wrong
you'll be blamed not so not at all it's
not a threat at all it's simply stating
that the facts this is an important
decision making we've just had an
important discussion we are in a
significant Public Safety crisis
decisions of this level are incredibly
important it's your decision but you'll
be accountable for it yes sir and um
that was on February 5th and at February
5th just in terms of what was going on
on the ground things were not going well
in the city of Ottawa Fair we were still
struggling to retain control yes right
and you were facing really unrelenting
criticism in the media and on social
media because people didn't understand
what the Ottawa Police were doing
the Ottawa Police Services facing on
relenting criticism and yes as chief of
police that would come with a title and
that was very intense pressure on you
was it not intense pressure on everyone
yes sir and it was intense on me and
what deputy chief Ferguson confirmed
with you was that in deciding who to
replace superintendent rayon with she
had consulted with her colleague who was
the deputy chief and was experienced in
the deputy chief role and you were
suspicious of deputy chief Bell for
having had a conversation with deputy
chief Ferguson about his thoughts on the
skill set required for to be the event
command sorry you just lost me there I'm
not quite sure what you're asking or
asserting sorry if my question had
multiple parts I'll try to break it up
um deputy chief you indicated uh that
you uh were on you did not support the
decision she had made
choose uh superintendent Dunlop correct
my first concern was that I wasn't
advised about it then I raised the
concern that he might not be appropriate
because he's still under a review
and you also
um uh she told you as did deputy chief
Bell that he had consulted with her
and suggested uh superintendent Dunlop
and you weren't happy about deputy chief
Bell
um giving his opinion to deputy chief
Ferguson quite the opposite I was clear
once I understood that it was deputy
chief Bell's suggestion or
recommendation to acting deputy chief
Ferguson I turned acting Deputy first
said you're the major Incident Commander
whoever made the suggestion is
irrelevant you've made that decision
it's on you to communicate that to me
and she doesn't have the ability to
consult with her colleague who's been in
the deputy chief role to say hey what do
you know about I never said anything to
that I just tried not talk over him and
if you could try and tighten your
questions a bit so I had no issues
whatsoever with acting deputy chief
Ferguson Consulting with deputy chief
Bell on that occasion or any other
occasion in fact I encouraged it
repeatedly
um and I suggest that on February 9th so
a couple days later now
um you were pretty concerned that you
would lose your job and be blamed for
what had happened absolutely not sir
okay and what you were looking for was
to blame somebody else absolutely not
sir okay um if we could please um turn
up Ops
14454 page 131
foreign
and if we could scroll down please
there's a meeting at 9 30 to 9 50
meeting with Chief Christian you know
and uh inspector Maloney your executive
officer
do you see that
yes sir okay and if we could scroll down
and so you'll see at the bottom of the
page
um oh sorry just go up a bit
if we just go up to the top Place Chief
out thank you
um double-sided incident command
question mark still don't have it Chief
outlines concerns over last week in the
event he is shipped out
I'm sorry I don't see that
uh double-sided incident command still
don't have it Chief outlines concerns
over last week in the event he is
shipped out
that indicates a concern you expressed
again about this incident of
superintendent Dunlop
again not not sure what double-sided
incident command question mark is that's
clearly The Scribe I guess this is
Christian you know herself not quite
sure what the point was so that's an
indication of some confusion on my
scribe
still don't have it I don't know what
that refers to Chief outlines concerns
over the last week that's definitely how
the meeting started in the event the
events you shipped out again that's her
interpretation of what's being said
um I can't speak to that and by February
14th I would suggest things were looking
very bad for you in terms of media
coverage and what was happening with the
opp and the RCMP
I'm sorry have we left this meeting now
we have okay thank you what was your
question um by February 14th now uh less
than a week later things were looking
even worse for you in terms of what the
media was reporting and what was
happening with OPP and the RCMP you were
under immense pressure
yes there was an incredible amount of
pressure yes sir
um if we could please
um call up Ops three zeros one four four
seven nine page 97.
and if we could just go to the bottom of
that page please
uh so these are deputy chief Ferguson's
uh uh notes advise Chief is looking for
emails to support I we purposely left
him out of the information loop on the
demo coming
if you go up to the next page
and then uh it ends
I'm sorry I did not see what you're
referring to before the page I apologize
advised Chief is looking for emails to
support we have purposely left him out
of the information loop on the demo
coming yeah and again if these are
acting Deputy Ferguson's notes I think I
said several times on Friday I can't
understand what why she was writing
these things and what was in her mind
but if that's her interpretation that is
her interpretation that certainly wasn't
my intention she said you were looking
for emails to uh
say that people intentionally left you
out I can see what she wrote I certainly
never gave those directions I never saw
emails for that purpose I completely
deny that assertion as I have before and
will continue to do so
[Applause]
and um thank you you can take that down
for the or you can keep it up for a
moment I may go back to it thank you
um you indicated uh that one of the
concerns you had about superintendent
Dunlop taking over as event commander on
Friday he said was he wasn't at the
February 1st meeting you had with the
POU so perhaps he wasn't even up to date
on everything that certainly would have
been a concern yes sir and a
superintendent rayon wasn't at that
February first meeting either was he no
he wasn't sir
and neither was inspector Lucas at the
February first meeting but they were
assigned roles within the major incident
command structure and would have been
properly briefed by all the members
there
and I understand uh from superintendent
dunlop's note that in fact he met with
the POU group on the following day on
February 2nd you have no reason to
disagree with that I have no reason to
know why he would have met with the POU
group because he wasn't part of the
incident command team he was overseeing
investigations so that's confusing on
its face and I understand on February
3rd the following day there was a Pou
update
that superintendent Dunlop attended with
you and the two deputies at 10 15 that
morning at which the three uh options
were presented yes and commissioner I
just want to be clear
superintendent Dunlop had no functional
role in the incident command system on
February 1st second third fourth I only
became aware of his involvement on the
fifth this Saturday
my understanding on the February 1st
meeting in Canada with the public order
unit officers was that I had invited the
major Incident Commander acting deputy
chief Ferguson The Incident Commander
inspector Lucas and the public order
Commander ESU Commander staff sergeant
Mike Stoll there were a number of other
people who were there who were within
the incident command system PLT members
external public order unit commanders
everybody that should have been there
was there with the exception of
Inspector Lucas who said he could not be
there I don't have a reference as to why
superintendent rione wasn't there okay
Mike but superintendent Dunlop had no
functional role to play Within the
incident command system on the Tuesday
the Wednesday the Thursday I will
concede at some point in that period he
was substituted in for Chris realm I
still don't know fully why or when but
he should not have been at any of those
other meetings and he was and that was
very confusing because he had no
functional role to play in those
meetings and you recognize the
importance of communicating and
messaging correct that's an important uh
obligation that you have as a chief and
it's important uh that you communicate
appropriately both in the service and
externally to the service correct yes
sir and in that regard you retained a
company called navigator to Proto
provide strategic Communications and
issues management advice related to the
freedom Convoy from January 30th they
were they were procured to support the
Ottawa Police Service and the Ottawa
Police Services Board yes sir and so we
know they provided services to you a
little bit to uh chair Deans as well
during that period from January 30th to
February 15th Navigator was procured by
the audible Police Service for services
to the audible Police Service and the
audible Police Services Board in fact
they even prepared a report for you on
what your reputation was they prepared
they prepared General reports that
covered a range of topics including
General Trust of the Ottawa Police
Service and yes they broke it down in
some cases to assess trust in in the in
the chief of police
um and there was a specific report
actually about your reputation I can't
recall exactly but I'm sure it did come
up in reports
um uh if we could please have Ops four
zeros 8402
you'll see that is a reputation audit
performed
of relevant media social media and
political commentary relating to Chief
slowly's reputation across uh local
media National media and social media
you reviewed that report I assume
I don't recall there were lots of
reports that came across my desker what
you say and how you say things can be
very important correct yes sir
and my understanding is Ops spent 185
000 on Navigator providing communication
advice for the period of January 30th to
February 15th uh most of it related to
um meetings and with you correct that's
not correct sir if we could please turn
up Ops
uh three zeros one four nine three four
commissioner
forgive me again I understand that this
document was loaded into the party
database only
last evening it may be wrong my friend
will know but it's it's a document
obviously that we have first learned
about minutes ago when our friends
emailed to say they were going to put
this document it's my respectful
submission not appropriate to put to the
witness for the first time in
cross-examination uh I haven't even
myself had a chance to look at it
um in In fairness
um the question of Navigator was
certainly something that was raised
throughout the commission asked us for
the invoice we actually provided the
invoice to the commission Yesterday When
I Was preparing I uh discovered that for
some reason it was not on the database
although certainly the commission had it
and there were many questions asked
about Navigator uh of many of the
witnesses so I don't see any unfairness
in it well I think let's see where it
goes first and give him some time if he
needs it but I at the moment I'm I don't
see a problem this is
a document that would have been
available certainly to
to him when he was Chief but that can
certainly be asked and if he's not
familiar he can take the time to review
it thanks and so if you'll just see on
the first page uh please if you could
scroll down you'll see the uh total bill
to keep strolling
it was 185 and you'll see from the
invoice that it covers January 30th to
February 15th you heard deputy chief
Bell say that he stopped using them when
he became acting Chief interim Chief
correct yes sir
um I want to talk so navigation
Navigator provides communication advice
um deputy chief Ferguson has in her
notes on page 67 and I can turn it up if
you want but I suspect you may remember
this that during the meeting on February
9th you said twice that you will crush
anyone who undermines the operation and
she said your chin was twitching when
you said it
I use the term crush and that was an
inappropriate term at a very stressful
meeting but yes sir
and Miss uh hyuno recorded that in her
notes as well and you would agree with
me
that when you say no changes can be made
and you will crush anyone what your
command team would understand from that
is you better not disagree with me not
at all sir I was actually very explicit
after that and miss you know's notes
talks about the context of That explicit
context around no changes the notes are
very clear there's no changes to the
Strategic Direction the framework the
changing of major positions within the
incident command team it was not set as
a blanket statement that there could not
be any operational tactical or even
strategic changes but that we were to
communicate carefully we were to act as
a committed and coordinated team and
demonstrate that continuously going
forward in fact what the notes say is no
changes can be made to the command team
unless you approve it which notes are
you referring to Sir deputy chief
Ferguson well I I haven't seen it you
need to put that up on the screen and I
can test Deputy Ferguson's
interpretations of my comments on many
occasions unfortunately she seems to
have taken her own interpretation and
great liberties with those
interpretations on a regular basis and
I've stated that in my evidence in Chief
and superintendent Abrams testified from
the opp
and you recall that the opp had an
inspector Don Ferguson who was working
with the Ottawa Police sorry you
confused me what question are you asking
sure I'm moving on I'm asking you
something else we're talking about
communication you recall superintendent
Abrams testified
yes he testified and you recall that
there was reference to an inspector Don
Ferguson who was an opp officer who was
working with the Ops
vaguely okay
and um superintendent Abrams uh Records
that at 10 o'clock you went on a rampage
uh was reported to him by inspector
Ferguson and we're making unrealistic
demands of sorry staff my recollection
is that inspector Ferguson heard from
somebody who described me as going as a
rampage so this would be fourth or fifth
hand information that's my recollection
sir and it says that you went on a
rampage and we're making unrealistic
demands of your command staff and their
partner agencies you don't agree with
that I don't agree with what was told to
inspector Ferguson I don't agree how he
related that to superintendent Abrams
and I certainly don't agree with how
superintendent Abrams would relate third
and fourth hand information in official
channels to a partner agency as
important as the opp I think that's all
very unfortunate and very untrue and um
deputy chief Ferguson also records a
meeting on February 9th where you got
angry and spoke of the conspiracy and
told you it was all political you
remember that I'm sorry again sir could
you pull up those notes
she uh do you remember that again I
don't even know what day you're on right
now I said February 9th
yes uh that you spoke of the conspiracy
and told her it was all political in
what meeting sir um if we could please
turn up Ops three zeros one four four
seven nine
thank you
foreign
oh I'm sorry I didn't give you the page
um page um 67.
the last bullet
or uh you can actually go above
uh talked about the plan for briefing
the embedded cell of planners and
commanders and if you could keep
scrolling down please and he spoke of a
type of conspiracy that is happening at
provincial and federal levels and that
this team is being handled by their
political Masters and promoted the idea
that they're not really there to help uh
advise that they were asking us not to
bring the Paul I advise that they were
asking us not to bring the politics into
our operations he got angry and told me
this was all political
again I'm sorry but I'm just amazed at
the amount of Liberties that an acting
deputy chief a superintendent relatively
newly promoted superintendent would take
in terms of interpreting my intentions
but none of this is accurate uh well
she's saying that that's what you said
and you were angry and nobody else made
notations of that so she seems to be the
only one making those interpretations
and on the same page if we go to the top
of the page please
it said this that morning
you called them all into the office
after the morning briefing present where
the chief deputy chief Bell CAO uh
dunker is it
um Kevin Maloney and Christian you know
and myself
and the chief began by saying he
floundered last week and that was we
floundered sir that's not he floundered
we floundered uh last week
I read that as an H but I'm sure there's
a w underneath it but perhaps I've
misread it and because we switched
Riders part way through indicating the
switch between rayon and dunlaw to
Patterson
so now uh the chief and the team will
not change any of the players until the
operation is over
and so again you raise this issue about
the switch in event Commanders
you now uh are not referring to
inspector Lucas anymore you've sorted
that out I believe we'll sorted out a
lot of things in that time frame sir
and the people that you accused were
deputy chief under accuse anybody sir
you spoke about what had happened the
previous week uh
in which deputy chief Ferguson in
consultation with deputy chief Bell had
replaced the event commander and you had
that discussion in front of their
colleagues I think um
the term we is used throughout this
sentence there was no finger pointing or
blaming you're applying your own
interpretation sir which I completely
disagree with
and on the same day you have a
presentation to the opp
and deputy chief Ferguson
said
that you are hostile when they asked
questions
I don't have any statement that says
deputy chief Ferguson said that if you'd
like to pull it up I'd be happy to see
it
um the notes are in the record that's
fine
superintendent uh Abrams uh was also at
that meeting
and his notes say and I'm happy to turn
them up if you want that you became very
Stern with him
please please show me the statement
you keep reference statements and then
you say they're in the record or you'd
be happy to put them up if you're going
to reference the statement sir please
put it on the screen for me um well I'm
trying to save time
um but I need to see the statements
please let me control the proceeding
sorry commissioner
um so if you're if you're going to
reference a
a comment in the record you should
either ask him to confirm it
if he doesn't want to kind of confirm it
or deny it until he sees it then you
have to take it to him but you can't
it's not useful to just say there is
this in the record I appreciate it given
the time and constraints I'm trying to
do it but I will call it up it is uh OPP
four zeros oh seven seven four
[Applause]
foreign
ly
um or fortunately for everyone I have
not noted the I've noted what line it is
but I haven't noted the page in my notes
so I won't take you to that I apologize
um what he indicates and you can tell me
if you um agree or disagree or you don't
remember
is that you became Stern with him during
that meeting and you became heated again
I have no recollection of Mr Abrams
statements here unless you can show it
to me and it's not excuse me he's not
asking you about the statement he's just
asking you if you recall and whether you
agree or disagree I don't recall the
statement by Mr Abrams
that's the meeting in his will say
statement
um as the overall tone of the meeting
was somewhat unprofessional and
disrespectful you heard that evidence I
do recall Mr party's Evans yes sir
and you obviously don't agree with that
either I can understand why he would see
that from his perspective but I said in
evidence in Chief that this was a
critically important issue the
resourcing and that we were discussing
things that had affected the resourcing
and politics was one of them and so yes
I could understand it became a very
tense moment in the meeting and the
following day
uh February 10th
um there was an issue that arose about
the Rideau Sussex operation that had was
supposed to have been the subject of a
Pou operation the previous night do you
recall that yes sir and that had
ultimately been called off because
superintendent Burnett was of the view
that it was too dangerous I believe that
was his decision I don't know all the
reasons behind it I'd heard dangerous
I'd heard resources but it was called
off yes sir
and if we could please turn up Ops uh
three zeros one four four seven nine
page 74.
and if we could go down to the bottom of
the page the last paragraph
there's a let me read to you uh
if we could go up a little bit
okay I advised uh this is Deputy Chief
Ferguson I fundamentally did not agree
with the approach the concern was about
the use of plts correct
I don't know what she's referencing I'll
continue reading that they were not
allowed negotiations to take place they
didn't give them the opportunity to
negotiate fairly I told them that our
policing Partners have huge concern with
the way things are running and I don't
believe we are listening to them if we
can scroll down please I advise the opp
are horrified with the Rideau Sussex
plan and that both Dave Springer's
information was incorporated into Paul
Paul being Paul Burnett's decision Chief
asked who we should have in to be Pou
Incident Commander and I asked for Dave
Springer at that point
um Mark Patterson said Dave Springer an
inspector came into my office this
morning and told me what I should be
doing that he wasn't actually there the
chief responded by saying if he did that
he would cut off Dave Springer's nuts
and call his boss and it goes on and I
don't recall do you remember the rest of
the statement you made I don't even
recall that incident sir okay so it you
don't recall it or it didn't happen
I don't recall the combination of things
that she's talking about singer sir and
you don't recall saying that you'll cut
off Dave Springer's nuts and use them as
bookends and use them as bookends
no sir I don't recall saying that
I don't think I've ever said anything
like that
um I want to move on and um
you would agree with me though I think
you said communication is very important
yes sir
I want to talk about
um the plts
inspector Lucas was The Incident
Commander and expressed The View
that plts should be a negotiating team
and de-escalating as many issues as
possible and that Pou as a tactical
resolution should be the last step
sentence part to Lucas you're referring
to yes
again I don't have a clear recollection
of that but I don't have any reason to
that is your memory
of his position I think that's what his
testimony was here okay and he explained
in his witness statement that it was
made clear to him after the first
weekend that you interfered with his
efforts to use the PLT to shrink the
footprint of the protesters and that
both he and superintendent realm the
event Commander at the time supported
efforts to remove the protesters from
the Rito Sussex intersection
and that it was made clear to him that
superintendent rayom lacked the
authority to do this and the chief's
approval was needed
you remember that evidence
that was a lot of information there I'll
just be very clear and I've said it
again
in my evidence I never gave any
direction regards to PLT at any level
with the exception that PLT were
critically important to all of our
operations in this I did everything I
could repeatedly and demonstrably to
support them including bringing the PLT
commanders to the February 1st meeting
with Pou so I will say it again sir I
have no idea where this Narrative of I
did not support would not allow and had
to approve PLT actions the only evidence
I've heard so far is that someone
assumes that that was my position I gave
no such Direction at any time during my
tenure as Chief and at no time during
the entire events of the Convoy
and superintendent so you disagree with
superintendent uh or uh superintendent
Lucas sorry I disagree with his entire
assertion that I had some position
against the PLT and gave some direction
that required my approval for any PLT
related action and you disagree because
superintendent Abrams was also very
clear in his evidence on that point so
you disagree with that superintendent
Abrams was very clear that he got his
information third and fourth hand from
sources that he never names as part of a
rumor-mongering Mill and deputy chief
Ferguson also noted fundamental
disagreements with you on the role of
plts and yet Deputy Ferguson never
points to any direction that I gave to
that
um if we could um turn to up Ops
four zeros five six three one please
that's the February first Pou beating
uh that you attended if you could just
scroll down a bit please uh you'll see
the discussion point is PLT would like
one more attempt to speak with every
Convoy to get them on the same page
truckers need to clear all the roads and
stop honking in exchange for fuel and a
place to park have zero room to
negotiate if they don't deal with it
this way they will be removed that was
the position you were espousing
I'm sorry sir but this is a meeting with
some 25 people in the room there is
absolutely no attribution to who said
anything on this document other than
meeting with the chief and the chief
wants something in writing within 72
hours I don't know who made those
statements sir and I said that in my
evidence in Chief
okay
um the opportunity to shrink the
footprint by not getting the group at
Guido Sussex to move came up uh yet
again on February 9th
and if we could please go to Ops 409573
at page two
at the bottom you will see that there is
um
at the bottom of the email chain
superintendent uh Burnett is emailing
superintendent clatterson uh and he says
at the end he's talking about a possible
move of the Rito Sussex
and he says look although it may not be
the desired outcome it can assist in
bringing an overall resolution to uh the
incident
sorry this is a long email I need to
read through this from top to bottom to
understand the point well so you'll see
at the bottom he said you know the
various options again I'm sorry I'm
going to need to see the emails okay on
that because I'm running out of time
um so
I'll I'll uh that's fine you don't
recall this discussion I don't even know
what the discussion is about Sir okay
and I'm going to suggest to you
um that that information was forwarded
to you as chief
and you said we'll discuss it anymore
sir I don't know what the information is
if you'd give me the chance to read
through this email I can give you an
answer but unless I can read through
this long email I don't know what point
you're trying to make and so I won't
agree to it or disagree with it okay I'm
going to move on
um and uh come back to the subject of
Navigator who was hired to provide you
with some advice yeah Navigator again
sir please stop putting words in my
mouth Navigator was hired by the audible
Police Service in consultation with the
Ottawa Police Services Board to support
both the Ottawa Police Service and the
Ottawa Police Services Board and if the
function of the office of Chief happens
to be a function of the audible Police
Service if we could please churn up Ops
14454 page 24
foreign
on February 2nd uh called next steps
meeting Ops and Navigator present were
uh Christianity you know the chief John
Steinbach who is a Communications uh
person in Ops he's the executive
director of strategy and Communications
yes sir Aaron Kelly Matthew barrier
Jamie watt Amanda Galbraith the last uh
four names are from Navigator correct no
they're not sir
um one of them is from ASI yes that's
correct that's the other company that
was doing social media uh scrolling for
you I don't think I would call it that
but there were a company that was that
was provided to us that have Kit had
capabilities in open source information
yes
um and none of your command team are
present at that meeting correct
well yes John steinbach's
okay
he wasn't involved in the actual
operation though was he yes he was he
provided Communications daily
communication support to the incident
command system okay and so this is
February 2nd you've had just to situate
you in time you've had a meeting with
the POU the previous day that's correct
sir
and um you'll see on page 25
following page
I keep scrolling please
PS that's Peter slowly
you ask them the question so you've just
had the POU meeting the previous day
what do we need to do more more arrests
tickets use of force then what go to the
politicians go into big lockdown mode
massive show of police presence and then
hold hands and come together or two
bigger lockdown of City for weekends
and then you'll see Aaron at the bottom
Aaron is from Navigator or ASI ASI sir
um
job is to keep the peace and keep People
Protected when you take a hard line
citizens of Ottawa want this but not
everyone need to acknowledge not
everyone
uh
represents or resonates as Fringe group
this is a national problem and prime
minister needs to get us out of it
Jamie Jamie is also from Navigator
Jamie is yes people want to do our job
when does that begin and end when is the
chief's responsibility starts and end
um and it then goes on and then you'll
see at the bottom
uh Aaron Aaron is uh also uh from
Navigator or ASI Aaron is from ASI uh we
need to be honest but the chief will uh
lose the trust of people if the
messaging exaggerated and she then says
they need to go out and lay charges but
that may not be enough two-pronged
approach will lay charges and we'll do
what we can and secondly but also
recognizes it may not be enough
and um I believe that it then goes on
Aaron says that you needed a
communication strategy to show that this
is beyond
Ottawa you remember that
do you have that in the notes sir 27.
uh you'll see just at the top we need a
communication if you scroll up you'll
see she says we need a communication
strategy to show this is beyond Ottawa
that refresh your memory I'm sorry I'm
just trying to find okay thank you
um
does that refresh your memory that
meeting
the notes refresh my memory but well the
notes are the notes I don't have an
independent direction of it but the
notes through the notes
um
page 29
is February 3rd so that's the next day
and um
on page
30. again it's another meeting with uh
ASI and Navigator sorry can you scroll
back up again please
follow up again
Aaron Jamie Matthew Chief John uh Amanda
and Christiana you know correct
yes thank you page 30.
uh Aaron uh top of the are we at the top
of the page please
let's just um
Aaron says at that meeting that the your
line there may not be a police solution
which is what you delivered at the press
conference the previous day after your
Navigator meeting might have come too
soon
and then you'll see
um I wonder if you could shrink it a bit
just so I can find the reference to
Matthew on that page
if you could shrink it a bit please
uh so I could see more of the page
please you'll see Aaron this might not
be a policing solution anger against Ops
has come down
they're the ones who came up with this
might not be a policing solution correct
not at all sir okay and if we could just
um
uh Matthew
plan for today Matthew's from Navigator
or ASI uh he's
he's from Navigator I believe plan for
today show you are doing everything in
your power need Creative Solutions cut
off something riot gear police uh
can't read that word floodlights all
night uh tickets
uh stickers for residents
tactics we are trying to do is that it
looks like we are doing everything
possible to resolve this
do you recall that meeting then I recall
the meeting sir
and um do you recall um I'll just um
there had been a discussion on February
3rd with you and the about the POU
options of hard medium and soft tactics
correct sorry the meeting on February
3rd there were two such meetings both of
them had to be ended because the people
who were supposed to be there and the
information that was supposed to be
provided were not available that meeting
was actually held on the afternoon of
February 5th and hard means Tactical
soft as negotiation and medium is
somewhere in between no sir in any
option there will always be an effort of
de-escalation mediation communication
engagement
Ops if we could please turn up Ops 14479
page 32
and just to situate you this is February
3rd
and you'll see a discussion uh Chief
hard medium soft options for each
approach
and then if you go to page 36
scroll down please
so there was this discussion about
Navigator sorry is this in the same
meeting
this is with respect to navigator but
are we I don't know what meeting we're
in right now February 3rd
that's the date what meeting are we in
February 3rd you've just had a meeting
with Navigator and you've also had a
meeting with um deputy chief Ferguson
and others in fact you told us you had
two I'm sorry sir can you can you scroll
up I I don't know there's a navigator
reference but I'm trying to figure out
what media well I haven't asked you the
question yet no he's asking what meeting
this is that the notes of it's if that's
why I gave you the previous page was
February 3rd meeting if you just want to
go back up to the previous page
you update okay
so I meant I'm at a 10 15 meeting in
regards to the POU update okay
and then on page uh the following page
and we saw
um just keep it there we saw elsewhere
the notes of the meeting of February 3rd
with Navigator
but these are not I'm confused I haven't
asked you the question yet okay question
we saw that you went to a meeting on
with navigator on February 2nd and
February 3rd and you talked about
options
do you remember that
I was getting Communications advice yes
we talked about options getting
Communications advice and you talked
about hard medium soft not with
Navigator
okay
and they talked about enforcement
tactics
and the consequences no sir okay
uh you don't agree okay and if we could
please go to Ops one four four uh three
zeros one four four seven nine
this is one four four seven nine yeah
I'm sorry page 97 now
uh the
s uh the seventh line
uh the first the that bullet in the last
several this is Deputy Chief Ferguson in
the last several weeks there have been
daily Navigator prep meetings for
command I have begun to decline them
because I believe it has begun to drive
our operations and influence the chief's
decision around things like enforcement
which has we know has been putting our
officers at risk for safety reasons what
date is it sir
um if you can just um
uh go backwards you'll see the date
February 14th
so she's talking about the last several
weeks what's been happening and you
don't agree with that either well what
I'm concerned about is that my acting
deputy chief in charge of uh who's a
major incident command would have any
reservations that weren't shared with me
I don't recall any time that acting
Deputy Ferguson came to me and shared
those concerns and that would have been
an expectation of me of her and one of
the messages we saw that you were
getting from Navigator was the need to
emphasize enforcement efforts of the
police to let them know that the police
were not letting people break the law
and get away with it
I think that was what we were hearing
almost universally at that point sir
on Friday I want to move on
um
to talk about some evidence he gave on
Friday you said that the two Deputy
chiefs were responsible for lost time as
a result of the decision to replace
superintendent rayon with superintendent
Dunlop no sir and again you're putting
words in my mouth and I don't appreciate
it what I said that we had lost time the
churn of the different event commanders
moving in and out
and if there was a problem with how the
pre-arrival intelligence was analyzed
you're suggesting it was the fault of
deputy chief Bell again I made no such
assertion you keep making it sir and I
disagree with it okay and even if he
didn't get the hand in reports and you
did
I'm sorry I don't understand the points
you're making
um and you told us sorry I don't
understand the points you're making I'll
move on well I'd like to respond to it
um deputy chief Ferguson oversaw the
intelligence information and
investigative directorates
several of his members within there were
receiving the handy reports from the
very first time the Henry reports came
out he was responsible and assigned to
oversee the intelligence threat risk
assessment that would inform all the
operational plans going forward whether
or not deputy chief Bell received
reports as a material to me as long as
he had an understanding that
intelligence was coming in from
appropriate sources was being reviewed
appropriately and provided an
appropriate timely manner to acting
deputy chief Ferguson for the
operational plans that was my only
concern
and the project Hydra plan was something
actually that was uh Navigator and Asi
came up with absolutely not so I should
disregard that if that's what the notes
say there's a note around the naming of
it the plan itself is a concept of
operations that I brought to the team
that morning and laid it out in an
eight-point structure yes and you said
that if people on your command team had
concerns about your project hydroplan
you would have expected them to raise it
correct you recall saying that in what
meeting sir that's what you said on
Friday if anybody on your command team
had concerns about your project
hydroplan you said you would have
expected them to raise it
that was your evidence on Friday
about the the eight point structure yes
and we had probably a two-hour meeting
well a one-hour meeting to that function
okay and even though you had just said
you would crush anyone who did not agree
again to be very clear the notes that my
that Christian you know took talked
about not disagreements with every
aspect but the overall structure the
these the move removal of significant
leadership within the incident command
it was not a blanket statement and in
fact the entire meeting on the Friday
sorry now I'm confused about the dates
and times
the meeting where Hydra came up was the
February 9th I believe
yes February 9th the morning was an open
planning session with the incident
command team all of the of the com of
the executive team in the room to get a
round table effort to pull that plan to
the highest level possible before the 12
o'clock meeting with the opp and the
RCMP and if you didn't succeed in
resolving the demonstration it was
because the ministry wanted you to fail
and delayed in sending you resources
I'm sorry what's the question
I'm asking if you agree with that that
was a statement are you asking me a
question do you agree with that no I
don't sir not at all
and if the opp superintendent reported
that he heard you tell your commanders
to say they want to double the actual
number of resources they needed he
misunderstood that he misunderstood and
he also misrepresented it to his Command
Staff and if David White the city
solicitors said that the police told him
that there wasn't a public safety
concern on January 3rd after his phone
call with you he's got that wrong too I
don't understand the context of what you
just said sir okay well you testified as
on that on Friday you said that did not
reflect your view and he's got it wrong
again I'm just trying to get clarity you
keep jumping around dates and I don't
know what dates you're on and what
meeting I'm supposed to have said that
thing and so if we go to sorry I need to
understand the point you were making
around Mr White
if we go to Ott
3029695
it's a meeting from David White
about his call with uh you
he says I just got off a call with Chief
slowly this is January 30th and if you
go to page two
he talks about uh you you were taken to
this document I believe on Friday and
then he concludes by saying frankly I
was left with the impression that the
chief is looking for an opportunity to
say that the city denied Ops a tool and
they cannot be blamed for any public
criticism of the police handling of the
protest it's an alarming assertion made
by the by the council for the city and
absolutely incorrect okay so you
wouldn't agree with that either no sir
and many of the Ops officers who
testified here said you didn't properly
follow the incident command system and
insisted on approving every operational
or tactical decision and that's wrong as
well correct I don't know about many sir
again I've I've heard that
Ottawa Police commanders heard from
somebody and assumed things but I
haven't heard a single out of a police
service Commander say that they received
a direction from me directly or received
an email with a direction from me to any
of that that much is absolutely clear
everything asserted about me has come
through a rumor or something that went
around the station that's the only thing
that I've heard so far in the testimony
um commissioner if I might just have a
couple of extra minutes I'm just
finishing up sure thank you very much
um
February 14th was your last full day as
the chief correct the next day you
concluded an agreement uh with chair
Deans I had a full eight hour day on
February 15th sir
um February 15th you concluded an
agreement with Chief uh with um chair
Deans correct that's correct sir and I'm
not asking you the amount of the payment
but you concluded an agreement in which
you negotiated a payment from the board
and then resigned correct that concluded
an agreement with the board for my
separation from the organization yes sir
um and in fact you'd been thinking about
resigning for a while not at all sir
okay so if that appears uh in writing
somewhere attributed to you that's
incorrect
if you'd like to show me it I'd be happy
to give you an assessment of it
um
if we could please turn to even a tweet
I wouldn't know about it if we could
please turn
um to Ops
three zeros one four four seven nine
page 93
foreign
this you'll see is on February 14th so
the day before
and um you'll see that one of the things
if you um scroll down please
yeah at nine o'clock command call Chief
finished with we succeed as a team or we
go down as one
did you say that
I don't recall seeing it but that just
sounds like a good old team kind of
rah-rah talk
together let's get through this together
and if we could please then go to uh
ops14566
Page Six
these are the Scribe notes of Vicki
Nelson
uh
uh who was your scribe
and if we could please go to page six
this is February 14th
if you if you could keep going down
please the last three bullets
thank you
this is you Ops has a long-standing
incident command system we can do
candidate they vary but then when
there's something that's longer the
incident commanders don't have the base
of level of expertise to drawn when we
get something we don't expect we don't
act well at the onset we didn't have
Core group of senior commanders who have
the skill sets we needed which caused me
to go through the different levels of
management and if you could please go up
to the next page
the third area to discuss this is your
discussion with chair Deans some people
Church persons took the opportunity to
use this for their personal agendas
which were not aligned to the mission
and objectives I can absolutely prove
that significant changes were made to
the command team which was withheld from
my knowledge for days which caused us to
miss opportunities this includes acts by
both D.C Bell and the acting deputy
chief Ferguson do I have evidence to
prove it was deliberate misconduct no I
don't have that evidence at this time
but it's all formally documented if
needed
um cannot and will not blame on this
entirely on these members but it has
affected the outcome
and so although you um said if you
succeed as a team it's as a team effort
and if you fail it's as a team effort
and I guess uh deputy chief Mr slowly I
apologize you would say that I guess you
failed as a leader then
so you're making a whole bunch of jumps
around here I gave I sorry you'd like me
to answer your question or your
assertion no uh please go ahead thank
you so much
so every day in some way or the other I
made comments around team and I used a
variety of terms that are familiar to me
um so yes I would make that I was asked
a direct question by the chair of the
Police Services Board if we encountered
any problems and I gave her a good
answer a full answer and that answer is
consistent with my evidence and my
statements that I've produced and the
interviews that I've had with commission
Council and finally
um we saw a number of text messages
between the police and City officials
between the police and other police
services we've seen text messages from
the opp commissioner Carrick with you
um those were provided by the OPP you
did not provide any text messages
correct
I'm not sure what was requested of
disclosure on May 26 uh 2022 a
representative of Ops provided you with
the USB stick of record of your records
from your emails and at that meeting you
returned your phone to her do you
remember
that
sorry for giving her back your uh Ops
phone
who's the person sorry you just got me
do you remember somebody bringing you a
USB key
and you uh with all of your emails the
Ottawa Police Service provided an amount
of information to allow me to prepare
for the commission yes sir at the time
you then returned your cell phone yes
that's correct sir correct and all of
your texts had been wiped off the phone
had been wiped yes sir
and so we don't have any of the texts
that you exchange except to the extent
they've been produced by other parties
no sir that's actually not correct I
handed in my phone the day of my
resignation to the IT services I asked
for it back after so I would have a time
to communicate with people until I could
get a new phone and there are no uh text
messages that we had provided the I.T
Department could have and should have
secured whatever content was on that
phone sir
my understanding is they were white no
they weren't sure when I handed in my
phone it was a complete phone that had
all my passwords they had it for I think
several days before I asked for it to
come back to me that was the opportunity
for the Ottawa Police Service to
retrieve any information on that phone
and as far as I know they should have
had all that in their archives anyway
uh thank you very much Mr Solly I
appreciate your answers thank you thank
you sir okay thank you
you have
to help me
that's fine
um
we can move on to the Convoy organizers
if you'd like to start and do sort of 15
minutes or half hour
um I think that probably is best
but if it is a problem then we can take
the morning break now
I was afraid of that okay
shouldn't have given you the option uh
my problem okay well we're going to take
the morning break for 15 minutes and
we'll uh
come back with the convoir organizers
then
the commission is in recess for 15
minutes
thank you
forward
um
thank you
order a lot
the commission is reconvened
okay
good morning sir for the record my name
is Brendan Miller I'm counsel to Freedom
Corp which is an enemy that represents
the protesters that were in your city in
January and February of 2022. can you
just speak up a bit please and first uh
thank you for your service and uh
sorry for all the things you've had to
go through since everything that's
happened to you it doesn't seem fair to
me
but I just want to get into asking you
some questions about
some of the things you gave evidence
about
I've read the transcript that I wasn't
here on Friday but you described the
issue with respect to the protesters as
assaultive behavior and I just want to
clarify by that I take it you don't mean
actual physical assaults under the
criminal code do you
uh two things thank you for your
questions two things
um and I may have been guilty of it
myself and chief the pejorative term the
protesters the Convoy
it's not accurate there were
an amorphous group of individuals
collectives convoys that
in totality could be described as the
protesters the occupiers but they were
by no means unified in their mind or
their intentions or their actions
secondly yes I used the term assaultive
in the broadest case possible about its
way possible it is my understanding that
there was criminal code assault of
behavior by individuals in and around
the protest areas of the city but I
can't tell you that they were
specifically a part of one Convoy or
specifically a part of some group that
had clearly established themselves as a
major if not a dominant Factor but there
was criminal cold criminal code level
Assad assaultive threatening
behavior that became the subject of
criminal investigations I don't know the
status of those investigations okay and
it's fair to say though that though the
Ops wasn't enforcing things for broken
windows or anything like that
that of course if there was a physical
assault in downtown Ottawa no matter
that the protesters were there that
incident would be investigated and
charges would be laid where appropriate
right yes sir that would be my
understanding nobody from the Ops held
off and wasn't enforcing the criminal
code they still were doing it in full
force in effect is that fair they were
with the caveat again that officers had
maximum discretion
to assess whether or not a there was a
need to make an actual arrest
B whether or not that arrest would cause
an escalation in public safety issues
for the public for those participating
in demonstration including the officers
and other members themselves but there
was an expectation that they would still
capture the evidence necessary and if
possible Pursuit charges by law
provincial or criminal federal statute
at a later appropriate time right and
would it surprise you to know it's
already an evidence that in the time
period between the start of the protest
and when the invocation of the
emergencies that came about there was a
total of five charges for assault in
total
I don't know the statistics sir thank
you
um so the second thing I want to talk to
you about is the barricades that went up
uh when the protests arrived and I just
want to get some clarification on that
from you I understand that the city put
up the cement barricades or uh whatever
they they have a term for the type of
barricade but they put up the cement
barricades where the vehicles were
parked
basically in the first few days and that
those barricades essentially would
prevent any other vehicles from getting
into where they were parked on the
roadways or from leaving is that fair
um again my understanding is there may
have been cement barricades used to
close or redirect uh traffic routes even
in advance of the convoys coming in
certainly I think as a general statement
once the the quote-unquote red zones
were established that those red zones
were largely demarked by barriers
barricades I believe in the first
weekend there was a combination of
different types of barricade usage
including the use of city-owned vehicles
at some locations and there were points
along the Red Zone where there might
have been a police vehicle and police
officers
either alone or in combination with a
variety of barriers and barricades right
because this commission has already
heard some evidence and even from the
the incident Response Group reports that
individual protesters with vehicles were
wanting to leave but couldn't because
they were barricaded in do you hear
about that
I don't recall the specifics I do know
that there were on two levels it would
have been difficult to navigate through
what had been established after the
first weekend and that would require
some level of communication and
assistance
um but that there were several occasions
throughout my tenure as chief of police
where I was made aware that people
wanting to leave within those zones were
able to leave to with some facilitation
by the officers
because I understand that they weren't
and there's going to be evidence from
our clients that that was a problem they
would ask to leave and they wouldn't
remove the barricades did you hear
anything about that
um nothing specifically but I could
understand that there would be
challenges in doing just that logistical
challenges but I do recall specifically
being told of a number of trucks small
vehicles or individuals that were able
to to indicated they wanted to leave and
then were able to do Logistics to
facilitate their departure small numbers
is what my recollection is but there
were instances okay thank you very much
for that and already in evidence is that
on January 30th 2022 you requested of
Stephen K at the city of Ottawa to
obtain an injunction you recall asking
for that is that right can you just give
me the date again sir uh January 30th
2022 it was a phone call and then a
follow-up email
again my recollection is that we at the
Ottawa Police Service started to
consider a range of options in Junction
being one of them as mitigation options
yes post-incident response options
um I don't know when the First
Communication would have went from the
Ottawa Police Service to the city
um and that might have predated that
January 30th call with Steve city
manager Steve kanalakis but I do recall
that phone call with Steve kanlakis
right and do you remember I can put it
up in front of you if you like it's just
a a bit of brothers and I'm hoping not
to do it do you remember following up uh
with him with an email just reciting
your call on what you asked him and he
was then going to get back to you I
don't have an independent recollection
sorry okay I don't need to put it up but
after
um you had that call I take it that you
had some ideas for the terms of what the
injunction would look like if it was
obtained and you told him those things I
take it
again there were very loose ideas at
that point we were still just trying to
figure out what had landed in our city
at that point okay
and
you then also provided uh Mr K
that the legal counsel the internal
legal counsel for Ops would assist with
whatever evidence and whatever support
they needed to obtain the injunction
correct I'd assigned my general counsel
to lead that and through her office they
would be the primary point of contact
right and as a very senior police
officer you're aware that once you
obtain an injunction its terms can be
enforced via the criminal code under
Section 127 if people don't follow its
terms right I don't have a lot of
experience with injunction search so and
how they tie into the criminal code I
will take you at at face value right but
it's fair to say that if an injunction
was obtained it would add another tool
to the toolbox for enforcement purposes
Fair
it would add another tool well beyond
enforcement yeah but that would be that
would be the potential benefit that in
the net there would be a net benefit to
addressing whatever the public safety
issue was right and in your testimony
last week I take it that you agreed with
the evidence of Inspector bondois with
respect to crowd Dynamics do you
remember saying that
actually
um
I I don't remember saying exactly that
so if for context commissioner um I
think inspector Boudin provided
fantastic context in general around
crowd Dynamics and Theory to the
commissioner I would encourage you to
utilize that fully
um
the only place I might diverge somewhat
from inspector Bowdoin and I suspect if
he had a chance to add Clarity to my
comment
I think we would find congruence
there were multiple crowds and therefore
multiple crowd Dynamics so to describe
the crowd within the Red Zone and then
try to ascribe those Dynamics to those
in the neighborhoods and then to
describe those to the Dynamics of those
in the Suburban parts of our city you
you couldn't do that the Dynamics
literally sometimes changed block by
block the Dynamics of the morning crowds
were different from the Dynamics of the
evening and overnight crowds weekend
Dynamics were different from weekdays so
I just would put one small cautionary
note on the otherwise excellent
testimony of Inspector Boudoir that it
wasn't a crowd and that crowd wasn't
static over a 24-hour period right but
in his evidence and I I think you're in
agreement with this uh inspector
talked about what has been referred to
as the 80 20 rule do you remember
hearing that
I'm not sure he said 80 20 rule but I
understand the breakdown of dynamic of
percentages rough percentages that he
was using right and just to reiterate
that it's presumed that 80 percent of
the crowd and a protest are law abiding
is that right
I think that's a general comment yes and
then the other 15 are what I would call
on the fence they could go either way
maybe they're influenced but there's
that 15 Factor
that's what he was describing seriously
yeah and then five percent of the
troublemakers that's how he sort of
summarized that so would you agree that
that's sort of the general rule with
crowd Dynamics I'm not an expert in
crowd Dynamics however lion inspector
budwen's uh uh testimony so if an
injunction was obtained I take it I know
you were just spitballing ideas at the
time but I take it that two of the terms
for that the major terms would have of
course been that the trucks that were
blocking roadways due to where they were
parked would be removed would that be
fair sorry can you just repeat so if an
injunction was to be obtained I take it
that you would have been looking for two
important points and the first I'd put
to you is that the trucks that were
blocking roadways uh due to where they
were parked would be removed is that
fair
unfortunately no sir and it's only in
this context
um
pursuing a city injunction that led to
that I would first need to know that I
had a reasonable
reliability on the resources necessary
to execute such an injunction
and quite frankly I think until well
certainly past my last day in office I
didn't have those resources right and
and of course the Ops simply cannot go
out and get an injunction themselves
either candidate the city does police
officers and police services don't apply
for injunctions that's not happened
that's correct sir right and so it's
fair to say that you were relying upon
the city of Ottawa to obtain an
injunction if one was going to be
obtained yes sir right now
I take it though if the the city did go
out and obtain an injunction if the 80
rule was applied and that injunction was
served on protesters
it's fair to say that some of them would
have left after being served the
injunction right
I think it's fair to say that yes some
some would see that as
a reason
if they needed one to leave at that
point absolutely and so what I'd like to
bring up now is uh Ops document Ops zero
zero zero zero four nine two seven
please
so these are the type notes and we went
through some of the handwritten ones who
somebody called uh CH previously but
these are the type notes of your meeting
with Brenda lucky as well as
commissioner correct from the opp so if
you can just take a minute I'm sure
you've seen these PS is you is that fair
yes sir do you want to just review that
for a minute yes please
okay
Adam Clark If you could or Mr Clark If
you could scroll down too for him
foreign
yes one last line there oh
okay thank you thank you so and what I
want to chat with you about is the
points that say four Ops
and there's five points there but one's
just commentary on the other four and so
the four Ops which I will call the four
pronged approach that you had
pitched was ongoing public order
management planning for long-term
application police LED intervention to
arrest to bring to an end and seek an
injunction at all levels because of all
three levels of land involved so that's
a a multi-pronged multi-tactic uh
approach that would be very common in
policing is that fair yes again I think
you've said it but just to be to be
clear it's not one or the other or the
other the other but some combination of
all four correct yeah so the it's a
multi uh a multi-faceted approach
because you you know you don't use a
sledgehammer to squash a mosquito but
you you want to have all your tools that
you can in place and use them as
appropriate yes sir all right so an
injunction on when you had this
conversation on January 31st was
something that was a part of those four
Ops yes sir right okay now if we could
scroll down please
and I take it BL here that's uh
commissioner Brenda lucky is that right
I'll assume so here that's right so I'll
give you a second to review those points
yes sir thank you thank you and so is
that those points first are those
accurate from what you recall from that
conversation
what she said they're accurate I I
recall that the second bullet point
around the injunction that the
commissioner at the time went into a
lengthy
a lengthy explanation of her experience
with and therefore position with
injunctions and and it was clear that
she was not uh did not believe it was
going to be a substantive part of the
solution right and so here she had told
you and then I believe uh commissioner
karrick uh somewhat backed her up but he
was more on the fence that
she didn't think an injunction was a
good idea
I would yes that's correct okay he was
not as emphatic but but was not far off
her overall theme right
and so
it's fair to say that at this point this
is the first time someone has told you
not to go the injunction route is that
right
again I wouldn't use the language told
neither Commissioners directed me right
they provided their perspective okay
but even after this meeting
um I haven't seen anything in the
records that you ever changed your
advice or anything to the city you still
were in support of them getting an
injunction if they wanted to do so but
it was up to them
agreed again just with the with the
almost the inevitable caveat that no
matter what you do
um whether it was a discussion around a
declaration of state of emergency and
injunction if we don't have the
resources it could be even more
problematic right
and
so I then want to take you to another
document if I can it's the one that my
friends have been
referring to if I may just second
and that would be Ops
00014454 it's the long set of notes and
I'd like to go to page 24 of those notes
foreign
so just from my understanding too sir
um these notes and the disclosure
package they say they're from somebody
called CH do you know who that is that's
general counsel Christian you know okay
thank you and so she's the general
counsel to the Ops that's correct all
right so if we can scroll down
so these are from February 2nd and it's
a meeting that all of you had
and there it says Steve K had a meeting
with the federal government today
and at the bottom it says not likely an
injunction
so
from your recollection of that meeting
did Steve K tell you that the feds told
him not to get an injunction
or whoever was representing Steve k at
this meeting yeah thank you um I want to
be very careful because I think I've
suffered somewhat from this trying to
interpret other people's language from
somebody else so I want to be very
careful on this
um
if this is the second of February so yes
this would have been the first time that
city manager Steve kanilakis advised me
that he'd been participating what I I
call tri-level calls right federal
government prevention government
municipal government and he gave me a
very quick overview of the one or more
calls that he had been on and that's my
best recollection of his very brief
overview so I wouldn't want to ascribe
anything particular to the federal
government based on this line in this
document so do you remember uh can we
scroll up too just so you can see the
Dayton who was there
so it doesn't look like Steve Bell was
present no so it's um myself Christian
you know John steinbach's
the executive director of strategy and
Communications the rest are are from two
external service providers right and do
you know who was making the statements
with respect to Steve Bell's meeting
with the Feds that are at points one two
three and four do you recall
that would be me providing that briefing
to the group okay and that's Steve
kanalakis not Steve
outside um Junction I just want to talk
to you about sort of
protest generally and how they work and
I'm not going to be asking questions a
lot this isn't an exam but I just went
through this with uh commissioner karerk
and I think it's important
um to go through with you as well
can you agree that in sort of General
protest law and enforcement and criminal
offenses regarding the same you
basically have three types you have
lawful protest which is protected under
the charter then you have an unlawful
assembly and then you have a riot you
agree with that
um
under the law if you're asking if that's
the definitions under the law I will I
will see to you under policing we would
talk about peaceful peaceful lawful
peaceful unlawful unlawful and there'd
be a range of other
but from a from a definition legal
definition perspective I'll I will leave
that to your analysis right and you're
aware of course with protests that when
they cross the Rubicon between
lawful protest and unlawful protest it
becomes a criminal matter under Section
63 of the criminal code I am not as
conversant with the code again I will I
will trust your your interpretation
right and so with that
um is it fair to say that
the Ops and and your office at no time
prior to the Declaration
issued any form of formal notice to the
protesters that they had been deemed to
be an unlawful assembly and they must
disperse that's correct sir so no time
that didn't happen not tomorrow not to
my understanding right
so you're aware also of the riot
Provisions in the criminal code for the
riot act because I am serious right and
so that requires that even if General
Riot isn't happening as recognized in
law without the Declaration that if a
sheriff a mayor or a Justice the peace
or judge of the Ontario court of justice
goes out says the set of words that end
and God Save the Queen or now God Save
the King and it's then deemed on illegal
Gathering and people in order to
disperse you agree that's what that does
yes sir sorry I'm just so when it was
written it was probably in an age where
where people might hear those words
exactly everybody in the area would hear
those words right and so there was never
a declaration of course as a riot and
there was no formal declaration that
there was an unlawful assembly
and therefore the protesters who were
there who were who were sitting there no
one in Authority it's fair to say told
them that they were doing anything
illegal is that fair
again I I will seed to the legal
definition of it but I I couldn't agree
that that would be the case given the
massive amount of social media
mainstream media coverage of what was
happening
in our city here and across the country
um I think it'd be very hard to to
believe that any individual could not
understand that there was
a level of unlawfulness and public
danger and risk heightened risk at any
point from January 29th onwards right
and so that that brings me interestingly
enough to my next area and I
heard your evidence or read your
evidence about misinformation
and it's fair to say that on social
media and particularly and even in the
news there was a whole bunch of
misinformation about the protesters is
that fair about everything that had to
do with it yes right so for example
there was reports in the news that there
was an arson committed by the protesters
and I understand that was investigated
and it turned out that wasn't true yes
sir and uh sorry they post the
investigation was concluded after I left
office my yes sir is what I understood
to be in the media but not from the
actual investigators themselves okay and
with the misinformation did you have any
idea about how the misinformation about
the protests started did you do any
analysis with your intelligence Bureau
on that no sir okay well not that I'm
aware of they may have made such
attempts but I wasn't all right so I
want to bring up a document I gave
notice of this earlier today
and I don't know if the feds are going
to object but I wouldn't be surprised uh
if if I could bring up document
ssm.can
dot zero zero zero zero seven seven two
two underscore Rel dot zero zero zero
one
all right so what this is Sir this is a
text message from a fellow by the name
of Alexander Cohen are you familiar with
him
doesn't ring a bell sir okay he's at the
pro he's with uh Minister Marciano's
office uh minister of Public Safety and
it's between him and Mary Liz power are
you familiar with Mary Lou's power again
the names aren't ringing a bell okay
she's with the uh prime minister's
office so I'm just going to read that to
you for you so you have an understanding
and this is from about the 24th on or
before the 24th of January and says I
got a quick response people are into it
let me know if your boss is too happy to
help however I can this is what I sent
through though by the way
hi I just had a chat with Alex at PS
meaning Public Safety who had a bit of
an interesting idea as you saw in the
Pod goals chat the truckers Convoy and
some of their more extreme comments in
Brackets I.E calling for a January
six-style Insurrection close brackets
are getting more coverage in the media
Alex was surveying whether there'd be
interest in his boss doing some media on
this eventually he was chatting with
mediciano about it right before he went
into the cabinet Retreat now I can tell
you the cabinet retreat was on the 24th
that's why I know it was before the 24th
I think there could be an opportunity to
get in on this growing Narrative of the
truckers particularly with the research
that lrb is doing into their backers my
thoughts of the framing here would be
similar to what PM slash Blair meaning
the Prime Minister and Minister Blair
said last year when January 6 occurred
and the first thing is our democracy is
something we need to nurture and protect
every day now that text message then
continues and I'd ask uh Mr Clark if you
could bring up
ssm.c a n dot zero zero zero zero seven
seven two two underscore r e l dot zero
zero zero one
councilor I think that's the current
document we're on
um sorry uh two seven one six
nope I apologize
hold on
well I've got the name of it wrong I
think I got the wrong number
I emailed it to you earlier if you could
open it up it's a text message too
just says text to
I have um a text to PB can zero zero
zero one five two seven underscore route
we can see if that works I'll let you
know if it's the right one
it looks to be a text from someone named
Pam no it's not I can afford it to you
again here
I've just sent it
I think that's I think that's why it's
good to have these things done in
advance and not last minute
true
Mr clerk it's Eric Brazil I think I've
opened the document that my friend I
think sent you and I think it's 7724
could be the second
um
text message that he's trying to refer
to
all right so this is the continuation
and it's
what sort of the the lines are going to
be and we will always support the right
to piece with protests some of the call
that organizers of these events are
making are concerning and we're taking
them seriously in Brackets we'd need
something to back this up close brackets
we'll continue to monitor the situation
closely the fine line to walk would be
to ensure we are not looking like we're
directing the police which obviously is
not the goal here hoping to Canvas your
thoughts Alex said he'd come back to me
with a proposal this afternoon when he
gets to chat with modiciano again and
obviously pending his boss and our our
interest in looking into this further
and if you could scroll down
and Alex responds thanks I had an
initial chat with my boss and he's
supportive but wants to wait a day or
two there's a danger that if we come
down too hard they might push out the
crazies
and then the response I think that's
fair apparently Global and others are
working on stories maybe see how those
land
so when I show you this and I
after this the exact same sort of
narrative came out from the federal
government following these suggestions
from their staff
is that misinformation
sorry I can't really comment that
not enough context to know how who these
people are how what they represent what
information
or or influence they have right okay
well then just moving on to a last year
I'd like to question you about and this
is sort of on the Fly I sat here and
listened to the evidence uh with respect
to the notes that
deputy chief Ferguson took
and all of those notes
were about you
now I've only been doing this for 12
years but I've never seen anything like
that with officers keeping notes on one
another can you explain to me how odd
that is or can you would you like to
elaborate on that because to me officers
keep notes on an investigation they
don't keep notes
on their Chief and they don't keep notes
on their colleagues it's for
investigative purposes do you do you
have any concern with what happened
there
in my 30 years in policing I've never
seen anything like that myself
anything else
well I think my evidence commissioner is
that her
extreme editorial license that she took
was extremely problematic for me and
reflects on her not on me and would you
agree that it's in police training that
officers are taught to make notes and
whatever they write is you know for
quarter for proceedings typically
and it goes and it's used if you don't
have something in your notes it goes
against your credibility and if you do
it supports your credibility you're
probably familiar with that
except for the last part yeah my
understanding is that notes are
evidentiary they are they are produced
for the purpose of judicial processes as
well as for internal
system and policy requirements but any
degree just because someone writes
something in their notes doesn't mean
it's true does it
they are supposed to be an honest
representation
sometimes they're not
clearly in some cases thank you
thank you next I'd call on the
government of Canada please
foreign
good morning my name is donnery Nygaard
I'm Council for Canada good morning
I just want to start by going back to
something my friend just asked you about
and that was in regards to your use of
the the word assaultive and what was
occurring during the protests and he put
to you that there were a very limited
number of charges for assaults following
the protests
would you agree with me that a lack of
charges doesn't necessarily mean that
these activities weren't occurring
absolutely and there's a variety of
reasons why charges may not have been
laid for example the perpetrator
couldn't be identified that's correct
there's been earlier in the hearing and
I'm not sure if you watched all of this
evidence a lot of discussion about the
resources that were provided to Ops from
the RCMP and when they were were
provided and I just want to go over some
of that with you to try and provide a
little bit more clarity around that
question
so starting at the beginning on the
first weekend of the protest there were
um and you were aware that there were
two public order units of the RCMP
stationed in two different locations in
Ottawa one at Parliament Hill and one at
Rideau Cottage they were not under Ops
control but you were aware that they
were there correct I understood there
were three RCMP public order troops but
they were all assigned to
protection services that were under the
rcmp's Mandate and not under the control
of
Ottawa Police Service
but you were also aware that if
something were to arise those uh units
were there and would come to the
assistance of the Ops correct that was
my understanding yes and in fact after
that weekend
you sent a note to commissioner uh
to commissioner lucky and also to
commissioner karik and perhaps we can
pull that up it's
pb.nsc dot can
1.401396
the underscore relativity Etc
and if we can just scroll down a little
bit uh
a little bit more that's good
so uh this is an email that that as I
said you sent to commissioner lockian to
commissioner karik amongst others
after that first weekend it was dated I
don't know if you got a chance to see it
it was dated January 30th
and in there you're expressing your
appreciation for the public owner units
that were were on the ground during that
weekend
yes
and you didn't make the first formal
request for officers to assist the Ops
under the ops's direction until February
2nd correct
in regards specifically to the RCM yes
sorry in regards to the RCMP
and I I can pull up the email if you
like yeah I won't challenge it I do
recall just lots of emails going out
prior to the arrival so I can't 100 say
one of them didn't go to the RCMP but
I'll take your
so let's let's
help refresh your memory it's uh
pb.nsc.com.401743
thank you
and if we can scroll down to the first
email in the chain please
and just maybe up a little bit so we can
see the date on it so there so this is
on February 2nd it's an email from you
to the commissioner of the RCMP
and you're requesting 50 uniform members
who would be able to Front Line traffic
requirements and Leadership to go along
with those teams and three public order
units that was your your request at that
time correct Yes again just for clarity
though like I don't have an independent
election that there wasn't some
conversation
with the commissioner or one of her
NCR level staff that we might need some
resources but this would be the first
formal Quest that went out right uh and
and
ottawa's a little bit unusual isn't it
in that uh in Ontario normally if a
police service is in need of extra
resources it's the opp they would go to
first uh but in Ottawa you sometimes go
directly to the RCMP
I'm sorry I was about to interrupt you
so sorry about that
um no actually
um
my experience has mostly been you would
usually
well maybe Toronto was lucky we had GTA
police services all around us and so we
would normally go to one of our border
agency partners and ask for those
resources
um
I can't recall other than from major
planned events like the G8 where we
would go first to Provincial Police and
then escalate to RCMP normal transaction
we don't have enough we need more we
would go to those closest to us or those
who we had worked with and knew that our
public order commanders had a good
report with so it's more informal in
that respect but but yes and I should
have been clearer I apologize uh in
respect of going to the RCMP the normal
chain would be to go through the opp to
go to the rxcn normally Municipal
provincial and then rcmc but
in Ottawa just because of your previous
the ops's previous relationship working
with the RCMP on large events you
sometimes as in this situation uh went
straight to the RCMP correct at the same
time as going to the opp yes and again I
want to be clear
um at this point there's no sort of
hierarchy of where we should be going to
we were just going yes to everybody yes
and
you'd agree with me that this email if
you're going to go directly to the RCMP
that an email from you to the
commissioner is the appropriate route to
be making such requests correct
absolutely I would normally follow I
would probably have sent a text but if I
didn't that would be the normal just
informal reach out and then heads up
there's something more formal coming
yeah and when you make such a request as
you did in this email uh
you set out exactly what it is you're
requesting that you need front line
traffic requirements that you need
leadership for those people and that you
need public order units that's uh that's
important information to include in
their in in the request
as best as I could receive it from my
folks and as best as they had that laid
out yes and after this request was made
the RCMP did in fact provide you with
not at all in fact perhaps I'll back up
and scroll up a little bit to
commissioner Lucky's response
so yep we can stop there uh so in her
response uh commissioner Lockheed sets
out in the second paragraph that all of
her public unit order units were
actively deployed and she wasn't in a
position to be able to redirect any to
Ottawa at that time and that in the next
paragraph
she indicates that the RCMP is
experiencing significant resource
challenges but she is asking her
management team to explore the
possibility of providing you with some
or all of the other 50 resources you
requested
uh and and the RCMP did in fact over the
following days provide you with uh
resources in that range correct I can't
tell you to what extent they achieved
the request
um that I sent on February 2nd
um perhaps we can turn to
another document that might assist you
uh it's uh OPB
four zeros
1014
foreign
and maybe I'll start by asking have you
seen this chart before
uh yes I well I've seen this framework I
can't say I saw exactly this chart but
um this was an effort uh towards the um
the last week of my time in office to
try to identify all of the resources
that were available to us over the
course of the the days of the Convoy
related events yes so this is an Ops
produced document I believe so there may
have been some some support from our
integrated Partners opprcmp to to help
to
build this document and then obviously
provide the content and verification of
it right and and this document came to
us through the OPB so I assume at some
point you provided it to them
or PSP the audible Police Services Board
yes yes I believe there was a point
where this a version of this document
was sent to the audible Police Services
Board okay so if we can just have a look
at this document
um it's broken into two parts and the
top part of the chart is as I understand
at the public order units or public
order members that are provided and the
bottom part of the chart is regular
members is my interpreting that
correctly yes uh and there's a note down
the bottom that external public order
deployments are incomplete between
January 30th and February 9th uh but if
we just focus for a moment on the
regular members that are provided and
the RCMP are listed at the top of that
bottom part of the chart yes and uh you
can see that on February 4th uh which is
two days after you made that request uh
there there are 20 and then it increases
up to 45 the following day and 52 and
49.
that's correct uh so you you'd agree
with me that the the request for 50
members was in fact actioned within a
couple of days by the RCMP that's
correct
foreign
and as was set out in in commissioner
Lucky's response to you you weren't
provided with any uh public order units
directly under your control at that time
that's correct uh and that was because
uh she said that they were deployed on
other duties
and and you would agree with me that
when a request is made of partner a
policing agency they have to make sure
that they can fulfill their own mandate
before they can give you additional
people correct I assume that it wouldn't
be just that brutal but but they would
also assess what the overarching threats
are and make a decision not just based
on
fulfilling their own Staffing but that
they could could or should make another
investment
I sorry
I'd like to think it was more than let's
just look after ourselves before we look
after anybody else as an equation to
make a decision around approving or not
approving particularly public order unit
assets yes but if if those assets are
actively operating somewhere else then
that has to be obviously taken into
consideration absolutely the entire
threat risk assessment I would assume
there would be some effort of assessing
risk as well as assessing
responsibilities
uh
and shortly after this on on February
7th I I won't pull it up but I assume
you are familiar with the letter that
was sent by the mayor uh both to the
Prime Minister and a identical letter uh
to the province as well requesting 1800
resources correct 1790 and change but
yes I understand that uh and
that's not the normal way for requesting
resources from another policing agency
is it no and I said in my evidence on
Friday this was these were not normal
times no that and that was
um
an attempt by everyone involved just to
do whatever they could to get uh
to get the resources that you felt you
required at the time yes and and I
assume it was hoped that by having a
piece of Correspondence go from the
mayor to the political level that that
would apply some political pressure to
encourage movement on that front
incentive whatever the the right term
but I think it was to send a different
signal under very unique and different
circumstances but at the end of the day
you also knew that you had to have that
discussion directly with the RCMP that
letter in and of itself wasn't going to
result in anything by itself absolutely
and as I understand it
um
there was additional resources uh
provided by the RCMP on February 8th to
stand up the integrated planning cell
correct
um they sent uh experts like
superintendent Lou yes to be part of
that integrated team so senior members
of the RCMP to assist with the planning
and I I think you said and I can turn
you to it if you like in your witness
say statement that they were provided at
least in part to assist the Ottawa
Police Service in securing the requested
1800 police resources is that accurate
uh and then the following day on
February 9th uh there was a meeting with
the RCMP and others in which the
February 9th plan was explained and you
provided some more information about the
nature of those resources correct that's
correct because the letter that went
from the mayor to the Prime Minister uh
didn't include any details about what
those 1800 people were to be made up of
correct I believe that's correct yes you
you had prepared internally that that
chart that we've seen but that wasn't
part of the letter that went I don't
think it was that's my recollection so
that that information was provided to
the RCMP through this February 9th
briefing correct
um
absolutely it was
um the only hesitation there was a
request that came from
a recollection it came from Deputy
Minister Rob Stewart for more details
and I've I actioned that request through
acting deputy chief Ferguson I believe I
saw emails with her corresponding back I
just don't know what the timeline would
have been between the ninth and that
request from Deputy Minister Stewart and
and I don't think I have the document
number here but I have seen the email
you're referring to I believe it
occurred on the 10th would that fit with
what I wouldn't argue with your
recollection somewhere in that zone yes
um
and so on February 9th the the resource
ask was explained in a little bit more
detail because you would agree a
of just a number of 1800 isn't something
that people could actually act on
because they don't know what that is
comprised of
um yes sorry just I am going to back you
up one day though February 8th was the
first time that the Ottawa Police
Service met with the members of the
integrated planning team and that was at
RCMP headquarters yes in the afternoon
there were discussions I wasn't there
for the whole meeting but I understand
there were discussions around what that
1790 would look like
the meeting carried on over into
February 9th um and then was a much
deeper discussion with more information
provided around the Staffing levels on
the ninth right and uh if we can go back
to to that chart that was OPB one zero
one four four zeros one zero one four
so if we look at this very shortly after
that meeting on the knife by the 11th
the numbers of RCMP officers start to to
rise quite significantly on the 11th and
the 12th correct
yes
and
um
there there is some delay in getting
RCMP officers into a position where they
can actually assist the auto of lease
Services correct they have to be sworn
in there is a delay again just sorry as
I'm recalling somewhere around well it
was February 5th
I received correspondence from
commissioner lucky that the RCMP were
providing 250 officers
and I actually think I made that
announcement at the public board meeting
on February 5th that I just received
this communication
so even before the official letter went
out from the mayor
and the chair to the two levels of
government there had been a offer of
Promise of
um
250 officers
that didn't materialize until
passed the dates on this chart here and
I to this day don't know what happened
to that deployment of 250 but certainly
there is an indication that the 50 that
was requested on February 2nd was
achieved very quickly and maintained and
then there was a significant uh increase
in Staffing after the
well on the 11th I guess but you'll
agree with me that um if the RCMP
provide a certain number of officers
they cannot all work every day
so you need a pool for example larger
than 50 in order to have 50 people
working every day
so I'm not sure I understand what you're
so if the RCMP if are going to have
supply to the uh to the Ops 50 boots on
the ground on a given day every day
that's not 50 individual officers it has
to be more than that in order to cover
off 50 boots on the ground every day
if a police service is sending me 50
officers
um and they'll be operating under our
incident command system then my
expectation would be that we would not
just deploy them on a day shift we'd
deploy them on an as needed basis and
some of that 50 would work daytime
afternoons nighttime but we would have
50 officers 50 human beings who are
capable of being deployed under the
direction of the Ottawa Police Service
incident command system I think we're
saying the same thing but I'm not sure
we're saying the same I'm not entirely
sure we're saying the same thing either
I I guess my point is
um because RCMP officers have to come
and be sworn in and obviously have to
have some time off they can't work 24
hours a day that you would need a pool
larger than the number of boots you want
on the ground in order to to have that
many boots on the ground there certainly
would be a delay around the swearing-in
piece and and I've heard it described
differently in terms of the actual
timing of that
there wouldn't be an expectation that
whoever arrived in Ottawa would work
every day although most of our officers
had been in and we know in some cases
like inspector Lucas did work
every day again that was one of our
challenges was just maintaining the
health and wellness and safety of our
members and part partner agencies
my expectation would only be if you're
offering us something make sure it
arrives and that we can fully deploy it
including days off there wouldn't be an
expectation that any agency would have
to oversupply
to manage days off we just needed to
know how many officers will be in our
theater dedicated to our incident
command system Deployable as fully as
possible at whatever time and whatever
relevant Duties are what duties that are
relevant to their capabilities
so you wanted to ensure you had 50
people on the ground every day and that
might require more than 50 people being
here in order to accomplish it no no and
I just needed to know I was going to
have 50 officers from whatever
jurisdiction had asked so in this case
the RCMP letter I sent on February 2nd
that was the date of the letter I sent
the official letter yes the 50 uniform
officers my expectation if it could be
honored that they would arrive as
quickly as possible and be Deployable as
fully as possible for whatever period of
time they could stay
okay
and I want to take you to to one more
document on this which is
pbnsc can four zeros3118
this might
help somewhat with this confusion if we
just scroll down to the bottom a little
bit
a little further so this oh no too far
this is an email on uh I believe it's
February 12th
uh and it's from uh Mike o'burn from the
RCMP to a variety of people including
Chief superintendent party about RCMP
resources as of that day so if we just
look scroll down to the numbers
so this is the resourcing that the RCMP
are reporting as of February 12th
uh and they indicate there are
Detachment to support the Ops assist
operation slash deployment 320
deployed as this date 24 hours to 25 and
operational Readiness 159. can you can
you help me and explain what or if you
know what the difference between those
those three numbers is I can't and they
don't align to what was on the chart
either no they don't I agree
um
that was a huge challenge for us
again this is in no way meant to be a
criticism with the RCMP but different
Police Services call things differently
they count things differently they
account for things differently and
there wasn't a day that I while I was in
office that I had a report from anyone
including my own folks that that anybody
could say was a hundred percent accurate
nor was there a day
other than maybe my last day in office
where we had a number that anyone could
reasonably believe give or take 20 or 30
that we were no longer just hanging on
protecting the Red Zone we were now
getting sufficient resources to
contemplate substantial additional
operations but this was a problem right
from the beginning when when everyone
was trying to figure out how many people
Ottawa Police Service actually had
in our theater under our ability to
direct through our incident command
system
this is probably very accurate for the
RCMP purposes
but not particularly
helpful for us to understand what we
actually had in terms of Ottawa Police
Services so you can't help us with the
difference between deployed and
operational readiness
no okay certainly there were not 225
RCMP officers deployed to the Ottawa
Police Service under our ICS on the date
of February 12th the numbers on the
chart we just saw don't bear that out
well they don't match up with the
numbers in the chart but you just said
yourself even your own numbers uh
couldn't be guaranteed to be accurate
yes but
um
our numbers were
plus or minus 10 15 20. these are very
different numbers 300 and
20
Detachment to support again I don't know
what the term means these are
substantially different numbers okay
so I want to move on to another issue
foreign
that's the tow trucks
and you'd agree with me that obtaining
heavy tow trucks in particular was a
significant issue throughout these
events correct second only to getting
extra police officers yes
uh and on Friday in your testimony you
commented at one point that Towing was
happening throughout but I take it that
you were referring to Towing regular
vehicles with regular tow trucks not
heavy toes correct um I stand to be
corrected but I do recall having
information that we did tow heavy trucks
not in the Red Zone but in other parts
of the theater around the Red Zone but
my understanding was there were some
successful efforts minor successful
efforts to tow heavy trucks and do you
know where those tow trucks were
obtained from
we had a number of contracts toes I
believe we had city-owned heavy trucks
um but so I don't know exactly where
they were obtain from I think we had
some three or five heavy tow trucks
through logistics pre-staged for that
first weekend and I'm assuming it was
some combination of those heavy tow
trucks that did the did the towing
but in any event it very quickly became
particularly with the heavy tow trucks a
problem to get them to cooperate
absolutely uh and I think the the first
reference
um
that I have seen in relation to this is
uh on February 4th and if we can pull up
Ops 406270
and so this is um the notes from a
command briefing that you appear to be
at have been at do you recognize the
notes of this nature I don't recognize
these particular notes but if it was a
command briefing unless I was tied up on
something else I would have been there
uh so and this um the date on this is
February 4th and this is one of those
ones where we have to subtract five from
the time to get an accurate reading uh
so it would have been around four
o'clock in the afternoon would that make
sense for a command briefing yes there's
usually a morning and afternoon briefing
cycle okay so if we can scroll down to
the bottom of the document uh so oh not
quite that far there
um you'll see there's uh an attribution
to you in the last comment and if we
look at the very uh last a couple of
lines of that it says Chief concerned
about lack of heavy tow truck
availability need to manage public
expectations if this is the case add to
operational plan as a logistics need not
being met
if tow truck drivers are being
threatened or exhorted extorted this
needs to be investigated so as early as
February 4th you are hearing about tow
truck drivers being threatened I assume
from this comment yes
and uh you are already having trouble
getting
tow trucks at that point absolutely
and uh then
if we can go to OPP one at four zeros
one five two one
foreign
6th
and if we can go to the fifth oh well
first I'll situate you this is a a call
uh appears to be between
um various Federal officials and
provincial and City officials and and
yourself do you recall
this is what I think what I would
um call the tri-level meetings yes
and if we can go uh to page
four to start
the bottom towards the bottom of the
page
and you can see those these comments are
attributed to you you're talking about
the RCMP officers being sworn in and
then if we can scroll down a little bit
about three bullets down on the next
page you say Ottawa Police Service has
two City tow trucks supporting and they
are looking for other heavy toes so at
that point it appears you had two truck
tow trucks now we've we've heard that
OCC transpo had two heavy tow trucks are
those the tow trucks you're talking
about I honestly don't know
uh but in any event uh you were still
looking for other heavy toes at that
point and I assume you were still having
difficulty getting them to cooperate at
that point that's correct and uh in fact
I won't well I can take you there if you
like but in the February 9th plan
there's specific reference to the fact
that tow truck operators were receiving
uh hundreds of threats and some of them
death threats is that your recollection
not necessarily from the February 9th
plan but that was really just the state
of affairs from the middle of the first
week through throughout
uh and at one point there was an attempt
to get the Ministry of Transport to
assist with the tow truck issue do you
recall that Federal Ministry of
Transport no provincial
um I I don't specifically recall but but
that was such a regular discussion we we
at one point I
I think even commissioner lucky
I don't think she was flipping about it
but they were looking at Kijiji to find
heavy tow trucks in Canada
and and even on as late as February 14th
you were still making comments that you
needed heavy tow trucks correct that's
correct
and
this document that we just looked at is
one example and you've referred to it as
well this was a consistent conversation
you were having with both Federal
ministers and federal officials that
there was no heavy tow trucks to be had
certainly not sufficient to heavy tow
trucks to be had to to carry out the
work that you needed to do to deal with
this situation yes and just and I think
you mean it implicitly but to make it
explicitly they were there it's whether
we could predictably count on their
ability to support our operations was
the Gap that needed to be closed they
physically existed yes our ability to
engage them reliably predictably on
scale was the challenge because because
they were not cooperating they did not
want to participate they were
intimidated for a wide variety of
reasons the sum total effect was we
could not access them predictably on
scale and and that was a consistent
message you were giving to the your
federal Partners yes and at no time did
you tell the the problem solved we've
got tow trucks not from me
so I'll switch off of tow trucks now we
seem to spend an awful lot of time
talking about them although actually
just before I do I just want to confirm
in your your witness statement and I
think you just said this now you you
indicated that that was the second most
present pressing problem you had in
order to be able to address this issue
was the lack of heavy tow trucks correct
from a resourcing standpoint people
police officers with particular
knowledge skills and abilities secondly
from a resourcing standpoint tow trucks
there were other issues that were
challenging but those were the two main
resource issues
so I want to turn to the issue of
negotiations sort of broadly speaking in
dealing with the situation in Ottawa and
there's been quite a bit of discussion
about the work of the plts and
um they were involved in various
negotiations throughout this this piece
but these weren't negotiations to
resolve the entire thing they were I I'm
correct about that right they were
negotiations to deal with particular
issues within the protest
um well technically anything that could
move us towards a safe successful end
was designed to get us to a safe
successful and in PLT always has that
role
um
I couldn't tell you that any one PLT
negotiation there was a huge expectation
that that in of itself would would
resolve the entire theater of risks and
and issues that we were dealing with I
think that would be unrealistic yes
exactly in any in any circumstance yes
so so they were they were working at
smaller goals working towards the larger
goal correct working at smaller girls in
support of the larger goal yes
absolutely uh for example one of the
things we've heard about is the
Confederation Park uh negotiations which
resulted in Federate Confederation park
being cleared so that's an example of of
of one of the smaller goals towards the
larger objective however all of those
those smaller goals that they were
working towards during this time
even the Confederation Park uh success
didn't result in a significant shrinking
of the footprint or reduction in the
number of protesters it dealt with some
important issues that getting people out
of Confederation Park but those people
didn't leave right they were important
contributions but none of them on their
own were sufficient enough to end
successfully and safely the entire uh
events taking place
and even the negotiations that the mayor
brokered uh
was along that same line it wasn't going
to resolve the entire situation it was
an attempt to solve a particular problem
uh the the awful circumstances that the
residents in the downtown core were
facing with the trucks in their
neighborhood correct that was my
understanding yes and and to your
knowledge there were no trucks that left
as a result of that negotiation although
they were moved around
I I don't know I believe my
understanding there was there was some
that departed the theater but again I
don't have any independent recollection
there was certainly a lot of movement
and my understanding was some of them
left the theater whether they went
outside of the city limits or just left
the downtown core I I can't tell you
and and some of them refused to move at
all during that uh attempt that is my
understanding
and you were asking for these large
numbers of resources the 1800 that you
had requested because although you
thought and hoped that you would be able
to shrink the footprint of this protest
through some of these tools there were
significant elements within the protests
that you knew weren't going to
voluntarily leave correct
um certainly that's part of the
considerations
um I I go back to the the February 1st
meeting with the public order unit
Commanders
um where during the sort of open
discussion phase of
what's our understanding of what we're
dealing with here and what's our best
estimate at this point I think barely
four days into it as to what it's going
to take to substantially remove the Red
Zone and bring about ultimately a safe
successful end
it was at that meeting where the scale
of the resources really became apparent
where public order commanders from four
or five different agencies within a
relatively short confab unanimously came
back and said it's going to require
every public order unit office here in
Ontario and much more from across Canada
I did quick math in my head we all
looked at each other that's somewhere
between lowball 700 eyeball
a thousand maybe a little bit more than
that that scale
I think others have said unprecedented
add in Patrol officers add an
investigators covert officers civilian
dispatchers crime analysts your number
goes towards 1800 ultimately I think
some 2 200 but the scale was clear
absolutely but but my point was at some
point
um
even using a measured approach and using
the plts to their utmost ability at some
point given the nature of this event
there was going to have to be some
enforcement action correct
um I can't rule out and I so I I Ruled
in the likelihood that a PLT alone
negotiated effort or any negotiation
negotiated effort including the mayor's
attempt would not likely result in the
penultimate safe successful end I can't
rule that possibility out though the
likelihood was very very tiny but I
can't say that it could not happen that
some combination of negotiation efforts
by the audible Police Service by partner
agencies by some involvement of one or
more levels of government an unknown and
Incredibly talented interlocutor
couldn't have arrived on the scene and
some combination of factors could have
resulted in a fully negotiated end the
likelihood though was very small in my
estimation
right
and that's that's why you needed the the
resources so I had to ask for those
resources
and and you were of the view that the
situation in Ottawa particularly taken
in the context of everything that was
going on around the country uh created a
threat to National Security correct that
was my view and why were you of that
view again to be clear I'm not a
national security expert but in the
totality of my experience over 35 years
30 of them in policing and almost five
years in security and Justice which
included National Security work
supporting agencies doing that
um
this was the closest thing that I could
see to a true National
security event
and when you say the totality of events
what are you taking into consideration
there absolutely what was happening here
in Ottawa but how that was being
coordinated
to different sites across the country
Coots and Ottawa happening at the same
time
the first real signal to me was the um I
think it's captured in
commissioner Creek's either his his
statement or in his testimony I forget
um but clearly the move to Windsor as
the southernmost point away from Ottawa
for a significant policing operation was
designed to split our resources across a
significant piece of territory at two
very high profile high-risk locations
that would demand significant resourcing
I recall explicitly in conversations
with commissioner Creek when the Windsor
piece was clearly underway that you know
we had some very capable
I want to be careful when they use this
term but capable adversaries who through
command control and communication could
understand the limitations of our
resources and our Logistics and create
two major events literally polar
opposite North and South
and your view that the situation was of
that nature that it created a national
security risk or threat that was a view
that you expressed quite consistently
throughout these events correct and and
quite publicly
I can't recall stand to be corrected if
I use the term National Security event
while still in office I certainly have
used it consistently as I've appeared
before various standing committees
um in my statement and in my interviews
with Mr ow and others so and and
your view of even if you didn't use
those words of the nature of the event
at the time it was going on was
something that you would have
communicated to the various Federal
officials and federal ministers that you
were dealing with absolutely whether I
used the term National Security events
or not again I stand to be corrected but
there was no doubt that my communication
was this was not just an Ottawa event
this was provincial and National in
nature and they had elements of
international in it and and Not only was
it not just a local event but that it
was a very serious event absolutely and
and uh that it was causing created
significant risks absolutely
thank you those are my questions thank
you
thank you uh city of Ottawa please
good afternoon Chief slowly good
afternoon I'm sorry Mr slowly my
apologies uh my name is Anne Hardeep I
represent the city of Ottawa thank you
so um I want to start by confirming what
I think what I hope is an obvious point
and that is that the Ottawa Police
Service was the lead agency with respect
to uh the events that bring us here
today it was till my last day in office
and it's my understanding that it was
until the end of these events here okay
thank you and the only reason I raised
that is in your witness summary you
indicated
um that the city saw Ops as the lead
agency and that's that's of course
because it was the lease agency yes
that's correct great thank you for that
um
okay now
um we've heard evidence already that
obviously Ops would provide some
briefings and messagings to the city in
advance and uh during the demonstrations
correct that's correct and my
understanding and for reasons you've
already gone into is that in general
those briefings were at a fairly high
level is that fair either with the
mayor's office his staff and whoever
they invited to the meeting or at
Council meetings where we were invited
to make presentations and answer
questions okay thank you and I realized
I was unclear Mr slowly I meant that the
information provided would be at a
fairly high level
um yes yeah okay great thank you
um
now we've talked a bit about how by
January 31st which is the Monday uh in
your view this had turned into not only
in your view but since I'm the one
questioning you into uh an occupation
right there was a pivot required to use
the language employed by some witnesses
is that fair that's correct and uh from
that Force point forward until your last
day in office my understanding is that
the number one thing you needed was
resources is that fair that's correct
okay and we talked a bit about how from
January 34th forward uh because this is
now an occupation the Ops is working on
um perhaps on a new plan but on evolving
the plan to meet the change
circumstances Fair that's correct okay
um I want to talk a little bit about the
injunction I I appreciate we spent some
time on it already
um I can take up documents and I will if
if we need to Mr slowly but I think we
might be able to get by without it my
understanding is that as early as
January 31st both commissioner lucky of
the RCMP and commissioner karik of the
opp expressed some concerns around an
objection and objection an injunction
pardon me being obtained at least at
that time is that accurate that's
correct
um
and at least part of that concern had to
do with uh an issue you've already
raised which is if you get an injunction
you have to be able to implement or
enforce it is that fair that's correct
and you did not I take it until the day
you left office have the resources to do
that that's correct
thank you all right
foreign
so if we could then bring up
Ops three zeros one four four five four
and these are miss you nose notes the
notes of your general counsel just while
they're loading and if we could start at
page six please Mr Clerk and I'll take
this opportunity Mr commissioner I did
not bring up my watch
um I don't expect to go over time but
please don't hesitate to let me know if
you want me to stop my questioning for
the lunch break because I did come up at
quarter to one o'clock Mr commissioner
so I'll accept the gratefully the
interruption okay and you'll appreciate
I gave you no option yeah
I did I wasn't expecting what they're
after my previous
set um Okay so
case the uh the Chiefs meetings with
City councilors you see that there on
January 31st yes okay and
um if we could just scroll down my
understanding uh Mr slowly and you'll
have to correct me if I'm wrong is that
this is you briefing these bullets and
we probably go back up to the top Mr
clerk just to give the Mr slowly a
moment
um my understanding is this is you
providing information to the counselors
does that Accord with your understanding
yes I believe at different points I
invited comments and presentations from
uh acting deputy chief Ferguson and
deputy chief Bell but I let off yeah
okay that's my understanding as well
that's helpful thank you and you'll see
there so we're January 31st the fourth
bullet down increasingly volatile and
aggressive do you see that yes I should
have started a point above we've already
talked about this turning from
demonstration to occupation correct
that's correct and if we scroll down
then to page seven
right here
a little bit uh well before we just stop
there and you'll see there it says the
crowd is turning and officers getting
swarmed do you see that yes now I
couldn't tell to be fair to you Mr
slowly who made that comment but does
that Accord with your recollection of
events is that some of the volatility
you were speaking to absolutely okay
perfect and so let's scroll down a
little bit please
a little bit further Mr clerk sorry
perfect right there now do you see where
it says Matsu at the top yes and so my
understanding is that's a reference to
Matthew Fleury who was at the time a
city councilor right that's my
understanding okay and he has some
questions he's very shaken he has some
questions
um uh about Ops focusing on the hill but
need to look at other communities and
and some of the suggest concerns that he
in fact raised in this proceeding do you
see that yes I do and if we scroll down
a little bit there's a response
attributed to you and it says Chief
agree many minor incidents that would
usually get a police response but this
is not normal times we'll look at new
areas but call for more resources and
complexity so does that sort of accord
with what the service was able to do you
know there were some minor issues minor
incidents that would usually get a
response but you simply couldn't up
until that point because again you
lacked resources I do want to clarify
something and this may not be going to
your point so I apologize oh that's fine
if I'm taking your time but certainly
commissioner was something that I had to
make adjustments about minor incidents
in the vernacular of a police officer is
okay it's not a homicide it's not a
shooting it's not a sexual assault it's
not an assault called Bosley bodily harm
it's a Mischief it's a hate incident
it's a threatening behavior of someone
telling yelling at someone take off your
mask
in the pantheon of of incidents
it's minor in policing
to a community member facing that that
is a major incident that is traumatic
incident that is assaultive
in nature and it can have long-standing
trauma and I believe that that is the
case and I needed to make a shift in my
language to be more clear about that
it's probably one of those regrets and
something that if I would have a chance
to do over I've been much more clear in
my language
so I understood it in the way you've
just explained it but I appreciate that
Mr slowly so with that explanation those
you call them here minor you've
elaborated now on what you meant but
those are the kind of incidents that you
say would normally get a police response
but didn't over the weekend into that
first Monday because the service simply
lacked the resources Fair
and uh if we keep scrolling down to page
nine
yeah a little further down
and stop there and scroll up a little
bit sorry Mr clerk just up to where we
see Menard okay s Minard is counselor
Menard you see that Mr slowly yes I do
and I'll let you just read what he says
um the point I'm going to draw your
attention to is at the bottom he says
two messages it's peaceful but violence
if we proceed do you see not
foreign
yes I'm not 100 sure what he meant by
that though well then we'll scroll down
to your response
or the response attributed to you in the
notes you say better language be
peaceful because Chief feels this this
is what's attributed to you this is
peaceful peaceful pardon me can't build
a moat I think that word is moat around
the city re-people cars Charter
violation do you see that Chief and
thank you um again this I think goes to
the clarification I tried to prefer
peaceful meaning we had no deaths no
serious injuries no rioting no burning
police cars
um but we had a lot of other
assaultive behavior and
a term I think we can use more broadly
violence uh impacting communities the
closing of schools the inability of
people to get medication they
constant at this point constant noise
and and
um and so many other things happening in
the theater at that time
thank you again I tried not to use the
term peaceful after that and recognize
there was a disconnect in the language
police language versus what community
could was experiencing and therefore
could consume
and and I wonder Mr slowly if I could
put this to you we we can bring it back
up if we need to but you've been taken
twice now to uh David White the city
solicitor Mr White's email his his
summary or his notes of the call he had
with you and is it possible that this
focus on you know Public Safety maybe
he's reflecting a change in your
language over time that perhaps you use
words like minor and this is peaceful
with him
intending what you've explained here
today so possibly his notes of that call
reflect wordings or language that you
were using at the time but now you've
since explained well I wouldn't use that
wording and as it went on I don't use
that wording it's possible I would have
hoped that he would have asked for
Clarity on that because he expressed it
in such a
strong way
that I would have assumed and hoped that
he would have asked for clarification on
that either before he wrote that email
or subsequent to it he never did to my
my recollection okay fair enough
um now if we could go to page 10
and there should be if we could keep
scrolling down
keep scrolling down there we go we have
a note from Steve K who is uh Steve
kanilakis the city manager correct
that's correct and we're still in the
same meeting just so you're aware Mr
slowly and he's explaining in response
to various queries no they haven't
opened the lines with the province and
federal government not a fan of bringing
military in to deal with civil issues
and then he says our lead will come from
Chief on whether he needs more supports
do you see that yes I do all right and
in fact when you did need more support
from the city fair to say that they
offered that support including with the
letter of February 7th city was very
responsive throughout the events
um
if we could turn please to OPP four
zeros one five two one
and you've already seen this document Mr
slowly but these are notes they've been
produced by the OPP and I believe also
the provincial government of a call on
February 6 involving you and various
Federal and one provincial
representative you're familiar with this
document not the document but the
meeting itself the meeting fair enough
um
so
um if we could scroll to page two please
no further down
go further down perfect stop there and
you'll see here you explain to uh
provincial and federal representatives
and I should mention there's also a city
representative on the call
um that the Ops was successful in
negotiating the resolution of the
encampment at Confederation Park correct
that's correct and that had been in fact
just that day or the day prior right
Confederation Park was resolved February
5th into February 6th correct yes and if
we turn to page three
in big bolded words so Mr Quick you can
just go down perfect thank you and
that's where you advise that the service
is compiling a list of resources that
the service will require for the next 72
hours just two weeks to assist in
managing the situation and it will be
exhaustive and provided to the mayor of
Ottawa correct the only thing I would
take some issues is the two weeks amount
that that would not have been
we were not seeing it as a two-week
event so that just may be a Mis
misinterpretation by whoever compiled
the notes but otherwise it's accurate
sort of 72 hours till the end if I can
put it that way till the end yes okay
um and this is the list of resources you
were preparing further to the direction
provided you by the Ops B the board on
February 5th correct that's correct and
you're giving them a heads up that this
is coming right that's correct okay and
if we can go to page four please of the
document
further down there we go deputy chief
Bell he's explaining on the six that the
service has about as of that date
120 to 130 officers of the ground on the
ground part of me and that's a
combination of Opp RCMP and Ottawa
Police Service correct
um I'm guessing that looks low so I'm
guessing that's Ottawa Police Service
members
oh no okay he says what date is this
February 6th
you know we should have had a lot more
than that
you believe the numbers were higher yeah
because six was the Sunday and that was
the weekend and so our numbers would
have should have been a lot higher just
based on the chart that we saw earlier
on okay so that's just again maybe just
a transcribing challenge as opposed to
I think the accuracy of Deputy Bell
sorry no that's no problem the 100 into
130 officers would that have been per
shift or both shifts combined that would
if it was it would be per shift and then
you'd double or triple that number and
and that would be a more accurate number
based on my recollection of okay weekend
Staffing fair enough
um and then at the top of page five
the second bullet second clear bullet
you'll see there the additional support
from Opp and RCMP which was expected as
of this date will help provide relief to
Ottawa Police Service officers who have
been 12 I think there's a word missing
working 12 to 14 days straight correct
that's correct and the influx that was
expected as of that time was really to
help the service maintain its current
posture it was not to shift it was not
enough basically in the coming days to
shift towards an enforced solution to
the demonstration is that correct
absolutely we never reached those
numbers until the final week
okay if I could take you to the bottom
of this page please
you'll see in the response from Chief
Peter slowly you see that Mr slowly yes
I do and you'll see that first bullet
underneath
um he is concerned about the risk and
efficacy of enforcement actions now you
say the powers of existing legislation
are sufficient but whether to enforce
given the dynamic risk situation is the
issue and the number of vulnerable
individuals such as children and
families embedded in the encampton
elevates the calculation for Ottawa
Police Service right that's correct and
that's the same issue we've been
discussing that is that you can't
enforce Powers unless you have the
resources necessary to do so safely yes
and and the additional element in this I
believe it was around the end of the
first week going into the weekend that I
became aware of the presence of children
and other vulnerable persons in the Red
Zone in and around the critical areas
so it it really was now two factors the
the necessary resources to do it safely
and lawfully
and then the additional risk factors of
children and vulnerable persons in and
around there that became
even more challenging
if we could go to the bottom of page
eight please
right here
all right
and actually into the top of page nine
keep going there we go and you'll see
here their discussion again of um the
the possibility of evolving an
interlocutor and there's a couple of
names matching there you see that Mr
slowly yes I do and so this was still in
the mix if I can put it that way as of
February 6 as a possible way to manage
the demonstrations yeah absolutely this
is a very healthy discussion that was
happening at the tri-level meetings and
I'd been asked a number of times to
suggest names and these were names that
were top of mind to me just and I put
the caveat I didn't I mean I knew I knew
some of them but I couldn't in any way
presume that they would be willing and
able or that the government would even
want to go in that route but as I was
asked for potential names I provided
that content
so is it fair to say that by February 6
we've still got the notion of it of a a
negotiation strategy perhaps involving
an interlocutor on the table but we're
also looking at what a Pou enforcement
plan would look like because you've
testified at some length that you were
looking for a pob briefing up into this
weekend correct that's absolutely right
yes and if we need to go the enforcement
route then we're going to need resources
no questions and again I'm sure you're
aware but even the enforcement route
just to be clear still requires
communication negotiation engagement
de-escalation you know all of those
things remain in even in an enforcement
public order focused option fair enough
but if you're gonna end up however long
you get there if the enforcement end
you're going to need those massive
numbers of resources we've discussed
right and and was proven true right and
when we're talking about the involvement
or potential involvement of a negotiator
and lock interlocking in my goodness
interlocutor fair to say that the the
the person or the entity that the
protesters really wanted to exchange
with was the Federal Government correct
I I can't say that no I can't say that
for sure that was not your understanding
there was clearly a lot of information
on different open source channels but I
can't tell you for sure that first of
all I'm going to go back to
there wasn't a convoy or odd
demonstration or anything there were a
lot of interested parties and a lot of
them had cross purposes or no converging
purposes but there certainly was a a lot
of noise around it you know the governor
general the Prime Minister
um but I can't tell you that that was
the Domino that had to fall over for any
substantive negotiated end to these
circumstances yeah and I sorry and I
think I misspoke what I was trying to
say was you said earlier these were the
interlocutors but you couldn't say if
the government would agree to that that
was my question is who's the government
when you said that who are you referring
to
probably predominantly my mind yes the
federal government but not not
exclusively yeah fair enough that's all
I wanted to clarify
um I can keep going Mr commissioner
wrote my sense is that we're right
around one o'clock
you have a good sense so if this is a
good time we'll take the uh the lunch
break and come back in an hour
the commission is in recess for one hour
foreign
all right
order a lot
the commission has been convenient
afternoon good afternoon still Anne
tardy for the city of Ottawa
um before the break
um we had a bit of confusion around the
number of resources I want to take you
back to that chart that my friend the
lawyer for Canada have up just to avoid
any confusion so Mr clerk if we could go
to OPB four zeros1014
I think you'll you'll recognize this Mr
slowly
so this was the chart of uh uh resource
deployments for the service from all
agencies that was prepared and some
version of this went to the Police
Services Board correct yes that's
correct and if you look at the six six
zero two 2022 which was uh the date an
issue and you look at regular members
there's a total there uh in the dark
blue of 355. you see that
yes and the two days prior which would
have been the Friday and the Saturday
because of course the six is the second
weekend of the Convoy the Sunday are
roughly the same number 329 on Friday
the 4th
362 on Saturday the 5th and 3 55 on
Sunday the 6th from all services correct
that's correct and so when we saw in the
minutes of that meeting that there were
about 120 or 130 officers on the ground
that must have been uh I'm assuming that
must have been per shift
again I'm not sure where the number came
from but that would be the only logical
explanation right
um but these numbers are the ones that
that ring about to you and that you were
referencing in your testimony before the
break correct these were the most
accurate numbers although again none of
them were ever 100 accurate okay
all right
thank you for that if we could we could
turn up op
four zeros
three two five
and if we could go right down to the
bottom Please Mr Clerk and we'll work
our way up
foreign
right there so this is an email Mr
slowly from John steinbach's and I
you'll for you'll forgive me I can't
remember his exact title but I do know
part of it is Communications he's the
executive director of strategy and
Communications okay thank you so from
him uh to you and some of your uh
colleagues at the service and he says Mo
which is the mayor's office you can see
that the subject line mayor's office
request this is on Monday February 7th
and he says uh Mo mayor's office called
chair Dean's office this am advising
that we need to send a letter of
requests for Staffing to our federal
provincial counterparts prior to sending
a letter to Soul gen meeting the
solicitor general and Public Safety
Minister has this occurred yet if yes
can we bundle them all and send over to
chair and mayor if not Kevin and
Michelle are on this email and can
assist in drafting organizing John and
so my understanding at Mr slowly and I
do see this email
went to you among others is that the
mayor's office wanted to ensure that the
request had been made
Chief to commissioner as it were before
they sent a similar request for 1800
officers to their political counterparts
I don't have that understanding
um
I don't really recall the the email to
be to be frank but um
I read it the other way we need to send
we meaning the mayor and the chair need
to send a letter
to their Federal counterparts I'm
assuming that would be the premier and
prime minister prior to us sending a
letter to the solicitor general and
Public Safety minister so actually read
that the other way around
but I'm still a bit confusing for me
right because I take it in Your Capacity
as Chief you never sent a letter
requesting resources to the premier
prime minister correct nor did I send
one to the solicitor general or the
public safety Ministry fair enough and I
think that we the way I read it is
because it's John steinbach's
re-drafting the email he's the author
and he's with Ottawa Police so the way I
read it just so you understand is that
the we was police and if you read it
differently that's fine but my
understanding is uh that in the ordinary
course before you know the first level
of requests would be from Chief to
commissioner Fair
again I just I have no recollection of
the email and it it's a bit ambiguous in
the way it's written so all right can we
scroll up Let Me Be that'll help
pass the redactions
no scroll down a little bit
there we go
um sorry just up a little bit so we can
see who it's from this is from Michelle
Gautier and she works with John
steinbachs is that right she was
supporting him directly yes okay and
it's to John and and you among others
and if we scroll down
she says this is what I have so far in
terms of a requirements for immediate 30
days greater than six months getting
more details through my calls with
superintendents Etc my discussions this
am is focused on immediate needs as per
night and call we'll need a breakdown of
the officer's general duty and public
order officers in terms of immediacy so
fair to say she's trying to put together
the numbers correct yes that are being
requested of other forces yeah she's
sort of the central hub for all the
spokes of information coming in okay and
Mr clerk could we scroll up from there
please
no and this is Blair dunker now
forwarding uh the information uh because
she Blair dunker I understand is the one
who would have uh in addition to
Michelle all of the information around
resources Fair uh well she was the CIO
so I she would have had a material role
to play in all this but my recollection
actually on this email now is that
Michelle really was sort of the
quarterback of all the requests coming
in Blair would oversee our HR and
finances area so she would have an
active role I don't know if she was
practically driving the numbers in the
way that Michelle was okay and just to
make sure we've gone to the top to be
fair to you Mr slowly can we scroll all
the way up Mr clerk I think that's it
right
um and it ends with an email from from
Blair dunker so fair to say what we've
seen here is the Ottawa Police
those involved in this process
quarterbacking the resource requests and
trying to figure out what in fact they
are right that's the emails we've just
gone through I I think so the back end
of that process okay and leaving aside
this email so I'm no longer asking you
about this email but my general
understanding is that where the service
requires additional resources over and
above what it can provide in the
ordinary course the request is made from
Chief to Chief or chief to commissioner
correct that's right okay I think you've
mentioned and you've agreed that the
letter from the mayor and the chair
deans of the opsb was
um uncommon but that these were uncommon
times that's correct okay fair enough
um okay and then I don't need to bring
it up but you're obviously familiar with
the February 7th letter signed by the
chief and chair Deans sent to their
political counterparts uh in support of
the Ops request for roughly 1800
officers right correct and my
understanding and you testify to this
is that uh chair Dean's on the meeting
of February 5th directed you uh in her
capacity as chair of the board to uh
particularize your request for resources
right that's correct and after you've
done so
um
you gave it to the mayor in the chair
and in fact you briefed city council at
their February 7th council meeting
correct correct and at that council
meeting you did explain that in fact
this request for 1800 officers was being
made that's right right and once again
you said that's out of the ordinary but
given uh the events leading up to that
and the request by chair Deans that's
what happened in this case that's
correct and
a little Indulgence but um
I think I I gave this in my evidence in
Chief on Friday
um the board meeting on the fifth
the chairs commencement of that board
meeting was really around do we have the
ability to adequately effectively
provide Police Services dot dot dot
direction to Chief send us the requests
for adequate and effective the resource
request for adequate effective
Not only was this out of the norm but it
was the board I believe trying to
exercise it's one of its sole primary
functions which is getting us the
resources that we need
uh the chair and the board were very
aware of all of our efforts to get
resources including the February 5th
announcement in the middle of the
meeting that the RCMP was coming in with
250 resources so it was unusual but I
think my interpretation and I recognize
that comes with some difficulty but my
interpretation of what the chair and the
board were trying to do the mayor and
Council were trying to do was to help us
to get those resources through unusual
but direct means
thank you
um if we could now turn up Ops
00014565 Mr Clark
and while that's coming up Mr slowly you
told us that after the
the pivot to recognizing this is an
occupation on January 31st the service
had to evolve its plan right to address
these new circumstances and my
understanding is that the service did
that and we have seen I don't need to
bring it up but we have seen as part of
these proceedings a plan that's not
what's on the screen now Mr slowly a
plan that's dated February 9th and
that's referred to as the 3.0 plan
you're familiar with that plan yes so
this is uh your scribe notes of that
same day February 9th it's not the plan
but it's scribe notes of that same day
and if we scroll down Mr Clerk
right there you'll see there's reference
to a phone call that you received from
the mayor Steve Cadillac was the city
manager and Sal Jacques who's the
mayor's Chief of Staff in the afternoon
of February 9th you see that yes we do
and the Scribe indicates only her Chief
side of conversation so I think we're
safe attributing
um these bullet points uh to you
um so you explained to these City
representative that you've been in a
meeting
all morning and into the early afternoon
with the RCMP and representatives from
the Big 12 and that's the big 12 police
forces in the province of Ontario
correct that's correct uh regarding the
resource requests that went out
yesterday and I assume that's the
request for the 1800 officers or so
correct that's correct and you say
making progress but we have not gotten
one officer out of it right
yes and then a few bullets down there's
a bullet that starts with if mayor hears
anywhere do you see that
yes you say if mayor hears anywhere that
we don't have a plan we have a plan
right and that's what you were
communicating the mayor on that day
that's correct okay
um if we could turn now to Ops 00011411
and it should be
yes your scribe notes of February 10th
and I'm going to scroll to page 2 please
a little further down
and then just the call with Steve
kanalakos Mr clerk so we get perfect do
you see there at 9 48 a.m on February
10th you get a call with the city
manager yes I do right and
um again you explained to him uh and
it's the second bullet there we spent
almost 24 hours with OPP and Big 12
presented them our plan right that's
correct and although obviously the city
would not have participated in that
meeting I assume that's a reference to
the February 9th meeting that we've
heard something about in these
proceedings yeah it would actually be
the February 8th meeting out at um RCMP
headquarters and then the carryover into
February 9th at our headquarters correct
um perfect and then you'll see there's a
reference there to again we cannot do
anything more if they don't give us the
numbers that's you communicating to the
city manager that you still need
resources to action the plan correct
that's correct and below that there
you've provided somebody I don't think
we need to go through it but you've
provided some additional details to Mr
kamalakis about resources that you think
will be forthcoming including from the
opp correct that's correct so there's
reason for cautious optimism at this
point in time Fair yes and then uh if
you go to the before last bullet of the
call do you see it says we and I assume
but I'll ask you to confirm that you
mean Ottawa we are not their number one
priority their concern is Sarnia and
Windsor was that your understanding at
the time and this is February 10th
that was my understanding that's
probably more so a self-assessment than
an expressed
an explicit expression from from
there whoever there is I'm assuming
that's OPP but I I just can't put that
on them as a statement I won't do that
fair enough and then you say Chief is
low expectations and I I take it what
you mean from that was you knew it was
going to take a little bit of time for
those resources to come to Ottawa while
the situation was resolved in Windsor
there and other locations across the
province there were multiple locations
at that point
understood and one final document if I
may Mr clerk it's Ops three zeros 10373
so these are scribe notes of a meeting
on February 12th
um between yourself and other uh Ottawa
Police Service representatives and
commissioner lucky of the RCMP and
commissioner karik of the opp they're an
Ops document Mr slowly so I believe they
were taken by an Ottawa Police Service
scribe yes
um if we could go to page two Please Mr
Clerk
so do you see the comment there that's
attributed to commissioner lucky getting
exhausted that someone cannot
communicate with mayor or Steve
canalakos do you see that yes I do and I
expect that we will be asking
commissioner Lockheed what she was
referring to then at that point but
given that you're in the meeting I
thought I'd ask you whether you recall
that comment or a comment to that effect
and if you know what she may have meant
by that yeah I think there was a general
concern not just from commissioner lucky
about the accuracy of the numbers and
um you know from our standpoint
we were being promised more than we saw
on the ground
um and from the standpoints of other
agencies that I don't purport to speak
for them but that they felt that what
they had said they were going to provide
were there and available the just
numbers did not reconcile
um and by this point uh the level of
integration with the um
uh with the chief party-led team was
substantially underway
um and I think everyone was starting to
feel that with their planning and
Logistics capabilities
what they were doing centrally for the
province and even more for the country
that we would very quickly get to a
greater level of certainty if not 100
but we weren't there yet
and I mean as much as I could feel the
pressure on people saying exactly how
many people do you have I'm sure
Commissioners karik and lucky were and
other police leaders were feeling
similar pressure
I take it from all of that that's the
expression that we got
add on to that when there are statements
made in the public about this or that
then
the roll back towards the chief of
jurisdiction or Commissioner of
jurisdiction would have been substantial
so just an expression of that
frustration that the numbers that the
Ops was providing the city and the
numbers that the RCMP and OPP were
providing uh provincial and federal
politicians didn't add up an expression
of that frustration that's that's the
way I took it okay thank you very much
Mr slowly those are my questions thank
you
thank you the next is the uh
Ottawa residence Coalition please
[Music]
[Music]
good afternoon good afternoon
my name is Emily tamman I'm one of the
lawyers representing Ottawa residents
and businesses
and it's a group of community
associations and bias who are most
impacted by the Convoy occupation
and I want to start by acknowledging how
validating it is for our clients to hear
you acknowledge on Friday and again
today the significant harm and Trauma
that they experienced in the course of
the occupation
you were asked on Friday by my friend Ms
Rodriguez for the commission
whether the streets of Ottawa were more
akin to a family fun festival or a
Tinder Box waiting to explode and you'll
recall unless I mistaken that you didn't
hesitate in expressing The View that it
was more akin to a Tinder Box is that
right that's correct ma'am and with just
a little Indulgence if you don't mind
again I'm always mindful I've said this
before about pejorative terms
the overarching sense was a Tinder Box
but there were clearly
elements and areas where it was less so
and elements in areas where it was far
more so I want to be careful about that
that I think there were some
I think there were some genuine people
trying to do some genuine things and
there was a lot of disingenuous people
doing very dangerous things
so I just want to be careful about
pejorative terms but overall the sense
was a Tinder Box ready to explode for
sure and the the residents wouldn't be
attributing their experience to any
particular individual or group but that
was the reality you'd agree that they
were experiencing within their Community
yes
and so I take it then you'd agree with
me that as early as January 29th when
you had the opportunity to walk around
and witness for yourself what was
happening
um that there was Extremely Loud and
prolonged honking yes
that there were spewing diesel fumes
from idling trucks yes
uh blockading of streets yes uh
threatening and anti-social or
assaultive behavior as you've described
it yes and a general sense of chaos and
lawlessness
if I if I was a resident yes I would I
would have that sense residents or
business business owner okay and
and the significant uh trauma and
victimization that local residents and
service providers and city workers and
businesses were experiencing were caused
by a number of different things
um and that would have included again
the honking
uh the fumes
uh and I think you'd agree that also
just living under the constant threat of
potential fires and explosions as a
result of fuel canisters being stored
beside burn barrels and wooden pallets
and fireworks
a Tinderbox waiting to explode as you
described it yes ma'am
and I believe you'd agree as well that
there were a number of residents and
workers and businesses who did
experience harassment and intimidation
by some protesters yes
and and you've been very careful to say
that you would never take away from
someone's feelings and and so I take it
then that you'd agree that there was a
feeling among many in the core that they
had been abandoned by their government
and by their police I understand that
yes
so I take it then that you would agree
that enforcement activities in and
around the Red Zone not only had value
but were actually quite critical for
Public Safety absolutely yes
and my friend from the Ottawa Police
Service this morning put it to you that
your interest was more about being seen
to do something and you disagreed with
that right absolutely
and that to describe them as small wins
or a kind of pandering to residents
really grossly underestimates the
legitimate risk to Public Safety
throughout that occupation right
more than that I think it disrespects
the residents and businesses who are
actively calling for that directly
indirectly through their counselors and
through many other channels right
creation this morning
any and all complaints of criminality
would be investigated and charges laid
if warranted
and you agreed with that but subject to
the caveat that police had a wide
discretion based on officer safety right
and second caveat that we would pursue
those charges when they were more
appropriate and safe to do so right but
you wouldn't have direct knowledge of
incidents that were reported and not
investigated either due to the exercise
of Officer discretion or a simple lack
of resources do you not to that level of
detail that was a general briefings that
I was getting but exact is incidents and
that not to that level of detail no okay
and in fact there were a large number of
complaints or there were a number of
complaints
um made to Ops which would have been
difficult if not impossible to
investigate because the location and or
identity of the alleged assailants
weren't known to the complainant right
that's correct
and are you aware or maybe you've heard
in the course of these proceedings that
a counselor matzo Fleury made a report
to the Ottawa Police Service regarding
intimidation and harassment by
protesters at his personal residence
actually I'm not aware I I was aware of
something in relation to former accounts
for McKinney other public officials
um
can't recall if I spoke directly to
counselor McKinney I know I called
another
public official a very high profile
public official who was receiving some
type of threatening behavior a lot of
public officials received including
myself received direct threats as a
result of all this and councilor
Fleury's evidence before this Commission
in fact was that he reported it to
police and he never heard back from
anyone about that complaint so I think I
put that to you as an example that you
know there likely are unknown to you
numbers of of complaints that for one
reason or another in a very chaotic
environment we're not followed up on or
or investigated
I would expect and hope that there would
have been some occurrence taken whether
or not meaning of An Occurrence taken of
whatever the nature of the threat was
from councilor Fleury even if it didn't
meet the criminal threshold there would
be a record of it if not an active
investigation into it
it's not meant for any Solace to anybody
including councilor Fleury but I think
when I left office there were some five
or six or seven threats against me and
to this date I haven't received a
follow-up call yet myself right right
and so I think ultimately then you'd
agree that any available data regarding
criminal activity which was investigated
and resulted in charges
um is not necessarily a reliable
indicator of the scope of criminality in
the course of that occupation that's
correct okay it's one of the reasons why
within our requests we requested
additional investigators crime analysts
um we just couldn't keep up with the
volume of intake we needed extra
dispatchers
um so a lot of it was public order and
yes investigations but the ability even
to do
intake of complaints follow up on
complaints uh were significantly
restrained during my time in office I
suspect for weeks if not months after
all the events concluded so things like
customer service and reliability of
follow-ups were challenged always would
have been extremely challenged during
that time right okay so I'd like to ask
you a couple of questions about the lead
up to the um Convoy occupation and I
wondered whether you would agree that
two big factors
um leading to the Convoy to become so
entrenched whether as the result of
reasonable mistake or misunderstanding
or lack of information or otherwise were
number one not anticipating that this
would be a longer event than it ended up
being
like would you agree that that was a
factor that allowed the Convoy to become
so entrenched
I'm not maybe I'm not sure of the
question or or the assertion so just if
you could try one more time apologies so
perhaps if
um Ops had anticipated that it would be
a longer occupation
the type of planning that would have
taken place would have
maybe prevented them from becoming so
entrenched that that was a factor yeah
thank you you probably said it clearly
the first time it just my ears were slow
catching up
um yes but no okay so length of time
isn't the issue as much as it is the
quantity of the people that would be
saying so it was clear to me
in the week leading up that I was
getting regular briefings from the
intelligence threat risk assessment side
of things that there will be a small
group
of people staying longer but that we had
experienced those things in the past
that were well established contingency
plans and and removal plans that would
go through stages of days weeks
sometimes months and that our partners
in the NCR were well versed in how to do
that so there was always a sense that
there would be a longer portion to the
weekend demonstration involving a
smaller group of occupiers
um what we did not have and to this day
I still have not been able to see even
in hindsight is there will be a massive
number of people who will remain behind
for weeks if not months and they will be
engaging in a wide range of social
disorder and criminal assaultive type
behaviors for that entire period right
and that's fair you've been cleared
probably one of the missing pieces was
the number of people who would stay
and would you agree then
and again not asking you necessarily
about the reasonableness yet at this
point but that had the trucks not been
allowed to enter the corps it likely
would have been more difficult for the
protesters to have become as entrenched
as they did
um
again
um yes but no
um
entering the core meaning entering
Wellington Street and the immediate
streets
east and west of that
I have heard this even before the Convoy
events arrive but closing down our core
closing down our inter-provincial
bridges
for any reason are hugely problematic
and they create a range of Public Safety
and Community Wellness issues for
example I believe it was in the late
spring of
2021 where there was a provincial order
that related to
the pandemic that inter-provincial
Bridges and access points be closed
there is very little if any material
consultation with the Ottawa Police
Service that of all the police with
jurisdiction in Ontario had the biggest
impact by that order and it causes
significant Staffing challenge we did
close the bridges to the letter in the
first 24 hours but the pushback was
massive and immediate from the health
care sector from the business sector
closing things anywhere in the downtown
core anything in the downtown court it's
going to cause a range of Public Safety
wellness and economic impacts on the
city
the concept of closing the entire
downtown core I think you've heard from
other Witnesses would probably use as
many resources as it took for the public
order operation some 2 000 officers
would have been required to come in and
it took the better part of a week and a
half to get those officers here so the
assumption that if we had known we could
have locked down the downtown core it
would have still taken seven to ten days
to get that many officers in here to
execute that plan and then the impact on
the city of Ottawa and the greater
Ottawa gato area might have been greater
than the public safety problem we were
trying to prevent in the first instance
okay well I appreciate that and so but
do you recall at the January 26 special
uh board meeting of the Police Services
Board where Matthew Fleury counselor
Fleury asked you about the possibility
of at least holding trucks to truck
routes and that you indicated at that
time or he says that you indicated to
him that you had received a legal
opinion that the charter would preclude
that activity
based on your understanding of the
expected Public Safety risks at that
time I don't I recall the truck route
comment I believe my comment was in
relation to the broader discussion can
we block the downtown Cork and we block
them from coming into the city and that
was the context in which I gave my
response and again it was the 26th
that's I would have already had my my
legal advice from my general counsel and
by then I think the 27th was when we
requested external legal advice which
essentially supported the same position
and when you say external legal advice
are you referring to Ops Legal Services
Ops Legal Services sought external legal
advice to bolster their own opinion that
they had provided internally not to
bolster but to validate one way or the
other their own opinion internally okay
but there doesn't seem to be any record
of that internal opinion is that fair
I I'm not aware but that was a question
I asked of my own general counsel and
you recall asking that question yes I do
okay
um
and
um I'm gonna just bring you to some of
the other evidence that we've heard and
get you to comment on it so
um deputy chief Bell testified that he
believed that Ottawa Police did have the
authority to stop Vehicles entering into
the city but that because the service
had successfully managed vehicle convoys
in the past it wasn't viewed as
necessary
I'm not sure if you're aware I don't
recall his testimony
in that way yeah so I apologize no need
to apologize
um and my review of acting uh deputy
chief Ferguson's evidence was that she
couldn't recall whether a legal opinion
had been sought but that like uh deputy
chief bell based on Decades of past
experience managing events Ops believed
it had the capacity to manage trucks in
the core
again I I've watched much of their
testimony I just can't recall those
specific elements but is it possible do
you think that you never did receive a
legal opinion before January 28th and
that in fact the question of whether to
stop trucks coming into the core never
arose I I wouldn't have gone to external
Council unless I'd started with my own
Council first okay
[Music]
let's move on to another topic then if
you don't mind sir uh
you had a discussion this morning with
one of the council about the role that
Navigator played uh in the course of
your managing of the occupation
and if I could just ask Mr clerk for you
to pull up a document please it's Ops
four zeros 5912
this would have been on the commission's
list of documents
foreign
and if we could just um go back down to
the start of the chain
okay
so here we have an email can you just go
up a Teensy bit more yeah from uh giant
John steinbox from corporate
Communications
to uh Aaron Kelly and Lee Thompson now
who are they
that's with Advanced symbolics
Incorporated
so that's ASI that's correct and what is
that exactly
a private company that that uses open
source information
I'm gonna not I'm not gonna do a great
job on the company's description but to
a degree it's sentiment analysis but it
also tends to predict
um
small P predict what opinion will be
around different different topics okay
and in that first inquiry if we could
just scroll down a little bit
um the question is are there any
sentiment indicators
you can provide us relating to and then
it lists a number of issues so and and
sorry what's your understanding of what
a sentiment indicator is
um
again I'm probably doing a disservice to
this company but um broadly speaking in
the industry
uh a a a scrape of social media
sentiment expressed on various platforms
um and then rating it one way or the
other positive neutral negative okay
and what was the purpose of seeking this
information
again to see how people within our
community a million people across the
largest Municipal geography in in Canada
the second largest in North America were
feeling around an incident that was
happening unfolding in a very very small
area again to see we had policing
responsibilities across the city and we
obviously had increasing police
responsibilities in this micro
percentage point in the Heart of the
City
and you would have received regular
briefings from ASI I take it by email
over the course of the
time that you were managing the
application
okay so if we could go back up to the
first page please so this is now an
email dated February 3rd
uh again from Aaron Kelly
uh to yourself and others
um within the Ottawa Police and it it
starts High team we ran the scenario the
chief asked
uh what if we were to take further
action and what happened in Alberta were
to happen in Ottawa so what did you mean
when you asked what happened in Alberta
so cute Alberta was happening almost
concurrently I forget whether it started
on the same day the 29th that that our
events happened or escalated
um and I recall whether it was a Sunday
or the Monday
um but early in the week there was an
attempt
by the Coots by the the operational
well there's an operation attempting to
remove the blockade and Coots
and I could see just from mainstream
media and I believe I got a briefing
later on from commissioner lucky that it
wasn't successful that literally within
minutes
uh what looked like a well-planned and
well-staffed exercise was frustrated and
and failed uh within minutes by a wide
variety of of countermeasures whether
they were planned and exercised before
they were just done in the spur of the
moment
um and my concern was that if that was
on a two-lane Highway in a very rural
part of Canada with no other buildings
on sides of the road and no density and
no school zones or anything else
a much smaller footprint of vehicles and
protesters and a proportionately much
larger amount of available resources if
it failed so quickly then any effort
that we would do here could be extremely
dangerous so it was in that context that
I asked that question okay so you're
you're asking for their assessment of
what would be the impact on
public sentiment vis-a-vis the Ottawa
Police service if there were to be a
failed operation to dismantle the Convoy
or to yeah I don't know if I put the
emphasis on the fail but just on the
operation as a whole okay
um but yes okay fair and so Aaron Kelly
then goes on to say having undertaken
that assessment
currently under 10 of people in Ottawa
are experiencing deep concern about how
the trucker Convoy is being handled
most of these people are downtown that
that wouldn't be surprising to you right
but the mo the people the most concerned
were the people that were experiencing
it
if you were to take an Alberta type
action you would get a 10 lift in public
opinion from Centertown residents
because they're happy you took action
but you would take a 50 hit from
residents in other parts of the city who
are currently not expressing any concern
with the situation
if things went South like in Alberta
then they would blame the Ottawa Police
for the missta
so why would it matter what the
sentiment indicators were for residents
unaffected by
and unconcerned about the freedom Convoy
it really didn't matter to me at this
point to be honest I'd already had my
meeting on February 1st in Canada with
the public order Commanders
the level of effort that we would have
to have the scale would be as I said
somewhere between the
700 range to the thousand plus range to
even begin to contemplate an operation
that happened in Coots so I mean I don't
want to say it was too little too late
whatever modeling was taking place here
it really was immaterial the situation
in here just required a scale that we
couldn't contemplate a similar operation
so the the circumstances on the ground
ground were just changing so rapidly
that you weren't even really
contemplating a Coots in alberta-like
intervention by the time you receive
this analysis yes and and importantly to
the point I think you were making and if
I if I get it wrong I'm sure you'll
correct me but
um
understanding we brought in ASI to
understand the budget implications
that's the original contract of ASI was
around the almost year-long budget
debate that happened in throughout 2021
in which case
the budget expectations and needs of a
farmer
out in the outskirts of Ottawa was as
important as
a condominium dweller or a business
owner in downtown
Ottawa but in terms of to your point the
people that were most directly impacted
traumatized victimized where the people
living immediately with within the red
zone or around the red zone and so while
it was somewhat
interesting to know how people felt more
broadly
the victimization was happening in a
micro location and the risk was
happening in a micro location 98 99 of
what we were dealing with was within one
percent of the geography of the city and
so it was an interesting exercise it
didn't prove fruitful and and the the
scale of the operation that ultimately
was required made this a rather less
than productive exercise
but you did continue to get updates from
ASI throughout kind of gauging so in
fact if you scroll up to the very top
Please Mr clerk you'll see
um you know anger against Ops is down 10
from yesterday you know you're trending
in the right direction so I mean I guess
what I'm asking is
do you see why some residents might be
concerned that there was a preoccupation
with
um almost a PR matter
um when you know they were going through
something really tough absolutely I can
see why and as I've said uh commissioner
to you and others public trust is a
direct equation to Public Safety and
what might look like a PR exercise to
some is is as rudimentary attempt as we
could in the crisis that we're having to
get a sense that we're public trust lay
um I could look at crime stats up and
down but I can tell you you can actually
have crime going the wrong way and
public trust going the right way for
instance underreported sexual assault
and domestic assault
when you can win public trust what
happens is you get an immediate spike in
reporting right and so sometimes a crime
Trend up is an indication of public
trust up and I've learned that over the
decades in policing it's important to
keep an eye on trust indicators as much
as it is important to keep an eye on
crime or victimization indicators they
are necessarily coupled this was our
best effort in the middle of a crisis to
try to do some of that but it was by no
means a perfect effort it was quite
imperfect as you can see okay understood
so just one last area I want to ask you
a few questions about
um in your testimony on Friday you
indicated that misinformation and
disinformation caused a number of
challenge are causing challenges as far
as policing is concerned right yes
and
uh you you agree and I believe you
agreed on Friday that there was a
perception in the public
um that there were elements within your
Police Service who and other police
services who were sympathetic or even
supportive of the freedom Convoy yes
right
but if I understood your evidence
correctly it's your view that the public
perception in that regard was based on
misinformation or disinformation
I wasn't um that black or white never is
in my world anyway
um no I I mean I think legitimately
there would be
within communities that were directly
impacted and and those that were
literally within line of sight question
a lot of things again without having
background information or other contexts
would question those things
I know that there were complaints coming
in and every one of those complaints
that came to my attention were assigned
to our Professional Standards Bureau for
a review and any one of those reviews
that showed misconduct were then
assigned for proper investigation during
my time I suspended one officer
um I don't know what the status of that
case is right now so to any extent where
there was a reasonableness to a
complaint around not sympathy but
actions that in any way undermine our
ability to keep the city and the
community safe and and bring about a
successful safe outcome we took
documented formal measured actions
okay and I appreciate that more
um detailed and nuanced answers because
certainly I think your evidence on
Friday might have left the impression
that you rejected completely that any
high five or selfie or fist bump could
be anything but a calculated effort at
de-escalation and so that's not your
evidence I appreciate the chance to
clarify that with some subtlety the
majority of it I believe were genuine
officer efforts keep people calm and
situations calm but I can't rule out
that some element of that at some point
could have been more nefarious
okay I'll appreciate that
um and
you're aware then I take it
um of reports in the media and you may
even be aware of this from your own
tenure as chief that there are at least
two dozen current and former members of
the Ops who have been identified as
donors to the Gibson go campaign that
was raising money to support the Convoy
occupation I've seen some media reports
but that information wasn't available to
me during my time as chief
and are you aware of uh recent media
reports
um of the that there's a um review by
Professional Standards
into a member of the Ops intelligent
unit intelligence unit Sergeant Chris
keys
uh who authored a pre-convoy
intelligence report that expressed
sympathy to protesters
um against covid-19 public health
mandates described the Convoy protesters
as mainstream and holding opinions that
are you know the views of the silent
majority of Canadians are you aware have
you read any reports of this no I
haven't okay and there there is um a
document in the disclosure that
particular report that has been reported
in the media as raising concerns about
the
a perceived double standard between how
um left wing or as as Keys describes the
professional protesters
um and characterizing this particular
occupation as more of a Grassroots real
authentic movement were you aware of any
Sentiments of that nature among your
members in your time as chief
um
I was going to answer but then you threw
a little curve at the end so I just want
to make sure I don't answer the wrong
question but there is a point I would
like to make to the commissioner and
yourself so if you can just repeat the
last part just so I get the question
right well I was wondering whether you
were aware that there is at least a
perception of a double standard and how
some kinds of protesters be they you
know associated with the defund police
movement or black lives matter or
environmental protesters or indigenous
protesters on the one hand
and a movement like this one on the
other
um so I was not aware of of any
complaint or or internal matter in
regards to that that member just I'll
put that aside
um but I think your question is
important commissioner I would sort of
engage you more directly with your
Indulgence but
um this has been something that I saw
during my tenure as chief of police it
was something that I saw during my time
in the private sector and it is
something with less Clarity but in in
general a trend in regards to
intelligence gathering threat
assessments at
local provincial national International
levels
there is a bias and I've spoken very
publicly about systemic bias in policing
and not limited to systemic racism in in
every aspect of of humanity
I saw this during my time in Kosovo and
peacekeeping after 9-1-1 happened
there was a significant shift
operationally politically
socioeconomically geopolitically to the
threat that was posed by
the various terms around radical Islam
and Islamic based terrorism
when I was in private sector I was
invited by Public Safety Canada to be
the co-chair of a committee of citizens
from across the country looking at
online radicalization to violence and
terrorism
and we received a briefing from cesus
including senior RCMP officials on the
current state of uh of the national
threat assessment this would be the
summer of 2019.
18 months before the arrival of the
Convoy but this is also the time that we
had the incel van attack in Toronto this
is also the time that we had seen a rise
of right-wing extremism white supremacy
and violent events South of the Border
and increasing levels of violence and
recruitment north of the Border
presentation that we got on the national
threat assessment had no mention
whatsoever zero
of right-wing extremism in white
supremacy
question that was asked of me is this a
concern of mine it was a concern of mine
in my days with the Toronto Police
Service
in peacekeeping missions in private
sector on a public safety Canada
committee
and as the chief of police here in
Ottawa I would validate that concern
and and just a final question then I
take it then that you would violently
agree that uh in order to rebuild trust
in policing institutions generally but
specifically here in Ottawa after the
events of January and February of this
year that it will be important for the
organization to sort of confront those
biases straight on and not be shy to
recognize when its own members fall
short
um by engaging in that kind of
um unfortunate analysis
uh first of all I'm probably out of
order here but your line of questioning
has been excellent and and how your
probing is helpful for me I hope it'll
be for the commissioner
um
it's almost entirely the reason I was
brought here man that's why they
recruited me
because I have an outspoken track record
over decades not just when it was
popular to do so to confront racism and
discrimination in any form in policing a
profession that I dearly love and
devoted my life to
but one that I know not because so much
of individual factors because we're just
human beings and we are incredibly
imperfect but incredibly imperfect human
beings will build really imperfect
systems
and those systems can have very bad
impacts on communities usually the most
marginalized and racialized communities
and I have been outspoken on those
matters and I've dedicated the bulk of
my leadership to addressing them when I
came to Ottawa commissioner that's
exactly why I was recruited to come here
that's the Mandate I was given and that
I did that every day I held my office
until the last day
and it is singularly the number one
reason for the resistance to me the
undermining of me
and so yes that was a priority for me on
day one and it was still a priority for
me on day last one
okay thank you very much those are my
questions sir
thank you next I'd like to call on the
opp
good afternoon sir Chris Diana for the
opp good afternoon sir just a couple of
topics that I'd like to discuss with you
the first one relating to OPP assistants
that was received by Ops during this
time
as a general proposition I'm sure that
you would agree with me that the opp
provided a significant level of
assistance to the Ottawa Police Service
from the beginning to the end of the
convoys plural presence in Ottawa yes
sir
and even before the Convoy arrived the
opp was already offering to provide
assistance correct yes sir
now we've seen text messages between you
and commissioner karik is it fair to say
that you communicated with the
commissioner karik
almost every day if not every day during
the course of late January until the
time until the day you left yes sir
so we can go please to opp4586
all right so these are the text messages
that I was referring to between you and
the commissioner
and it starts off I believe the first
one
says good afternoon Tom just left you a
voicemail please have a listen and call
me back at your earliest convenience uh
it's January
correct yes sir and I take it even day
before you had already established kind
of a relationship with commissioner
Curry where you felt you could discuss
issues yeah sorry just one small at the
27th is a Thursday uh 28th of Friday
29th technically that the Convoy started
arriving on the 27th
technically in trickles yeah um a little
bit more on the 28th to Friday and then
the big wave tsunami on the 29th yes
thanks for clarifying you are correct I
I always think of it as a 28th because
that's when a lot of them really started
to come in but I guess the point that
I'm trying to make here is that even
early stages before many of the people
and trucks arrive you've already got an
established relationship with
commissioner Creek I had an established
relationship with him throughout my
entire tenure as as chief of police he
was incredibly assisting on a number of
issues
okay so please scroll down we got
January 28th which is the next day my
understanding based on what we've heard
before is that the time stamp is
actually five hours earlier than the
time actually stamped and that appears
to be a text from the commissioner hi
Peter just checking in to ensure you
have everything you need your response
was to thank him for checking in and
your response is as it says all good
right now we greatly appreciate the
public order support please also keep
the Intel coming that's on January 28th
correct yes sir all right and so you're
at this stage happy with how the OBP has
stepped up and offered that kind of
assistance as well as the Intel I very
rarely use the term happy but I am very
satisfied yes that's fair enough
for that first weekend we've heard
evidence prior that the opp provided
Frontline officers in addition to public
order unit members is that your
understanding
yes although
fairness I Now understand the POU were
not underneath our incident command but
they were certainly within the theater
yes
if we can go down to page three
we're looking for the time that stamped
11 February this is February 4th we're
looking for the time to stamped 1107.
there we go so this is to situate you
sorry this is February the 4th
it says Peter over and above the number
of people we have supporting checking in
to ensure you are receiving the level of
support in Council you were hoping to
receive from our PLU cic and PLT command
group that is contributing to your
concepts of operations and planning
process scroll down
and you've asked for a quick call
scroll down again
okay and so he was available at your
convenience so again on February 4th
we're a few days into this now the
commissioner is again reaching out by
text to make sure you've got everything
you need correct yes sir and that's
consistent with how the commissioner was
available to you throughout this time
period yes sir
all right can we go to another document
I'm going to go back to this one
eventually but let's go do ops 7455
all right so if we can go down to the
bottom of page one
all right so stop there this is an email
again to situate you an email from
yourself to commissioner karik February
4th 5 30 p.m scroll down
and here again you can read it just as
well as I can where you're expressing
your appreciation for the your word
significant and ongoing support that the
commissioner and his team have provided
to the Ops over the course of the
demonstrations and you refer to OPP
officers demonstrating the highest
levels of professionalism and work ethic
and that their turnout is universally
top shelf I'm curious what you mean by
turnout I'm not sure what that turn of
phrase means they're addressing
Department the way they presented
themselves which is quite frankly the
most
positive level in the earliest level of
of office reinforcement just a
professional image of an officer and
they were really top shelf just across
the board and I take it that I mean this
is you obviously show on your
appreciation for the support you've been
given but I take it this is a genuine
email I take it from the from the tone
of that that you generally did
appreciate that you could have done blah
blah blah blah blah their turnout was
universally top shelf I was telling the
commissioner of the largest Police
Service outside of the RCMP that whoever
they selected however they arrived here
they showed up looking good and and gave
me confidence that they would do good in
the circumstances that they're here okay
so we can can we go back to the tax
exchange please which is OPP 4586
and let's go to page six
so we're looking at if you scroll down a
little bit we're looking for February
7th at the time stamped is 10 58.
all right so it says hi Peter at your
convenience can we connect regarding
Opera operationalizing the request for
additional police resources that the
province received from the mayor thanks
do you see that yes sir and your
response hello Tom I've consulted with
Deputy Ferguson and the resource
planning team will be established within
the current Ops incident command
inspector Palmer will be the correct or
contact point for your OPP team
so do you recall that Exchange
I do that the Gap in
three hours is probably some other
conversation that we had but this is the
understanding that
we've discussed that integration a
greater level of integration
he was going to send some of his best
not just planners but operational
leaders
uh Chief superintendent party's name was
one of those and I welcomed it welcomed
the support of expertise and experienced
leaders and welcomed the greater level
of integration and this is just me
advising yep I got Point people on our
side to make this thing happen as
quickly as possible yes and you also
indicated that this would be under ops
command so I guess you're just being
clear so there's no misunderstanding
that this is an Ops operation that's
what we had agreed to in our
conversations that you're not coming in
to run our shop you're coming in to help
our shop run at a higher level and I
take it the commissioner respected those
jurisdictional boundaries at all times
not only did he respect them he
understood that what we needed was help
we we did not need and I think he's I
won't put words in his mouth but I think
his testimony ultimately said that there
wasn't a need to come in right and
because we understand under the police
services act the opp just can't walk
into another police or is it
jurisdiction and take over right well it
can't and it shouldn't and there should
always be a reason
and there's only very limited exceptions
that would even allow that under the
police services act that's my
understanding sir yes and you felt at
the time that the Ops was more than
capable of handling this with extra help
that's correct and I kind of don't want
to speak for the commissioner but I
believe that that's what he shared with
me throughout our daily calls and
nothing changed to my last day in office
and in addition and I don't need the
that document any further you're
probably also aware that during this
period of time the commissioner also
chaired various calls almost every day
with Big 12 or oacp to help coordinate
further resources correct again that was
a phone call that commissioner Creek and
I had I think it was the first weekend
um a suggestion that I had made that we
have some sort of a convened group of
police leaders I think I was focused
mostly in Ontario and as commissioner
Creek would often do he said you know
what let's let's get on that we'll run
that for you Peter you're busy and then
what he established was more than I
requested and grew in in a relatively
short period of time right and you may
be aware you may not have seen the
document it's an opp document but he
sent correspondence out to other police
services trying to integrate all that
absolutely I was very much aware of it
without even seeing the documentation I
I had that sense he was lifting that to
the highest level possible
and so you understand of course that the
opp provided not only boots in the
ground but a lot of Specialists as well
and services such as Logistics Aviation
PLT undercover incident commanders
planners PLU yes sir
and did you hear commissioner Creek's
evidence for the most part yes sir one
of the comments he made was that when it
comes to providing assistance the opp
unfortunately doesn't have extra
officers that he can take off a shelf
and send where they're needed do you
recall him saying that I do I feel his
pain and so he also indicated that every
Frontline officer that goes to help with
Ottawa or Windsor or anywhere
uh if taken out of a community where
that officer would usually work I had
the same experience in Toronto where we
had to move hundreds of officers on a
regular basis to other jurisdictions and
they were not they were not available
for their primary duties in Toronto and
so you can recognize that when and I
believe the OPP's institutional report
and I won't pull it up I think the
maximum number of Frontline officers on
any given day was 463 on one day in
Ottawa you would recognize and
understand the kind of strain that could
put on the opp and the other communities
of polices absolutely sir
all right the other area I'd like to
move on to intelligence because I think
one of the things we're trying to figure
out here is kind of what happened and
how do we do things better going forward
so we need to figure out what happened
on the intelligence side
I've spoken about the different levels
of assistance but I'm sure you would
agree that the Hendon reports and the
daily conference calls on intelligence
were another form of assistance provided
by the OPP yes sir
I believe your evidence was and if I
misstate it please correct me was that
you became aware of the January 13th
Tenon report you received it
you understandably had a lot of a lot of
other things on your plate at the time
and so you asked deputy chief Bell to
conduct an intelligence review is that
correct
uh no well it is mostly correct but just
I asked deputy chief Bell to oversee to
oversee not to conduct himself the
intelligence threat risk assessment that
would then inform acting deputy chief
Ferguson who was assigned the role of
developing the operational plan and
intelligence-led operational plan that
was reliant on the intelligence threat
risk assessment the Hendon reports would
be one of many things that would go into
the intelligence threat risk assessment
and that made sense of course because
Deputy Bell at the time was responsible
for intelligence part of
portfolio yes
and Deputy Ferguson was responsible for
planning yes
and if I get the chain of command
incorrect then please correct me but
under Deputy Bell would it would it be
superintendent Patterson at the time on
the intelligence side
I believe so yes
now when it comes to deputies Bell and
Ferguson you did give some evidence
about a lot of the changes that were
taking place and the challenge that you
had in senior command
colvid turnover other things
but neither had been in their positions
for long correct that's correct that the
transition had happened at the command
level I think the last week of or second
last week of December 2021 and then
functionally it flowed down into the
first week for superintendents
inspectors and civilian equivalents yeah
yeah but both of them were senior
officers though right they had been with
the Ops for a long time yes and both had
many years of experience dealing with
large protests in Ottawa I I don't know
to what extent Deputy Bell had I don't
think he had as deep experience in that
area is
acting deputy chief Ferguson but yes
they would have both been around and
seen and been involved in to some degree
events I think acting Deputy Ferguson's
actual experience as a critical incident
commander and training was a little bit
more than deputy chief Bells but either
way you trusted in their ability to
review the intelligence and prepare an
appropriate plan correct yes sir
now you testified that you did not
review the hennan reports in detail that
for the most part you skimmed them when
they came in
I read reports in detail but not
everyone I skimmed other reports and
sometimes I would not have had time to
open my email but again at that point I
would have known that these reports were
being sent to individual members within
within the audible Police Service but
particularly within the intelligence
section right because there were a
number of Ops members on the
distribution list so you trusted in your
team to review them and to keep you
apprised that's necessary correct as
necessary yes sir
and I take it that once you've skimmed
kind of or once you saw the first
sending report I expect that you knew
that that could be a valuable source of
information as the Convoy made its way
across yes sir that's why my
recollection to this day is that I
forwarded it on but I stand correct
now I take it you did not participate in
the daily Hendon conference calls no sir
and that's something you would have
relied on either Deputy Bell or
superintendent Patterson or someone
within that someone would have had that
delegated responsibility yes
are you testified that it was your
expectation that this would primarily be
a weekend long event correct yes sir
with a small group remaining behind
right now this is what you were told by
your team you're not coming to your own
assessments necessarily at this point
you're relying on your team to tell you
that that's the sum total of of the
balance of information and the and the
threat risk assessment that came from it
that was brief to me right and so I
believe in your witness summer you
indicated that you were advised by
Deputy Bell
that he expected the vast majority would
leave at the end of the weekend or
shortly thereafter yes sir
did he tell you and this is where I just
want to get into kind of your own
personal awareness of what was in the
Hendon reports kind of when you knew did
Deputy Bell tell you that there were a
number of indications in the Hendon
reports that suggested there could be a
lengthier stay
um again I just want to be careful the
briefings I was getting from deputy
chief Bell are are what the briefings
were passed up to him sorry can you say
that again briefings that Deputy Bell
provided where the substance of
briefings that he received
um so I just want to be careful he's not
the intelligence Commander he's not the
the LP ops's version of superintendent
Morris right just to be clear no that
that's good clarification but you're
hearing it from from Deputy Bell and
Deputy Bell can kind of speak for
himself as to where he heard it or who
he heard it from or who briefed him
you're hearing it from Deputy Bell
correct yes sir
and so my question was did you hear from
the deputy Bell inform you of some of
the warnings in the Hendon reports
um
I don't have explicit recollection of
explicit lines from the Hendon report
and and nor would I expect I would
expect and received briefings that said
on total the balance of what we're
getting here's what I'm being told in
totality
as opposed to there's a line in the
Hendon report that says X there's a
tweet that says why and there's an
Instagram video that shows Zed
what I was getting was a roll-up
briefing not attributed to the exact
exact data source where it came from did
we at some point discuss explicitly the
Hendon report or reports probably but at
a macro level at an aggregate level as
opposed to a
line by line detailed analysis and
whether or not all of that added up to X
I was getting briefings in the sum total
of balance of intelligence information
available because ultimately as a chief
you need the higher level right so you
don't necessarily need to hear the
details you need to hear from Deputy
Bell who needs to hear from his people
look this is going to be a weekend event
or this is the sum total of what the
problems could be correct yes sir and so
uh
but Deputy Bell again just so I
understand this your understanding was
this would be a weekend event and was
that kind of the the summation of what
you were told by Deputy we can event
with a small group that would be
remaining behind with some level of
occupying but nothing that we had not
seen in previous events but he did not
say look we think this is going to be a
weekend event but there's some
indications that suggest it actually
could be a long term event
okay um so
we looked at the range of what I was
getting a briefing on the range of what
this could be and yes there were
certainly in some of those briefings
this could be longer term but the sum
total of it came back to
consistent briefing of the threat risk
assessment multi-day event primarily
over the Saturday Sunday smaller group
remaining behind something that we've
dealt with in the past
that's what we're planning for all right
and I'm going to ask if you at the time
and this is pretty erupt and I apologize
I am interrupting you but don't worry
there was the other end this is all a
overblown social media thing this group
may never even make it here if they do
it could be
a relatively small thing
we never cancel anything out but the
aggregate of the assessment landed where
we were now but were both possibilities
being given as kind of equal
probabilities that it might be it's
equally likely they're here for the long
term and equally likely they're not
coming in and In fairness no I don't
think there was an algorithm attached to
that that that that level of
sophistication I'm not sure exists
anywhere but but it certainly wasn't the
level of detailed and and mathematical
equation that you may be vindicating but
I was given a reasonable overview of the
reasonable Spectrum around which it
could be and then an assessment on the
balance of probabilities what it was
planned to be all right so what I'm
trying to understand now is again and I
know you were briefed and then that was
primary source more than your own review
with the Hendon reports correct yes and
so I'm just trying to understand kind of
what you knew before the Convoy arrived
did you know for example that the uh the
the reports indicated that there was no
exit strategy I believe I saw that at
some point in a Hendon report but again
I just want to be clear
I can't tell you how many pres protests
and demonstrations pop up or planned
where the presence or absence of an exit
strategy were weighted in any
significant way I'm just telling you
what my experience has been okay and did
you know that the intent was to remain
in Ottawa until all mandates and
restrictions had been lifted again I
just want to be careful about pejorative
language it was clear in a variety of
forums and reports including the hand
and report that they could not speak for
every person that was planning to or
talking about coming
so that much was clear to me that and in
reports or other reports social media
monitoring that was happening canvassing
of various people PLT actions was clear
over and over again there is no one
entity called the Convoy there is no one
person who represents the protesters and
so everything that I got briefed on had
explicitly or implicitly this is what
we're getting from some this is what
others are saying they got a line here
that says this but we can't extrapolate
that to mean this that's the context in
which the majority of the briefings were
coming to me and the reason I asked in
particularly the last point I think is
is an interesting one about their stated
intention to remain until the mandates
and restrictions were lifted because
it's it's one thing to say there's no
access strategy it's another to set a
specific goal before they leave and
that's something that you probably
wouldn't have experienced before is it
uh no actually
um many demonstrations
76 days straight in front of the U.S
embassy when NATO was bombing in
Yugoslavia
we're not leaving until the war's over I
mean you can stand on a corner here and
watch somebody raped in a Ukraine flag
I'm not leaving until the war's over so
that's a relatively common the Tamil
events in in Toronto and I believe here
in Ottawa all had that sense we are here
to support what's going on over there
and we're not leaving here until over
there is better or completed that's a
pretty regular item but what's not right
I just put to you what's not regular is
that the protesters would come all the
way across Canada have millions millions
of dollars of fundraising have lots of
trucks and people all converging with
that stated goal that's not regular is
it again I want to be careful not all of
them had that stated goal and not all of
them came from across Canada a lot of
them came from right here in this good
old city as well too so again I just
want to be really careful I I don't
operate in pejorative terms that is a
universal application of anything good
or bad to any group is never fair to any
one individual in that group
and I I can't take that position no I
understand that but I think what we're
trying to do here is to try to figure
out to what extent the planning here was
based on the actual intelligence that
was being received or as I would suggest
it was based more on experience of Ops
and others that have seen a lot of
protests come and go and that perhaps
there might have just been a bit of an
over emphasis on what had happened in
the past
yeah I I I'm I'm certainly going to be
agreeing with you that it was a little
bit of both it was a lot of both I can't
tell if it was 49 versus 51 on any
particular topic but I think there was
some good evidence presented and it's
certainly been my experience that you
you go based on imperfect intelligence
and you go based on imperfect experience
and you try to project forward what is
the most likely outcome that's going to
happen and then you build a plan that
will not only address the threat that
you've now gone through that process on
but not cause additional problems beyond
that
now I know we're looking back at it and
we have a certain lens because we can
look back at what happened but when we
look back isn't the the issue isn't the
quality of the Hendon reports isn't the
issue the fact that Ottawa Police just
didn't take them seriously enough
absolutely not so first of all the issue
isn't they had been reported I don't
know when it became the issue maybe for
the opp you see it as the issue for me I
don't see it as the issue and I don't
know any member of my Police Service
former police service that said you know
what this is all on the Hendon report oh
if OPP had done a better job I actually
never heard that I've never said that
I've never heard that
because it hadn't reports in fact were
actually very useful tools right I
always said they were
I would say though and commissioner I've
met references to you on Friday
I think the opp did an outstanding job
I'm not sure it was their job to provide
National threat intelligence assessments
I'm grateful they did because otherwise
it wouldn't have gotten done from any
other form that I know of but I don't
think it's fair to the opp
to do that thank heavens they did it I
just don't think it's fair to them it's
a structural deficit that the opp did
their best to fill but it's actually not
the job of a Provincial Police Service
to provide National threat risk
assessments on what was a national event
from beginning to end
I'm not sure you would get any
disagreement with the opp on that point
but I guess again looking back at things
with the hindsight which is what we're
forced to do here of course
the warrant a lot of the warnings in the
handling reports were correct right A
lot of them were incorrect but a lot of
them were correct and a lot of them were
incorrect sir again it's not an
indictment of the Hannon report and I
don't want my answers to you to seem
that I'm somehow blaming a deficiency
but they are like most intelligence
reports they get some of it right and
some of it wrong and you never know
until after the event what was right and
what was wrong
the we heard some evidence from
superintendent Bernier who indicated
that even though that wasn't his role at
the time he did happen to see some henon
reports and his evidence was that they
were in his view comprehensive and like
nothing he usually would see in advance
of a typical demonstration
I would agree with superintendent
Bernier that the Hendon reports were one
of the better intelligence documents
that I had seen I'd seen some
outstanding examples and I'd seen at
least one that was even better
but it was one of the better ones but I
want to be cautious superintendent
Bernie Acting Superintendent Berner then
inspector Bernier because he was an
inspector was not involved in the
incident command system he was not
involved in getting daily briefings he
was not involved in the threat risk
assessment he like many members of the
Ottawa Police Service were picking up a
little bit of data and he had an opinion
but I think even he cautioned that his
opinion was less informed and not fully
appropriate given that he was not
involved
so Deputy Ferguson's evidence was that
this that the plan that was prepared
presumably under her own watch was not
intelligence-led that was her evidence
would you agree with her or disagree
with her that was her evidence but I
have to tell you that's alarming that
she felt that was the case then she
really needed to have worked harder on
it so at the end just to get the the
answer you would disagree with her then
on that point
I never heard her say at any point
in any of the briefings that we had that
there was a misalignment uh an under
developed plan and one that she wanted
to change substantially the plan I
received from her on February 28th was
one that I received With No Reservations
from her I sent back some minor feedback
and I heard
nothing else from her until she gave
testimony before the commissioner and
said some things that were very
concerning all right thank you sir I
appreciate your happiness
thank you
next I believe it's the Canadian
constitutional
constitute Foundation
Mr slowly uh good afternoon my name is
suji Chaudhary I am counsel for the CCF
um I'd like to begin my questions to you
by referring to the theme of your uh
conversation with my friend Ms Nygaard
from the government of Canada and and I
think that that my recollection uh is
that you agreed with her that there was
no need for the Ops or for that matter
for the city of Ottawa uh to reach out
to the opp or the province first
before going to the RCMP
for assistance it was perfectly
appropriate
for the Ops to go to the RCMP directly
in parallel
without reach to the opp because Ottawa
is the seat of the federal government
and on federal institutions
um up until the last comment around the
seat of anything
my comments were that were exactly that
at that time I was trying to get
resources from any source and I didn't
have a priority in my mind as to what
sequence I should go through I was
simply actioning a series of requests to
agencies that were large enough and near
enough to provide immediate resource
relief to what we were facing at that
time good so so let me take you back
uh to when you um dramatically increased
your request for resources and I'm
speaking here of the February 7th
letters
uh one sent to the province
uh one sent to uh the federal government
I'd like to focus on the federal letter
if I may so it was a letter from chair
Deans
and mayor Watson to prime minister
Trudeau
uh administer Mendocino and I won't call
it up because we've seen it a number of
times but it's true is it true that in
that letter that was based on your
advice
uh that a request was made for a total
of 1800 additional officers from other
police forces in Canada I again I
believe the number was 1790 and change
is about 1800 has become the rounded
number
um and and some 100 of those resources
were civilian but yes substantially yes
and is it true approximately
that about one-third
of that number was to come from each of
the RCMP the opp and other Municipal
forces I I never put those restrictions
on there I've never heard those numbers
those divisions of responsibility until
you've just put it to me now you know
mayor Watson put it that way to prime
minister Trudeau in the letter no in in
a phone call with them I have no idea
what that conversation was well
um and so how many RCMP officers did you
wish to be deployed from that 1800
I never put a percentage or a number
against it sir
so
commissioner
um I seek leave to put uh to pull up the
interview summary for uh Minister Bill
Blair
uh and to show it to Mr slowly if I may
okay well let's uh unusual is there uh
any objection
so maybe we can see again that will not
be entered as an exhibit in the normal
course it'll just be referred to uh and
wouldn't go in as an exhibit until if
and until uh Minister Blair
comes to testify and so go ahead and
we'll see if there's any problem sure so
uh this is uh Mr registrar this is uh
witness summary 48.
and uh could you please go to page five
uh and so let's just stop there so Mr
solely I take it you've never seen this
document no I haven't so we're going to
take a little bit of time uh to let you
read a couple of passages so the first
passage I'd like to direct you to is the
paragraph that states a minister Blair
explained there were two problems with
the mayor's request for resources
uh and then the in the next paragraph
I'll summarize for you he speaks to the
issue of a of planning and the need for
a comprehensive plan uh in order for the
Ops to receive assistance from the opp
and RCMP that's not what I want to focus
you on it's this it's the next paragraph
So okay if you could scroll up please to
the paragraph that begins sorry sir I
thought I was being asked to research
please now you're scrolling away from it
yeah do you want to explain everything
to me and then I'm just summarizing that
one paragraph but I want to ask you
questions about the following paragraph
I'm in your hand so I can start reading
now or just wait till you finish
summarizing and then read everything why
do you read these two paragraphs and I'd
like to ask you about the second okay
thank you
foreign
okay I've read as much as what's on the
page here so so I I want to ask you uh
some questions about that second
paragraph so so Minister Blair would you
agree
uh that in that paragraph he makes two
points which first
uh that in his View
the Ops was required to go to the opp
first
before requesting assistance from the
RCMP and second that the police services
act requires
the Ops to go to the opp first before
going to the RCMP
what's the question sorry so do you
agree that that's what he says
it's a bit confusing because I've in all
my times
in the
Toronto Police Service when he was a
chief that was never the case okay well
I want to go I want to ask you some
questions about that so before we before
we get there I want to talk about and
ask you some questions about the
tripartite meetings
that took place on February 7th 8th and
10th and if if
you you were at two of those meetings
February 7th where you came a little bit
late
uh and February 8th I was I think four
or five of those meetings so so
um so Mr solely I'm sorry in in the
course of the commission's work we've
referred to three of those meetings 78th
and 10th so let me Focus your attention
on those three uh or that's fine but I
was that sure far more of those meetings
so let's go to uh if uh if we could
register if you could please call up the
readout for the February 7th meeting and
the document is pbnsc
canned 2335
right
so Mr Sully have you have you have you
seen this document before
what's on the page here doesn't does if
you could scroll down please
no I've never seen this okay so so this
is a readout from this call if you go
down to page four please
so let's go back up a bit
um and so um here is an exchange between
uh Minister Blair BB
uh and you and and I would just want to
focus on the last exchange here what's
the date on this sir uh so the
we've been told that this is a readout
from a call that took place on February
7th February 7th correct
the only recollection I have of a direct
conversation with Minister Blair was on
the last weekend
but I may be wrong so sorry continue on
well let me ask you what you know a
question based on this evidence
and so uh and so there's an exchange
here at the end
um where you um you discuss how you've
uh you you have great respect for cheap
for for former Chief now Minister Blair
uh and Minister Blair says we are
working to provide the city with the
resources you require
that is our sole intent there will be
follow-up conversations we will be here
for you
um I I take it you don't recall that
exchange no I no I don't recall that
exchange I recall a different exchange
on a different date oh what date was
that I just haven't been able to find it
in any of the notes yet but it was
either the Saturday or the Sunday so the
uh of the last weekend in office so what
would that be the 12th and 13th maybe
the 14th maybe but I think it was more
the 12th and 13th okay well I wanna
let's get to that in in a minute so but
would you agree here that in this record
of this exchange you had with Minister
Blair he didn't raise with you
uh the concern
that the request was somehow problematic
because you had not gone to the opp
first or you hadn't complied with the
police services that's correct in in
what's transcribed here and certainly my
recollection of the other conversation
at neither of those times were those
concerns raised to me okay and and so uh
or anything about a plan or not having a
plan or not having a good enough plan
raised
Mr Mr Sully I'll ask you to come back to
that in just just a minute
um Mr registrar could you please take us
to the readout from the February 8th
tripartite meeting and the document
numbers SSM NSC
can 2052
uh so Mr Sully do you recall
participating in this call
I imagine there were hundreds of calls
so probably not
that's right I'm looking at a date can
you scroll down a bit please Wednesday
February 23rd so that definitely would
have been me oh I think we might have
the wrong document
give me a second please
and I apologize Mr relisher give me one
second
uh commissioner
I have a request when do we do for a
break
because it might be helpful if I could
pull up these notes correctly I
apologize for having given the wrong
document ID to the registrar
um council is it a February 8th meeting
yes it is you have it thank you
we've had excellent service with our
document yes we have
so if you could scroll down to so so if
this is another readout Mr slowly and if
you could scroll down please to page
four
um
uh the participants in this call were
um
yourself
uh BB who's Minister Blair mm who's
minister of Mendocino and others and I'd
like to take you to the last Exchange
between yourself and Minister Blair and
where it begins
um
on the RCMP only 20 have been sworn in
the rest are with Rito cottage which of
course refers to where the prime
minister's residences
and the precinct which I I assume refers
to the Parliamentary Precinct I need
more
and and then Minister Blair says for how
long are you asking resources and then
it's not it's not attributed to you but
I think it's reasonable to infer that
the five seven days answer came from you
I wouldn't say five to seven days sir
you wouldn't have no not at that point
but you do but you you would agree that
these notes state that you
said we need more RCMP officers only 20
have been sworn in
yes that that was
okay that was part of the challenge in
terms of getting RCMP getting this
morning and you'll agree that so when
Minister Blair asked you for how long
are you asking resources he did not
raise with you
the concern that you were going to the
RCMP first
or not going to the opp first and you
were not complying with the police
services act that's correct sir but I
just just a note for the commissioner
this is the first time I'm seeing these
documents they are they're I'm not
debating the content but I just haven't
a chance to read through them to see the
context and situate myself in it so I'm
answering your questions as best as my
recollection can be stimulated from
these documents but the first time I'm
seeing them of course Mr slowly and
we're doing our best here given the
limited time we have available to you uh
Mr solit you refer to a third
conversation you had yes sir with
Minister Blair would you be able to tell
us a bit about that conversation on
these themes
yes so again my recollection is that
this this other conversation takes place
on the last weekend that I'm in office
so this is a Saturday Sunday potentially
Monday the 14th of February I was late
coming onto the call uh ministers
Mendocino and and Blair were on the call
there were others
um and sort of kind of waited in until
things turned around towards me and and
then I I recalled there was an exchange
between the two ministers
um Minister medicino indicated that he
would leave the commentary to minister
Blair and then he proceeded to ask me
two questions
the first question was whether or not we
had considered
uh using bylaw enforcement to address
some of the challenges that we were
facing here
I thought it was an odd question and so
I said yes we've actually issued
hundreds if not thousands of by law
enforcement tickets but that any level
of enforcement was difficult both in
terms of the potential volatility of
Public Safety impacts and the resource
restrictions he then asked a second
question as to whether or not we
considered towing trucks or vehicles and
I said yes we towed hundreds of vehicles
and we'd actually towed some heavy
trucks but again there's extreme
volatility around that type of
enforcement action and that we had
resource challenges with with the tow
trucks particularly heavy trucks
and that was the sum total of it
but he so he never raised these
procedural objections that he appears to
have been be raising neither the
procedural objections or the concerns
around the plan or lack there of a plan
so um
Mr slowly how long have you been or were
you a police officer in Ontario
I think just over 30 years in total in
two different police services and so
you're familiar with the police services
act yes sir and is there any provision
in section 9 of the police services act
that requires
a municipal chief of police to go first
to the opp before seeking assistance
from the RCN not that I'm aware of when
I stand to be corrected by by lawyers
who understand the ACT better than I
ever will but I said my practical
experience has been over the course of
those 30 years and two police services
and for a substantial amount of time
where I actually perform that function
for chief Blair that if we needed help
we went to the best agency available
where we were likely to get the best
help from we didn't I wasn't directed to
nor did I have a system where I had to
reference section 9 and call the
commissioner of the day from the opp and
then through that process find my way to
the right resource I would call North of
Steels and say hey York Region can you
send us a public order unit I'd call
West of the 427 hey peel can you send us
a public order unit I'd call over past
the zoo and say hey Durham can you send
us a public order unit and they would do
the same thing and we would do that in
reciprocity I'd never before seen any
reference section 9 of the police
services act and and Mr slowly
RCMP officers can be sworn in a special
constables that's my understanding I
pursuant to section 53 sub 1 of the
police services act I'll Trust You on
the section and as far as you know uh
there's no condition
for swearing in our RCMP officers a
special accountable that a request must
first be made to the lpp I'm not aware
of that sir and so uh and now Mr slowly
if we had more time I would take you to
the RCMP Act
uh but I'd put it to you
that there is no provision of the RCMP
Act
that requires a local police force to go
first to its Provincial Police Force if
there is one I'll Trust you in that sir
I have no understanding of the RCMP act
and and so would you say Mr slowly that
at best
um so there is no federal or provincial
law
there's no RCMP policy
there's no OPP policy that required the
Ops to go to the opp first I'm not aware
of any of those things sir I've just
used a practice that was long
established and never previously
challenged by any level of government or
any other Police Service uh and Mr
slowly do you wish that these concerns
about procedure have been raised with
you at the time so you could have
responded to them that would have been
the fair thing to do yes thank you Mr
slowly
thank you the next if I can call on the
ccla
good afternoon Mr slowly I'm uh joining
you by assume can you hear and see me
good afternoon I can see you yes
thank you my name is Cara zweeple I'm a
lawyer for the Canadian civil liberties
Association and I have a few questions
for you
um and I think I apologize because I
know you're you're having to go back and
forth in time here but I think we might
actually talk about some of the other
um sort of tripartite type meetings that
you were just mentioning some other ones
that you had
participated in so
um I'm going to be asking you about a
few meetings that involve Commissioners
lucky and karik as well as the the head
of cesus Mr Vino
um as well as a deputy Minister Rob
Stewart uh and uh Jody Thomas who I
believe was the National Security and
intelligence advisor to the Prime
Minister
um
before we do that though I just we're
gonna we're gonna do that by looking at
some of your legal counsel's notes the
note so we've looked at a number of
times but before we go there I just want
to take you to some of your notes
um and ask you a few questions um and
this is document Ops three zeros
14484 and we would be starting at page
20 please
these are I think notes you said you
sometimes sort of send yourself an email
or make notes uh through throughout look
or your email program about the things
that are going on so on page 20
um this is a call a sort of reporting on
a call I'm not sure whether was a call
you made to yes or an app fee or a call
that he made to you do you do you recall
I remember it was a phone call I forget
who contacted who
okay so this is January 31st so I guess
the
um
yesterday Monday okay
um and he was contacting you um because
he's he's an MP in the Ottawa area yes
sir yes ma'am okay and he also was
asking how how he could help
yes I mean I think he was both at
situation update and and what can we do
to help you Peter okay
to see what he could do was this the
sort of first Outreach from someone
within the federal government
um other than my communications with
commissioner lucky I think this was the
first time I had spoken with anybody
else okay so sort of the first political
uh person let's say within the federal
government yes
okay great thank you and if we can just
scroll down I think it's the next page
uh thank you this is a call from the
deputy solicitor general of Ontario Mr D
tomazo yes that's right
um and this is from February 2nd
um and he if he could just scroll down a
little bit so he asked you if there was
any interference of hospital or medical
staff from the demonstration and you
advised yes
um you asked if you were getting he
asked if you were getting help from the
opp and you advised yes and that you
were also getting support from the local
Crown office
um and you also told him that other than
the opp commissioner he was the first
provincial official to call you
regarding the demonstration
um do you recall
how or if he responded to that statement
um he did respond
um and he asked if I would like to have
a call with then solicitor general
um Jones
and okay I said yes
okay and did that call happen
it did it I think it was scheduled for
later on uh on the same day somewhere in
the evening hours I believe
and um I mean were you making that
statement because you were surprised
that by this point I guess February 2nd
we're at the
Wednesday or Thursday Wednesday to
Wednesday yes
um that by that point you were you
surprised you hadn't heard from someone
at the provincial level yet yes okay
um do you recall where things went with
um with Minister Jones when you with the
solicitor general when you did
eventually speak to her
um there's probably notes around that
um but
I think that that some total the call
was
that she had received the information uh
from uh Deputy solicitor general
titamaso that is noted here
um she had understood that I was
interested in a phone call with her I
provided for her a very brief update on
what had transpired locally
um she quietly listened to it and said
thank you and there's sort of a bit of a
pause
I asked if if she wanted to get a deeper
briefing if she felt there might be any
need to engage other ministers or even
the office of the premier
I can't remember what her exact response
was but essentially you know she would
she would consider that on her own
undertaking and that was the substance
of the call
okay thank you thank you very much
um okay and now if we can take a look at
that other document I mentioned so this
is Ops three zeros one four four five
four
and we're going to start at page 35 so
these are once again as uh who knows
sorry I just I apologize for
interrupting
um in my in my update to minister Jones
I did reference that I felt at this
point February 2nd that this was going
to have a significant impact across the
province while I didn't have specific
locations
um I don't even think at this point the
um
the planned protest to Queen's Park had
been announced or I wasn't aware of it
at this point certainly the Windsor and
Sarnia events were not known at all at
this point but it was clear to me that
this was going to have a larger
provincial impact
um and and so it was actually more of a
suggestion than a passive voice uh that
the premier be briefed to some degree
and that other ministers be prepared to
engage beyond the solicitor general
15th
um did that briefing to the the premier
or other provincial ministers ever ever
happen to my knowledge I don't know
but you didn't provide a briefing I mean
you weren't asked to arrange one no no
okay thank you okay so this um this is
hughner's notes and
um this is looking at the February 3rd
meeting in the evening
um with Mr kenolakos Mr Stewart
if Kevin Maloney
um wish you're lucky
um David Vino is at this meeting I'm not
sure what that middle name is press
I don't know if you know that's fine
um so I just want to um if we can scroll
down just a little bit
um so there's the prime minister's
office you know wants to open up a line
of communication here I'm gonna give you
a moment to read read through this I'm
going to ask you about a particular part
um
there's a note understanding we've
avoided the worst but now dealing with
illegal protesters
we are risking public confidence to
solve this problem
government wants to be helpful but has
limits what can we do if we were going
to engage then who would we engage with
uh there's questions about by law and
the highway traffic act enforcement can
we scroll down a little bit more please
uh yeah keep going
I know that um so there's a something
from Mr canalakos a little bit next page
please sorry
okay
um
and then sorry can you scroll down just
a little bit more so these are I think
RS refers to Mr Stewart
and
uh he's asking about enforcement and
what leverage do you have
and and this is the the note that your
your counsel is written if you want an
assessment of risk of this demonstration
please bring the questions properly so
you can get the info you need
don't appreciate you suggesting my
police differently based on color
uh and I think Mr Stewart is saying that
or there's a reference that a minister
said this
your observation is very insulting to me
uh and he's I think saying I hear you
um and then you're providing him with a
briefing about the risk assessment do
you recall this exchange and what what
this was about very much so
do you mind telling us about it
this was the first of the tri-level
meetings that I attended I've been
advised about their existence I think
the day before
from city manager kanilakis
uh he suggested that I participated and
I welcomed that that invitation because
it would allow me to be able to speak to
all three levels at the same time and
ideally to secure resources that we so
desperately needed at that time so I
attended a meeting with great
expectation and hope quite frankly that
this would be a very productive and
constructive environment and one that
would accelerate uh the delivery of
resources not just police officers but
across the board support to something
that we desperately needed here in
Ottawa and I think increasingly The
Province and the country we're dealing
with Kutz Alberta was active other
locations across the country were active
I think by this time we knew there was
something going to be happening in
Queens Park on the weekend so I was
looking forward to this
um the section on the page above that
you rolled you scrolled through
was largely
I'll describe it as a monologue that
Deputy Minister Stewart was providing to
the group on the call
I wasn't familiar with most of the
people in the call so I was just quietly
listening and sort of waiting for it to
become more of a discussion
but there was a comment near the end of
that
that isn't captured by my general
counsel but it's what I reference on
this page here
and this is not an exact quote because I
don't have
um so I'm going off of memory and it's
not captured in these notes but
essentially the comment was the Ottawa
Police Service seems to be wanting to
help a group of extremists and white
supremacists to take over
Ottawa Wellington Street
it is that comment that I took great
offense to
okay and it was this was a comment made
in the meeting or was it reflecting
something that had been by a minister
elsewhere it wasn't sort of clear to me
from the notes if uh well so I took it
as a comment from Deputy Minister Stuart
I don't recall him clarifying as that
note in the corner says that this is
something he heard a minister say
but it seems to be captured by general
counsel you know here okay okay
we're at the
third
um starting to if you're starting to
feel some significant pressure from from
the government about about this
situation
well I would go well past pleasure
um that seems to be a condemnation
statement an allegation and that is why
I said
um I found that
suggestion that I police or the audible
Police Service who I represent
differently based on color on race
was this I know that in your testimony
on Friday you mentioned that
there were a few points where you felt
that um individuals both at the federal
level and the provincial level had made
some public statements that you felt
undermined the public trust in the
Ottawa Police is this I know this wasn't
a public statement but is this the type
of comment that you're talking about
yes
um not a public statement but in a room
that had Representatives
um city manager ministers from across a
variety of platforms at the federal
level I don't believe the province was
represented on this call but I don't
know I don't know everybody else that
was in the room but these are policing
Partners like commissioner lucky
National Security Partners like David
venue
um right I found it very problematic and
very embarrassing
thank you can we slow down
38
towards the end of the page this is the
same meeting
um
and I think you've been talking there's
been some discussion about the
possibility of of negotiations
um I think Mr canalakos had maybe almost
you know is it is it worth it to
negotiate
um Mr
Steward
um or sorry Mr
sorry can we scroll down to just the
next
page
so it I I think this was Mr Stewart
saying I hear you say yes it's
productive to negotiate
and you you say I need constructive
conversation and questions from all
levels of government
yes
so in this meeting am I right that you
are you're communicating or trying to
communicate to the federal government
Representatives that as you said before
all options are on the table
uh the federal government I think Mr
Stewart was interested in understanding
what the group needed to feel like to
have a win there's a statement I think
earlier up that was attributed to to him
um is that sort of the nature of the
discussion that's happening here yes we
got into a very constructive dialogue at
this point and and that is the gist of
it
thank you and can we just go down to the
middle of page 40
um this is where Mr Lino comes into the
conversation
and
um I I think that first notice this is
unprecedented the word of um like the
word of the day or the word of the
commission I'd say
um the social media is creating
reactions and and then he talks about
command structure so we need to break
this down better we can look at foreign
interference
observe the people involved are Nimble
ex-cops might be some things to be done
to expose their rules I'm not sure what
the thing in Brackets refers to but
psyops psychological operations okay and
then a notion of Engagement people below
the PM and ministers that may better
understand the Dynamics
um today press conference she is more
organized they have lawyer so I'm not
I'm not sure if you do recall those
those things being mentioned do you know
what Mr Vino's doing there are these
sort of the items he's taking back to to
look at
um yes this is my understanding of my
recollection is that uh Mr vigno was
getting from a thesis perspective his
assessment of unprecedented he's in
point number one he's talking about the
command structure of the of the
convoys demonstrators writ large again I
won't speak for Mr vigno but I'm not
suggesting there was a unified command
but he's talking about elements of a
command structure there he then goes
into in point two to talk about how
Nimble they are
including the fact that it involves
ex-police officers
um I forget if he talked about
ex-military or national security but
certainly referenced officers
um
psyopsis is a term that I knew from my
time in peacekeeping and Kosovo and in
point three
um
engaging and educating my word educating
his word engaging
um prime minister and ministers to
better understand the Dynamics of what's
actually taking place here and he used
the example of the press conference I
believe that day
um to give an example of the level of
ability and capacity to use social media
use mainstream media for leadership that
seems
if not unified cohesive as
we haven't seen this before and
I would suggest of of all the moments in
this meeting and one of the most
significant moments for me in my entire
time in these events was hearing the
head of thesis describe
what I had at that point
um begun to realize this was a national
security level event that nobody had
seen coming nobody fully understood and
was rapidly still evolving not just here
in Ottawa but across the country and I
hope that was a really big alarm Bell
for the people on this call more so than
the one that I had been trying to ring
loud and clear here in Ottawa as the
police chief in the Ottawa Police
Service
just just to remind you you're over your
time so you're gonna have to wrap up
already over my time okay um
one or two more very free questions
commissioner as long as they're quick
and sharp all right I will do my best
um can I just ask about Mr Vino it
accurate to say that say the stage he
hadn't formed any opinion or haven't
made an assessment about
um whether this was you know a foreign
influenced
um action or that these are things that
he was going to explore but there was no
assessment at this stage I don't believe
there was I I do remember either on this
call or a subsequent call he touched on
the level of foreign involvement and and
it was I believe minimal if if anything
um I can't recall if it was on this call
or not though okay thank you and can we
just briefly go to the bottom of page 92
and this will be my last stem
Point
um
this is
another one of these meetings I believe
this was the one this is the one on
February 6th with Mr if you know and Mr
Stewart are in this meeting again and
this is Mr gitomazo
um
and if we go to the bottom of page 92
yep
um
so Mario I think that's Mr uh di tomazo
no appetite to engage and thank federal
government needs to step up and engage
and then if you can scroll down
and then I think this is Miss Thomas
saying you know if this if not Ottawa
would Province be looking at federal
government
and he replies yes this is a trucker
protest because it mandates at the
border that federal government put in
place do you recall this Exchange
I don't have an independent recollection
um
but it seems to be well noted here okay
did you was that your overall sense that
um
Mr ditomazo was was communicating to you
that the provincial government have no
appetite to engage in sort of the
negotiations that were being discussed
again with great reluctance I don't want
to presume intention on anybody it's
been used against me too much
um I can only give my observations it
was several days into it before there
was any Outreach from the provincial
government to me directly
um the first two meetings that I was on
in the tri-level meetings I don't
believe there's any provincial
representation uh the next two I believe
there were
um
those are my those are the only facts I
can tell you I won't try to put
intention into anybody's comments
thank you um thank you very much for for
answering those questions and thank you
Mr commissioner for the Indulgence
okay next is the National Police
Federation but before we turn to them
this might be a good time for the
morning break I don't I don't mean to
all right I'm sorry the afternoon I'm
just having
it's it's so exciting that uh
I wanna hear more
um
thank you for the correction I will take
the afternoon break uh for 15 minutes
and recess for 15 minutes
thank you
the commission has reconvened the
commissioner
okay where are you ready
I am okay
hello Mr slowly my name is Nene Jones
and I'm counsel to the National Police
Federation can you see and hear me okay
yes I can thank you
thank you
um the National Police Federation is the
union for RCMP members and one of the
good things about going late in the day
is that most of my questions have been
asked and answered already so I'm going
to be very brief with you and
um focus in on an area that we haven't
touched on I don't think over the course
of the day so you've had lots of
questions today about the resources
available to the Ottawa Police including
from the RCMP as well as the opp and
other large police services in Ontario
um but no one's asked you about the
Parliamentary Protective Services or the
PPS are you familiar with them yes I am
okay and you know that there are a few
hundred security officers based out of
Parliament Hill yes I do
in the main I mean other parliamentary
elements other elements of the
Parliamentary Precinct
um and the Ottawa Police Service didn't
look to them persistence in responding
to the Convoy correct
I'm sorry did or didn't I didn't hear
you did not
uh well they were part of our intersect
planning team and have been for years so
in that sense yes they would have
um
been able to support information
gathering intelligence potentially
Logistics
so I have no information to suggest that
they weren't involved maybe not as
involved as other entities like the RCMP
but I have no indication to say that
they were not involved
okay
um you know that their security officers
are not peace officers that's correct
and you know they're not a law
enforcement agency that's correct
and so in fact if uh criminal offense
occurs on Parliament Hill they actually
call the Ottawa Police Service right
that's correct
and so during the Convoy just to sort of
circle that back PPS officers weren't a
resource to in terms of what I think
some of my um friends have said earlier
in terms of boots on the ground to
support Ops uh in its physical response
to the Convoy
um
no actually I wouldn't say that okay
well they certainly are not uh in imbued
with full police powers
uh they have some Force protection
capability they would be able to provide
at a minimum situational awareness
updates from the ground as to what's
taking place all of that would have been
at Parliament Hill at Parliament Hill
their line of sight would have taken
them well beyond Parliament Hill
um they would have had interactions with
uh protesters and other people and those
could have produced information that
could have been valuable and could have
been shared in real time or in briefing
notes at the end of the day and in
briefing Cycles so again I'm not saying
that in any these aren't items that I
know took place but to suggest that they
would have had no physical benefit to
the entire theory of operations I don't
think is is correct
okay well just to go back um to some of
the evidence that we've heard uh you
know it's clear Ottawa Police Service
was looking for additional uh bodies or
boots on the ground to respond to the
Convoy yes um and you'll agree with me
that the PPS did not provide that in
terms of boots on the ground to respond
to the Convoy in terms of those policing
responsibilities on Wellington and
Beyond
again all I can say is that there were I
never made a specific request I wasn't
asked to make a request that I never
made a specific request
for PPS members to be participating in
it I can't rule out whether or not any
PPS members would have had the skill
sets the knowledge skills and abilities
that we listed in our
1790 odd requirements there potentially
could have been a member of the PPS that
had a background in investigations in
crime analysis
um who could have who had a background
in in some form of skill that could have
helped with mass arrests and processing
of prisoners so I just can't rule it out
I don't have an explicit note that we
made Us explicit request to them
okay and in fact would you agree with me
that is police of jurisdiction Ops had
to actually account for providing
policing Assistance or support to the
PPS on Parliament Hill
that would have been a risk area that we
would have had to assess but again I
would I would suggest that that by the
virtue of the PPS and their capabilities
that would be
um there was some capability there for
us to lean on as opposed to a
condominium building
next to the red zone that didn't have
any security that probably would have
required more more direct and urgent
help should something go wrong there
I think it's fair to say that we can
agree that some security is better than
no security yes that's fair but to be
clear if there was an unlawful event uh
the Convoy protest overtook Parliament
Hill for example there was some sort of
a non-lawful event on Parliament Hill
you'd agree with me that that would fall
to the Ops and the additional resources
it had gathered to respond to in terms
of criminal conduct or the Convoy
actually uh making Headway towards
Parliament Hill yes as police of
jurisdiction we would have primary
responsibility uh just again note there
were I believe three RCMP public order
unit troops and two OPP public order
unit units assigned into that theater
not to the Ottawa Police Service and any
one of those units could have also
responded not as police's jurisdiction
but could have responded in exigent
circumstances to support whatever was
happening there
and in fact just to sort of close the
circle on that the fact that those Pou
units had to be
um placed in the inside the
Parliamentary Protective Services areas
which meant they couldn't be available
to Ops outside of Parliament Hill right
Fair Point yes
okay those are my questions thank you so
much for your time thank you thank you
very much
okay thank you the next uh it's uh the
Democracy fund and jccf
good afternoon former Chief slowly uh my
name is Rob kittridge and I'm counsel to
the Justice Center for a constitutional
freedoms in these hearings I think uh
maybe we had all hoped that the towing
question was put to rest last week but
uh it's starting to look like a bit of
an inquiry into a purported national
Towing emergency so I've got a few
questions to ask on that subject about
what your conversation with uh Council
for Canada earlier today
um you indicated that you felt that
there were two main obstacles to
clearing the Ottawa protests first you
needed additional resources meaning
about 1800 people skilled police
officers or skilled Associated people
and second you needed to secure heavy
towing services is that a fair
characterization of your testimony
um from a resource standpoint that's
what I was needing I was needing a lot
more Beyond resources to have a safe
successful outcome that was envisioned
all right
um if
so maybe on that note I'll skip the next
two questions and jump to something a
little more certain
um
in uh in your cons
in your conversation with Council for
Canada you said that while you may have
had some concerns about their
willingness to participate in clearing
the protests tow trucks were there when
you say that tow trucks were there
you're talking about the city's standing
order Towing contractors weren't you
um so my understanding was we had
somewhere between three to five tow
trucks available to us on the first
weekend and those numbers did not
increase to my knowledge
um until my last day in office right so
those would be this the towing
contractors that you typically deal with
when you have Towing to do on a any
given day city-owned vehicles
and or tow contracts but again I'm not
certain about the tow contract part of
things right just a number of vehicles
okay uh you weren't directly involved in
the procurement of towing services for
the eventual police operation that
cleared the protests were you no sir uh
and in fact that procurement was handled
by uh the opioid oh sorry the opp and
not the ops isn't that true I don't know
who handled it sir right
um but you don't have any direct
knowledge related to the out of town
towing services procured by the OPP at
all do you no
um so you really don't know if there was
any reason to think that the tow trucks
procured by the OPP weren't as you put
it earlier to council for Canada
reliably and predictably engaged to
provide towing services during the
police operation do you
well what I was talking about to uh
Canada Council was the need for Reliable
predictability around the resources
necessary for any operational plan of
the scale that was being considered if
your question is that did I know whether
this contract was going to prove
reliable and predictable I had no
involvement in that contract right and
the towing providers that eventually
participated in the in the police
operation had traveled long distances to
Ottawa and if the opp was confident that
they were in fact ready willing and able
to participate in the towing operation
you have no reason to disagree with
their opinion would you I had no
involvement in whatsoever so I can't
comment on it whatsoever right
but you'd have no reason to disagree
with their assessment again I had no
involvement sir okay fair enough
um
and Council for Canada also asked you
about National Security issues relating
to the protests I take it that you agree
with the evidence from all OPP and Ops
officers who've testified on the subject
so far that there was no credible
intelligence or evidence indicating a
threat to the new to the security of
Canada as that term is defined in
section two of the thesis act do you I'm
unfamiliar with section two of the
thesis act and I've heard some testimony
from Where I Stood this was a national
crisis right but uh did you have any
credible intelligence or evidence of
Espionage or sabotage against Canada or
that which is detrimental to the
interests of Canada or activities
directed toward or in support of such
Espionage or sabotage no sir did you
have any credible intelligence or
evidence of foreign influenced
activities within or relating to Canada
that were detrimental to the interests
of Canada and were clandestine or
deceptive or involved a threat to any
person
if you'd like me to read that again I'm
happy to do it so far from where I saw
satin Otto and the information available
to me there were significant elements of
foreign funding
there there were briefings that people
might be coming north of the Border
uh to join in some of the protest
activities I can't rule out as police
chief here that there were not some
elements of
Other Nation involvement in one way or
the other whether it Rose to the level
as you're describing under section two I
don't have any ability to say that right
so you had you're saying that you had
credible intelligence or evidence of
such a threat I had information
available to me that suggested there
were there were activities taking place
beyond our borders that there were
activities taking place beyond Canada's
borders
um
so I I mean I guess can you just
I didn't test it with any great measure
I I again the the level that you're
describing in section two this is just
the vast
funnel of information that was coming to
me and there was a
different calls where questions are
being asked or information was being
provided about whether or not convoys
were joining from United States into
Canada whether or not the convoys here
were impacting other countries whether
or not money was flowing into any of the
different funding projects from foreign
sources so I'm just telling you in the
sum total of all the information that I
was aware of some of it related to
activities outside of our borders right
but would it be fair to describe that as
you you had a information or a suspicion
that there might be participants in the
protest coming from outside of Canada
and that some amount of funding might
have been directed uh you know donations
to the GoFundMe account or GoFundMe
account or whatever that's the balance
yes so that would be the sort of that's
what you're talking about when you're
talking about foreign influenced
activities yes sir all right and uh
there was nothing mentioned in the
Hendon report about a credible threat on
that uh I don't have a complete memory
of the hand in report so I
as a matter of recollection and that's
the source of your information there
were some 20 odd 24 30 Hendon reports I
can't tell you whether or not it was
ever mentioned but then the head and
reports it's a question probably better
placed to the opp sure with regard to
your own recollect on this subject can
you remember what the source of the
information that you're talking about
was
uh there was a discussion at one point
on the tri-party level where I believe
uh csis director Vino referenced his uh
discussions with cbsa and other entities
around whether or not convoys were
coming north people were crossing the
border to you made some reference to
International funding as an example
and that would be funny in the level of
donations to the GoFundMe I couldn't
tell you anything I couldn't tell you
how he broke down the funding comments
but that's my recollection sir all right
well then I'll move on to the last two
items here and uh I'll be uh finished
with you for the day so uh we have did
you have credible intelligence or
evidence of activities within or
relating to Canada directed toward or in
support of the threat or use of Acts of
serious violence against persons or
property for the purpose of achieving a
political religious or ideological
objective within Canada
there is a wide array of social media
posting I don't know to what extent they
were all identified validated and in one
way or the other cancel is a threat but
I was aware of a wide variety of Open
Source social media that made a wide
range of threatening type behavior that
might touch on one or more of the points
that you raised sir and do you consider
any social media posts to be a credible
threat on its own no it has to be
validated and corroborated by other
information but you aren't aware of any
social media posts that was validated
and corroborated not to my awareness or
no okay thank you
um and was there any credible
intelligence or evidence of activities
directed towards undermining by covert
unlawful Acts or directed toward or
intended ultimately to lead to the
destruction or overthrow by violence of
the constitutionally established system
of government in Canada no sir all right
well thank you very much and my
sympathies and my uh I'm very impressed
with your sheer endurance here and on
Friday thank you so much thank you very
much
okay thank you next if I could call on
the province of Alberta
thank you very much I have just a few
brief questions this afternoon aimed at
possibly clarifying just one aspect of
the timeline
um Mr clerk if you could please pull up
document
ssm.nsc.can dot four
zeros2052 underscore Rel
thank you very much
um and so Mr solilo recall my friend Mr
chaudry for CCF took you to this
document earlier
um it's minutes um that somebody
recorded of a February the 8th uh
tripartite meeting that you had been on
yes
and in that discussion
um you had mentioned that it was your
recollection that you um had had a
subsequent call uh you believed it was
the weekend of February 12th or 13th
with ministers Blair and Mendocino
um in which minister Blair had asked you
about two issues first of all uh whether
you had considered uh law enforcement uh
by law enforcement sorry and the second
issue on um uh the status of Towing
efforts is do you recall that
conversation yes
could I just take you to um page three
of this document please about halfway
down the page
and I'll let you read this Mr slowly
just starting at the part that says BB
which is is Minister Blair
um then there's a brief response from
the mayor and then there's a paragraph
indicating your response to minister
Blair oh thank you this is hugely
clarifying and that's why I was hoping
to be able to read the whole document
the first time but so this would be the
one and only time I did speak to the two
well I was on a call with the two
ministers and it does relate to the
conversation that I had with Minister
Blair could I just read the document now
though because it is refreshing my
memory
this is my only area of questioning and
I have five minutes so I'm I'm content
of the commissioner's content to to give
you the time to look at that okay thank
you could someone just scroll back up to
the top of this and uh I'll just read
through it then
so can you just go go up a little bit
further please
okay thank you just
yep even further than please
and these are all notes from within the
same minute meeting
yes
okay please go further
up to the very top please sorry I just I
just need to know when I come into this
meeting because I recall
coming in part way
okay keep going
okay keep going now please
stop there
okay thank you
okay next
okay thank you keep going
thank you
thank you keep going
sorry just down a little bit
up a little bit more now thank you just
stop there
okay up to the top there please keep
going and stop there
and down again
okay I believe that's the end of it yes
thank you very much uh commissioner for
your Indulgence here
and so Mr clerk if we could return to
that portion on page three please with
the exchange with
um
Minister Blair uh and Mr slowly
um would this then just to for the
transcript briefly uh Minister Blair
asks whether you'd look at traffic laws
Etc uh and expands on that uh and your
response is rest assured
um you talk about a number of uh
ticketing
um efforts uh we're looking at insurance
and Licensing we're looking to create an
impound Zone simply put we can create
the Zone impound these vehicles where
they are until we are able to remove
them with the trucks we have or get more
trucks very very brief summary of of
what the exchange is
um would this be the exchange that you
thought had occurred perhaps on February
12th or 13th yes it is in fact
okay thank you very much I just wanted
to clarify that those are my questions
thank you the next uh
is uh Council for Mr slowly
[Music]
for the record I'm
counsel to former Chief slowly
um I just have a few questions that I'm
going to ask you and you are
Tom Curry sorry I left that part out
thank you commissioner
the voice would have given an indication
which Council but I think there are
three so it just doesn't say everything
thank you
um
she's slowly a few things for you please
uh chair deans of the Police Services
Board has told the commissioner
that when you became chief of this
Police Service the she described as the
honeymoon period was very short
do you agree with her
it was here yes
and Council for the uh for the Ops has
raised a number of issues about trust
and confidence among the members of The
Command Staff including some issues
raised in notes that he took you to
um
including a conversation that you had
believed recorded with a meeting with
chair Deans February 14th I wonder if I
could just ask you to look at that to
refresh your recollection of it please
for the registrar it's Ops one four five
six six
and it should be found on
I think page three or it's 13 14 hours
so if that's page three it's a little
could you try page five I think it's 13
14 hours we should see in the margin
there it is thank you
thank you for that
uh do you recall this conversation
February 14th with the with the chair
yes it is Sir and
um you can see if we just scroll down
just a little bit thank you that the uh
the discussion between you and the chair
concerned the invocation of the
emergencies Act
yes sir and the implications for among
other things
enforcement through tow trucks that are
described there
you were asked questions about the the
in the middle of that bullet about
orders that might have been disobeyed
during the demonstration
and you described I won't repeat it it's
in the in the note you it what is
recorded is that you said that the best
and the worst of us have been strained
this is why there has been tense
meetings and why some
have not demonstrated their best levels
like everyone I have been at my best and
I have not been at my best you were
asked some questions about this
previously but just explain to the
commissioner in from your perspective as
the chief at the time
we can probably understand the things
that you did that were your best what
were the things that you did that were
not your best
the range of meetings that we had on a
daily basis
um
I mean I think we've been some in my
examining Chief where I started my day
at you know four o'clock in the morning
and
didn't end it till sometime after 10 11
o'clock and for me I think I was 21 days
in and there are officers that worked
longer than that and members that worked
longer than that it's just beyond the
human condition to be at your best and
turn up as a leader in every single
moment in every single conversation
phone call text message email
operating at the at the highest levels
um and I've been in three different
professions and every one of them
required me to be a high performance
athlete high performance Police
Executive and high performance business
executive and despite your best efforts
you just can't perform optimally in
every single occasion that's what I was
trying to say here not just on my behalf
but on behalf of the people that work
for me at every level in every part of
the organization and In fairness that
holds across all institutions and
organizations
did the fact that you came from outside
the Ottawa Police Service with the
Mandate that you told the commissioner
have implications for the converse the
points that you made in this
conversation
absolutely uh chair Dean's again I think
it's been uh well documented uh that the
board of the day was seeking an outside
chief of police uh one that would tackle
a major change agenda
um almost all of the questions put to me
and all of the components of the
negotiation for me to sign a contract
were around a change mandate the
introduction of Me by chair Deans to the
public in late August was all around an
outsider coming in to change an
organization that was in significant
need of change and a change that was
well established for years and was going
to be a very large effort
um almost every conversation board
meeting that I was involved in during my
entire tenure of chief of police had
some element of major change culture
change administrative change HR change
operational change change of the
relationship with our communities
particularly racialized and marginalized
marginalized communities so
couldn't have been emphasized more
before I took the job it was continually
emphasized literally every time I had
any interaction with the board and
certainly was the focus of the vast
majority of my efforts as chief of
police internally with our with our
members chair Dean's told us that of
course you were the first black police
chief in this community
that's a fact and how many at the time
that you assumed that command in 2019
how many
police services in our country had black
police Chiefs only the Ottawa Police
Service
she also discussed that and has
discussed publicly and also in her
evidence in her view you had faced
issues of racism
during your time as chief of the Ops
that's correct sir
and did that impact your ability to lead
the service
no absolutely I mean it's it's an an
outflow of resistance to change on on a
variety of levels
it's an indication of the depth of the
change needed
um and any personal attack on the on the
office holder of chief of police will
will be a challenge to manage
um
but attack of that nature on the office
of the chief of police
I would suggest is a very significant
indication of the depth of the
challenges that were facing me and and
the board and the organization and the
City
I want to ask you some questions please
about Staffing my friend from the Ottawa
Police Service asked you about
the the event commander and in
particular superintendent rayon
who was an event commander and when you
learned that that change had been made
you recall those questions yes sir
um I'm not going to turn it up but for
the record Ops
14537 commissioner at page five are the
notes that superintendent Rio made
indicating that he had been removed from
that role by acting deputy chief
Ferguson on February 1st did you know
about that at the time no sir I did not
and within the incident command
structure who had the responsibility for
making those decisions the major
Incident Commander who is acting deputy
chief Ferguson
in relation to the incident command
structure
the Commissioners heard some evidence
from commissioner karik about this but
what role is played by the chief of the
Police Service
I don't like all things I'm responsible
for all operations and all
administration of the Police Service it
all rolls up to me I delegate Authority
down through several levels around
functional responsibility uh usually
that is in the function of an
organizational chart but in this case
that's the function of an incident
command operation in which case I
delegate operational Authority down
through the Matrix Incident Commander to
the event Commander Incident Commander
and so on
thank you
um in answer to questions from my
friends at commission Council you
spoke about the numbers of vehicles that
were in the city to support the protest
over the first weekend and that left
on the first I believe Sunday so the if
if you're with me the end of the first
weekend where there was an expectation
some Vehicles were leaving could I ask
you please to look with us at uh Ops IR
so this would be the institutional
report Mr registrar in page 13. just
want to have your assistance with
something please
this is an Institutional report prepared
by
on behalf of the Ottawa Police Service I
Believe by our friends who are counsel
to the Ops so if you if I unders just
look at the paragraph in the text please
choose slowly and in actuality
thousands of vehicles descended on
Ottawa for the first three days
it says the following sets out an
estimation of individual protesters and
vehicles present in the downtown core
the data is imprecise and it refers to
the fluid nature of the circumstances do
you see that yes sir
um
the if you if you look at the
the
column on the date 29 January 30 31 and
then into February do you see the
numbers there according to the different
uh Geographic areas Parliament
Wellington Elgin Rito Sussex other and
then the vehicles do you see that on
February 1st looking at the final column
676 is the estimate of vehicles
uh on Feb one and thousands are the is
the estimate on the three days
previously do you see that yes sir I do
does that uh Accord with your the your
recollection and the information you had
that that
Vehicles left at the end of the third uh
significant number of vehicles left at
the end of the of the weekend yeah and
uh math was never my strong suit so
someone will correct me but Jan 31st is
actually the Monday
so I would look at the Monday not
February 1st and if I'm looking at the
total
the first two columns that say
Parliament Wellington
are those
protesters or vehicles that I'm looking
I believe those are protest numbers
protester numbers protester numbers are
down to 250
which if I just use the 6000 and I'm
five to six thousand number that would
be five percent of five thousand
can I stand to be corrected by any Math
teachers in the room
right can I and there is another
commissioner we can deal with it later
but there is another document I won't
ask and it be turned up but the RCMP has
an estimate of the number of trucks uh
at PB NSC c a n one three six nine I
don't need that document Mr registrar
thank you but just for the record I want
to ask you some questions if I can about
the plans and mission statements yeah
and sorry just not to refresher but
again
there's been a lot of questions about
well what did you know there's a large
group coming and some will stay behind
five percent stayed behind
as of Monday
I don't have the number of trucks
because it says thousands but I think
the estimate of trucks was somewhere
between three to five thousand
again 676 would it indicate around 10
percent of the vehicles stayed behind I
think that falls more closely to the
bucket of some than all right and of
course the the numbers
uh it continued to increase on the
weekends as you have already described
absolutely I want to ask you then some
questions please about the plans and
mission statements you were asked by my
friends for the commission about a
February fifth plan uh could I please
ask you Mr register for your help Ops
6941
you recall those well that documents
coming up do you recall those questions
yes sir
I'm interested in the in the in two
things in this document mission
statement first of all
foreign
thank you it's just within the first few
pages
uh
to the
keep going I think there um
well
if you go to page there it is
there it is thank you very much
you'll see that the the mission
statement in this plan
was for the Ottawa Police Service in a
collaborative approach with other police
agencies
Etc provide a safe and secure
environment in the city during the
freedom Convoy event the primary goal is
to end the protest peacefully
maybe achieved through proactive
engagement by all officers including
police liaison teams facilitating
communication de-escalation and
negotiation you see that I do sir and
was the was the idea of negotiation
um important to you clearly it was by
how much space it took up in the mission
statement
now
um could I that's fine with that
document thank you uh Mr registrar can I
ask you some questions please next about
resources
um
I want to first start with your own
resources the management of the Ops
resources can you tell the commissioner
what steps were taken by your by your
service in cooperation with the Ottawa
Police Association
to use the resources it had available to
maximum effect to maintain the Safety
and Security of the city thank you very
much sir
um as I was reaching out for resources I
had to ensure commissioner that we had
utilized everything that we had
available in good faith I couldn't ask
for other
Police Services to go down in capacity
when we hadn't exhausted everything that
we had
to that effect
um
I think by the end of the first weekend
we had extended shift schedules
increased our overtime pay
um we then canceled a covid reserve
platoon that we kept in case a new wave
of covet wiped out a platoon that we'd
be able to bring another in and not have
any gaps so we canceled that and
deployed those resources
uh that would be the Monday Tuesday
after the first weekend
shortly around that time we got into
negotiations with the
Ottawa Police Association I don't want
to exclude the Ottawa Police senior
officer Association because we probably
needed to extend our senior officers and
Senior managers as well that was
assigned to CAO Blair dunker to lead
that I believe towards the end of the
first week into the second week we
achieved a successful negotiation with
the OPA and that allowed us to change
the shift schedule timing significantly
and that brought additional hundreds of
more officers into bear we had already
notified that we'd be canceling
um
elective leave and I think at that point
we just canceled everything
around
that point of the let's say the end of
the second weekend
I don't think we had anything in reserve
and at that point we were only giving
officers time off literally for health
and safety reasons and we've heard some
examples around that we already had
officers working in excess of two weeks
straight 10 12 hours a day and it's been
given in evidence I've given it most of
this is during the coldest snap that
ottawa's had in over a decade with
average temperatures daytime minus 25 to
30 and nighttime minus 35. there was a
frostbite warning for the majority of
that so these were all the efforts
there's probably more that I can't
recall off the top of my head that we
put in place leading up to the request
for that additional
1790 odd officers thank you
my friend from the Ottawa Police Service
also asked you some questions about OPP
superintendent Abrams
including the questions I believe about
the memorandum or an email that he sent
to his chain of command and just tell
the commissioner did superintendent
Abrams raise any concerns with you about
the nature of the estimate for resources
that had been provided no he did not
or did anyone in your team raise any
concern or question about that no
um
now resource requests you've told us
were were made both to your policing
Partners both before and and during the
uh the Convoy protests did you have
direct contact with ministers and Deputy
ministers
and police leaders throughout the entire
period of occupation concerning your
need for resources yes sir
now um
a couple of just questions to fill in uh
for the commissioner who is the Deputy
minister of the solicitor general Mr D
tommaso
I'm sorry I don't do you did you know we
saw the deputy ministers solicitor
general Ontario is Mr D Tomaso yes sir
were you familiar with him very very
much so and how do you know him uh you
and I were colleagues together in the
audible Police Service
um worked together for probably the
better part of two decades
um just uh I'm gonna stop you you said
Ottawa Police sorry yeah sorry Toronto
police service thank you we worked
together for the better part of two
decades uh probably the closest uh time
working together was when he was
promoted to
staff superintendent I was already a
deputy chief
so his promotion would probably be
around 2000 and 12 2013 and he reported
directly to me he was one of two staff
superintendents that reported directly
to me
ran a an area of responsibly of some 789
business units mostly front line
operations right
um
I also became very involved in a
significant incident in in
in in Mario's life and I won't go into
it for public record but it was a
significant incident and one that I was
able to provide as much support as I
could beyond my role as his supervisor
to him and his family uh during that
period as an extended period of time
and and you were also asked questions
about Deputy Deputy Minister Rob Steward
and we've seen Communications uh what
about uh Mr Stewart did you know him
prior to the events of the Convoy no sir
right
now I want to ask you some questions
about
um
uh an exchange that you were asked about
again uh concerning that between the two
Commissioners commissioner locking
commissioner karik OPP
4583 please
page three and four
foreign
just uh you thank you if we could just
stop there
um this you've seen this this exchange
and correcting for the hour of the day
uh
um
commissioner of the RCMP rights between
you and I only
the government Canada is losing oblique
stroke lost confidence in Ops
that's written on February 5th did you
know about this at the time no I didn't
sir did you know what lay behind the
loss of confidence
if indeed that was accurate that is
expressed here by the commissioner of
the RCMP to the commissioner of the opp
no and when I take GOC I take that to
mean Govern of Canada that the entire
government of Canada
the entire governor of Canada had lost
support or was losing lost support
confidence in the Ops it's quite a
statement could you scroll down Mr
registrar please
exchange continues
and
with commissioner karik describing that
he has
looked like he reached out to you we're
going to assume that you're the Peter
there for a call are you free for a call
and then the commissioner of the RCMP
writes nope still on the call with
ministers and then please scroll down
trying to stop there thank you trying to
calm them down but not easy when they
see cranes structures
horses
bouncy bouncing castles in downtown
Ottawa just stopping there
to the extent that the that the concern
from the government of Canada it's
expressed at the level of ministers
observing the
circumstances on Wellington Street would
that concern have been shared by you and
every other person affected in Ottawa
yes sir
now
um
sticking with uh thank you for for that
one um seeking then please just with uh
commissioner Creek now for a moment I
want to show you OPP 4586
and this registrar's page five
uh you I believe you spoke to
counsel about this you you exchanged
messages with with commissioner Creek by
text and email and other forms of
communication calls and so on I want to
ask you about
about this one February 6th do you see
that yes sir
that this is to you from commissioner
curry good morning Peter or GM Peter
good morning a Beyond difficult day
yesterday
here for you if you personally or Ops
need anything this morning before the 11
A.M meeting or in general
then just scroll down you describe back
to him you're getting a 10 a.m briefing
then we'll let if any let know if any
new resource needs and you say thank you
to him
and then he writes back to you and I
believe that I'm not going to take you
to it but I believe the briefing to
which uh this is a reference the
commissioner will learn is a is a
briefing of the of the larger group
Federal and provincial uh
Representatives including the two
Commissioners and so on commissioner
Creek's right writes to you outstanding
briefing this morning Peter
thanks for representing us all so well
you've got this and you continue to have
our unwavering support did you receive
that message from the commissioner yes
sir I did
in his discussions with you did
commissioner karik continue to support
your command through to the end of your
term yes he did
and in your discussions with
commissioner lucky
did she convey the same thing that she
you had her support
uh not as explicitly and certainly not
as emphatically
um or regularly
um there were you know clear statements
that she would consider resource
requests and there were efforts to
fulfill those
um but I found I was getting a lot of
questions from commissioner lucky on
things that I thought we had cleared
and kept coming back to them things like
did you sign off on the plan has the
plan been signed off on going into the
last my last weekend in office
overall it was constructive but there
were elements that I found
seem to be just going around in circles
on a little bit right I think you
touched on this in the in your evidence
to my friends from the commission about
um knowing what we what you now know the
the embedded Convoy uh protesters and
the challenges that it posed to the
Ottawa Police Service and the your
policing partners
just in terms of the issue of resources
can you tell the commissioner whether
knowing what you now know you would have
approached the resource requests
differently in order to accomplish your
objectives
again with the wonderful benefit of
hindsight and all of what's been
presented sir and disclosed
if I had arrived at an earlier
understanding of the level of
the occupation fortification
that took place here and the resulting
impacts and events that took place
across the country
um
at any point that that became crystal
clear I think the effort would have been
around
convening a very specific meeting
um
probably with the big 12 agencies
I would have no doubt either hosted or
asked OPP commissioner karik to host it
or commissioner of the RCMP if she felt
other agencies from across the country
should have been involved
but essentially I think we needed to
have the discussion around
greater integration leading to a unified
command structure as was where we ended
up on the 13th of of February
there would have been a joint assessment
as there was on February 1st in Kanata
where we had multiple Pou commanders
experienced credible Commanders
whiteboarding an understanding of the
scale of resources and very quickly
coming to an understanding that it was
going to be of a scale that we had never
seen outside of a planned event
in the range of a thousand uh Pou Ward
officers and that within that same
72-hour period that I asked for a three
a three option plan to come back we
would have had an integrated if not a
unified effort across Big 12 agencies
nationally
three levels of of policing putting the
logistics and planning in place to lift
those officers into this jurisdiction or
any other jurisdiction that was facing a
similar level of threat
um that's probably the number one thing
that I would have initiated and I
suspect if I had this information
commissioner Creek would have had this
information Creek commissioner lucky
would have had this information interim
Chief Jim Raymer would have had this
information and we would have been
bullying up each other's phones saying
we need a call and we need a plan and we
need to pull this thing together on
behalf of Canadians
I ask you just you raised an issue about
planned events were you a member of the
Toronto police service at the time in
2010 of the G20 Summit yesterday I was a
deputy chief and uh I understand from
from
Justice Morton's report that the Toronto
Police Service had four months to plan
for the G20 approximately I recall five
but call it five
um did you play a role in the in the G20
or in the response to G20 by the Toronto
Police Service and other police services
either before or after yes sir I I was
asked by
um Chief player to attend the initial
briefing up in Muskoka that was a
briefing jointly I Believe by OPP and
RCMP on the status of the g820
um at that briefing
feels like about an hour into a two hour
briefing the announcement was made we're
severing the G20 from Muskoka it will go
down to the city of Toronto
um
that's a that's a memory that won't
leave me very quickly because at that
point even without fully understanding
the implications that statement I knew
that
our colleagues there had some four or
five years of planning lead time and we
were going to be really behind
um where they were to to take on the G20
aspect
uh in the city of Toronto and driving
straight back down to provide that
information to the command team
did that did your experience G20 in the
Toronto Police Service
inform any part of your response to the
events that unfolded here in Ottawa
hugely hugely
um now then a couple of other things
then please navigator you were asked by
my
my friend again from the Ops about
Navigator I understand Navigator is a
the Best in Class advisory firm dealing
with
Communications advice and crisis
management yes sir
um
have you been involved in a in other
complex crises other than the protests
that we're dealing with here all too
many sir and and have you made use of or
other police services to your knowledge
made use of experts in Communications
yes sir yes
now why in this case did the Ops and the
board
the Ops board want the advice of
communication specialists
of the caliber of a firm like Navigator
I can't remember if I provided it in
statement or in evidence in Chief but um
throughout my tenure as Chief my
performance evaluations by the HR
Committee of the board were always
outstanding uh the one area that they
wanted me to continue to try to push on
was that Services capability for
corporate Communications broadly crisis
Communications specifically
um while I explained that was a function
of a lack of Staffing and a lack of
budget to fill Staffing our inability to
recruit that type of quality
Communications into the organization it
was going to take far too long for us to
build that capability organically
through HR processes and if they felt
that we needed to make a leap then we
would have to procure those Services the
board was very much supportive of that
particularly going into the long budget
battle that was 2021 and so I made a
recommendation in I believe in a public
board meeting that the board consider a
procurement for a firm of Navigators
quality and and I was granted approval
by the board to pursue that with the
condition that they would support both
the board and the Ottawa Police Service
through the procurement process
Navigator was signed on that was to help
us with very high risk high profile
controversial joint board service
initiative to address workplace sexual
harassment workplace sexual violence and
harassment and the Ottawa Police Service
systemic misogyny to be clear and
Navigator was contracted to come in to
support the board and the service around
internal and external Communications
when the Convoy events arrived here I
recommended to the board that we
continue the com the contract with
navigator to support both the board and
the service around Communications and
crisis Communications
my friend again from the Ottawa Police
Service asked you to showed you an
invoice that actually was delivered
after you had left office but had you
remained as chief of the Police Service
once this Convoy event was over would
you also have ended the Mandate that was
the procurement for assisting uh in that
respect
um no until I had probably had a
conversation I would have had
commissioner was with through that
unified command structure to what extent
would Navigators support that unified
command structure particularly the
communications component of it if there
was no need for any further supports
from navigator to the to the incident
command unified command then I would
have ended Navigators participation in
that because they did support
Communications uh efforts up until that
point
the next conversation I would have had
was commissioner to commissioner karik
and lucky
to what extent do the three of us
believe that Navigator supports benefit
us going forward in that unified
organization chart that you received
that you showed and if I had received
significant negative feedback or a
significant decision position from both
of them that we discontinued I'd have
taken that into serious consideration
and likely ended the contract totally at
that point if I didn't and my two
colleagues felt that it was useful I
would have continued on the contract but
only to support the Strategic level the
command level of that unified Command
right
and just as to that I'm not going to
pull the document up but
um am I right that you shared the fact
that Ops and the Ops board
were using navigator to assist in
Communications with your federal agent
Federal policing partner and other
policing Partners yes sir both Navigator
and Asi were referenced in my tri-level
meetings where all three levels of
government were present and in both
occasions I offered their services to
any of those levels or any of those
parties if they thought it would be
helpful I was completely above board
about the fact that we procured these
services and I was willing to share
those resources should there be any
value in it by any of those Partners
just for the record Ops I don't need it
Mr registrar but Ops
14454 at page 39 is one such
communication
um I think you told the commissioner
that Navigator was in was working with
your Communications
team at the Ops significantly augmenting
vacancies that existed in capabilities
that we simply did not have
now
um
I want to ask you then please some
questions about your February second
comment that there may not be a policing
solution
to this protest you've explained that
this was an aspect of the event that you
you wish you'd done differently I won't
go back to to that part of it but after
the meeting of February 2nd 2022 you did
clarify your comments in a number of
communications I want to just get your
get you to identify them please so
register OPB 424 please this should be
an email February 3rd
between you Chief slowly and chair Deans
scroll down if we can
there if you see in the first paragraph
I encourage you as board chair and other
City officials to use your influence to
secure additional resources for a safe
lawful end to the demonstration
I once again accept your full support to
secure more resources this aligns with
my statement that there may not be a
police solution to this demonstration
despite the fact we are doing everything
reasonable to resolve the situation
safely and lawfully and it carries on
did you send that to the chair yes sir
can I please ask you to look at OPB
981 and Mr registrar this time on page
two of the document please
thank you
foreign
ah there it is you see the Radio Canada
reporter
earlier the question is to you these are
notes of a press briefing earlier you
said there might not be a policing
solution do you still have that same
opinion regardless of what is being said
at the federal level
we continue to do our very you wrote or
said we continue to do our very best and
as you know this has gone far beyond
Ottawa
um I will continue and you gave another
answer this continued to be a discussion
and you continue to try to clarify and
answer press questions and other
questions absolutely sir okay there and
it carries on but I'm going to leave it
at that
uh please you were asked questions today
about documents rather that showed the
possibility of an interlock insurer to
assist in negotiating a solution to this
issue
um is that a a policing solution
no it would not be sir right
I want to ask you some questions about
the PLT and your support for PLC could I
please ask you to look at Ops 14454
and Mr registrar this is page 49 of the
document please February the 4th
these are notes of your
and I believe your general counsel
and
just scroll down if you would to page
three of the meeting notes or it's page
three of this meeting
and one two three there we go uh Pia
just at the top then thank you Mr do you
see PS that's you yes sir want a full
um negotiation strategy negotiation
strategy thank you it won't be perfect
but build on PLT
build it a PLT part into it yes sir
we won't take this down at once we are
working on a larger negotiation strategy
yes sir did you make that comment yes
sir not just in this meeting but many
many others did it express your your
intention and attitude towards PLT and
negotiation I think so explicitly and
repeatedly could I ask you please to
look at Ops 7999
just for the record that was February
the 4th could I go to February 7th Ops
7999 Please Mr registrar
Ed
just this is a an email message that you
sent do you see to a number of people
um
I'm not going to get the ranks right but
you can see that's the senior command
it's
uh superintendent or perhaps that time
inspector Bernier
um actually the the the two line is to
Sergeant Louis Carvalho is an
outstanding front line
supervisor and was one of the two
supervisors for the for the Ottawa
Police Service PLT thank you on the same
line I've put Mark Patterson who then
was the event Commander and you wrote
thank you for this you and the PLT
members are invaluable we are still
learning how best to work with you
integrate you leverage you support you
please be patient and continue your
great work be safe and be well did you
you sent that to the team yes sir same
question did it express your your view
and attitude towards PLT and its work
absolutely and Beyond this email I went
down to the PLT room at headquarters
sorry at City Hall spent the better part
of an algorithm listening to their
concerns hearing their ideas expressing
directly unfiltered from me to them my
full support and appreciation to them
I brought Louis Carvalho and his
colleague I shouldn't forget his name
another excellent Road Sergeant who led
the PLT to the November 1st meeting with
the public order unit to make sure that
they had Direct input and involvement in
that most critical moment
um I just can't think of any more that I
could do and could say to demonstrate my
full commitment to the PLT function in
these events and this reflects my
commitment to them well before these
events arrived in my city thank you
couple of other questions then please
finally texts text messages mobile
devices you were asked questions by
Council for the Ops about your mobile
device I understand that you surrendered
your
your Your Service issued mobile phone to
the Ops when you left your command is
that true that's correct sir
and when did you receive it back
I can't remember the sequence but
shortly after when I didn't have any
Communications and people were trying to
get a hold of me I asked if I could get
it back and I was given it back
um and then I asked when are you gonna
once I got my own device personal device
Now set up I asked when they were going
to pick it up and I literally got no
response sometimes for weeks on end
somewhere around May I'll take Council
magikovsky's magikovsky's advice that it
was late May when they finally sent
somebody around a to deliver disclosure
that I've been waiting on and B to pick
up my device I had stopped using it
months before and so I simply cleared it
to make sure that it wasn't going to be
used by anybody else did you know in the
period of time when the service had it
back prior to it being returned to you
what was extracted from the device or
what could have been recovered by the
service they could have taken everything
out of the device if they chose to or
what might be available to them as that
the service from the service provider
that provided mobile phone services to
the service absolutely sir right and
final question then please final topic
your resignation
chair Dean's told the commissioner
that in the midst of these events the
Convoy events she spoke with you and
performed a form of wellness check
during you had a conversation with you
do you recall first of all having that
counter with her I had a conversation
where it was not a wellness check sir
she told us that she told you that there
were people who I think she used this
language wanted your head yes sir do you
recall that yes sir
can you tell us what was your reaction
to that
I have to tell you sir I think by that
point
um the wanting your head comment
just piled on to the hundreds if not
thousands of other comments that I was
receiving
through literally every form of human
communication possible
she told us that she telephone you on
the evening of the 14th of February
and that she raised the issue of your
possible resignation you told us about
that yes sir she did yeah please tell
the commissioner what was your answer to
chair Deans when she asked you whether
you wished to resign
my answer was actually reasonably
accurate as reported by chair Deans I've
put my heart and soul into this and by
this commissioner I met this entire
Ottawa Police Service for my entire
tenure as a chief of police and it
included the last three very difficult
weeks of the Convoy events I told her
that it was my intention to see it
through right to the end of successful
and safe end for the events happening
here in Ottawa and through that a
contribution to the events happening
across the country
told her that it was very inappropriate
for her to have this call with me I
think at 9 30 at night on Valentine's
Day and I just happened to be in my
bedroom with my wife
trying to get some sleep for another
busy day the next day and to be asking
me to resign from my office at this
stage at that time and in that manner I
thought was very inappropriate
what did she ask you to do in response
when you told her that
think about it
which to me meant she'd already made up
her mind she wasn't interested in
hearing anything about my commitment to
the organization and my commitment to
see it through she was pushing for me to
resign did she ask you to think about it
overnight yes
now you've explained that the to the
commissioner your resignation
was motivated by your wish to enhance
Public Safety and removing yourself from
the equation and could allow the
resources to be obtained
was it also important to you or how was
how important was it to you to show the
community and the service and your
family who had come to followed you to
here to Ottawa that you were not
quitting
that was critically important on both
ends most most importantly commissioner
to do everything I could literally with
the last Act of my my time in office to
remove myself out of a trust equation
that was heading in the wrong direction
for the audible Police Service which I
led
anything that could have contributed to
faster and more resources arriving in
this city to address this still
metastasizing local crisis and National
crisis was my obligation was my
responsibility and so I took that last
Act
but I will tell you it mixed very
heavily with the concept of me quitting
something
and to this day it still rubs me
I won't do justice it still hurts me and
it hurts my family
thank you very much
thank you commissioner
thank you sir thank you
any re-examination yes please no go
ahead good afternoon Chief slowly good
afternoon sir this morning Council for
the Ottawa Police Service asked you
about the circumstances in which
superintendent William was removed do
you want answer all those questions
setting aside any dispute as to why he
was removed help us understand how the
instant command structure works normally
isn't there someone predestinated to
step in and for contingencies such as
when the event Commander becomes
unavailable or simply to cover uh 24 7
when the event Commander needs to go to
sleep
yes a challenge that I found when I came
into the organization
um when I built the incident command
team in the Toronto Police Service I
identified that as a major risk
um so as we're going back commissioner
this would be somewhere in the range of
2000 and late 2007 2008
we would have multiple Cycles on a
regular occasion in Toronto for major
events major incidents that would
require an incident commander and
potentially an event or major incident
level commander on top of that so when I
started to build that as a staff
superintendent for the Toronto Police
Service I built in three levels of
redundancy so that we could handle any
three major events in the city at any
time with full incident command teams
full teams meaning an Incident Commander
an operations lead a planning lead a
logistics lead at a minimum and then it
could be built out from there but we
could have three stood up incident
command teams fully trained and capable
Deployable within a 24-hour basis it
also meant that if we had one event but
it was protracted and went longer than
12 hours or 24 hours we would have a
plan B and a plan C to come in place now
I did not inherit that level of Staffing
or that level of funding when I came
here as chief of police but that is an
optimal level and the audible Police
Service at no point during my tenure was
anywhere near that level even with that
I encouraged our thinking around
incident command and critical incident
command to go beyond the 12-hour cycle
because every now and then something
takes us past that point of human
resilience where we see a significant
decline in decision making and
capability
we didn't have that ability going into
these events we were very stretched we
were already overwhelmed by the events
of the explosion that we've talked about
in in Maryvale and so we were
overstretched and overtired before we
even got to the point of these Convoy
events unfolding on the weekend of
January 29th
now you also said this morning in
response to questions from my friend
Council for the Ops
that superintendent Dunlop attended a
meeting on February the 3rd in the
morning do you recall if you asked the
deputies that afternoon as to why
superintendent Dunlap was at that
earlier meeting
I didn't ask him that afternoon I asked
him both times when the meetings
happened I think the first meeting is
around 10 30. I stand to be corrected
I asked during the meeting why is
superintendent Dunlop providing this
briefing I want to hear from staff
sergeant Mike Stoll I want to hear from
inspector Murray
Jamie why are you providing this
briefing and he tried to give me some
explanation we've moved off of the
public Order Plan we're going to talk
about a neighborhood policing strategy
and again I politely interrupted that's
not what this briefing is about the
briefing is about the public order
options the plan that I asked for on
February 1st literally after doing that
two times and not wanting to go to a
third time I said look I think we're not
in a constructive place here let's end
this meeting I would like another
meeting before noon hour where I get
inspector Moran and staff sergeant still
giving me a briefing on the public Order
Plan with the three options I waited
patiently for another hour and a half I
think somewhere around 12 or 12 30
another briefing happened again
superintendent Dunlop appeared on my
team's screen
he started to present a discussion
around neighborhood policing in the
neighborhoods outside of the red zone
again I politely interrupted that's not
the briefing I'm looking for where is
Staff Sergeant Mike Stoll I was told he
was in another room I said well let's
wait somebody go get him bring him onto
the screen or have him sign on to the
teams meeting I need to hear from staff
sergeant Mike Stoll eventually staff
sergeant Mike Stahl was brought into the
room and given a chair next to
superintendent Dunlop
I then asked Mike what is the plan what
are the options he started to tell me
that they hadn't got the resources they
had requested on February 1st he wasn't
in a position to provide the briefing to
me I was extremely frustrated and
disappointed and I was confused because
I still did not understand why
superintendent Dunlop was involved in
this meeting nor did acting deputy chief
Ferguson I can't remember if deputy
chief Bell was on either one of those
calls In fairness but deputy chief
Ferguson didn't explain to me at any
point as to what the role of
superintendent Dunlop was and why we
were not getting a presentation on the
public Order Plan and the three options
I only found out about superintendent
Dunlop on Saturday morning February 5th
towards the end of that morning incident
command briefing where finally I said
where's The Incident Commander and I was
told then by acting deputy chief
Ferguson
that that was superintendent Dunlop
closed the meeting I raised concern that
I was not aware of it I closed the
meeting and then I asked for acting
deputy chief Ferguson and deputy chief
Bell to see me in my office it was at
that point I finally had a disclosure
from acting deputy chief Ferguson that
she had switched
superintendent Dunlop into the incident
command I felt I understood it was an
incident command level not an event
Commander level I understand there's
confusion around that but the essential
disclosure on February 5th was that
rione was no longer part of this Lucas
was at a lower level and superintendent
Dunlop had been inserted into the
significant decision-making operational
level
that was the first time I heard of it
counseled both for their respective
roles and I made sure that from there on
in in repeated meetings that we would
not have a repeat of that level of
miscommunication I never removed the
decision-making Authority from acting
deputy chief Ferguson I always allowed
her to confer with whoever she needed to
around these decisions
but I was very clear going forward no
more surprises like that
now in relation to these events I like
to take you to a document and see if it
refreshes your memory Ops three zeros
one four four five four
Mr clerk if we go to page three and four
please
oh sorry one four four eight four
so this appears to be some notes to
yourself dated February the 3rd
page three
the time is one o'clock to 1 30.
and the title says meeting with
acting deputy chief Ferguson and deputy
chief Bell repeal you briefings so this
would be the afternoon after
superintendent Dunlop attended the
morning meeting at 10 right yes sir so
if we go down to page four
so scroll down for a bit do you see the
paragraph that starts with I asked why
superintendent Dunlop was doing the POU
briefing and not staff sergeant Stowe
was that a question you asked at this
meeting I believe so yes sir what answer
did you get
I don't think I got any answer except
that Jamie was superintendent Dunlop was
really experienced with neighborhood
policing issues I said that's not what
we're dealing with here it's a PLU plan
Jamie's not in charge of of the ESU
which is our version of the POU staff
sergeant
Stole was in charge of it again there
was no
sir you need to understand we've made
the switch this is what's going on and
in that switch superintendent Dunlop
feels that we don't need a Pou plan we
need a neighborhood policing plan that
wasn't provided to me
now in relation to staff sergeant Mike
Stowe who the person who you expected uh
a Pou briefing from what was his role
within the POU at that time he was in
charge of the public order unit and do
you know if he continued in this role
into February no that's my understanding
and I still haven't received any formal
explanation that he removed himself from
that role at some point in the next week
I still don't tell to this day a
specific reason why I've heard through
my own staff that he was frustrated with
the overall incident command
but I haven't heard it was in relation
to any one individual or any one
particular incident to this day and I
don't know if in the after action review
that was completed that that's become
more clear for anyone we've seen
references in some documents that he
resigned his position on February the
7th now are you aware of why he left his
position with the Pou or anything that
was expressed either in writing or
otherwise my ceremonial sergeant major
Steve Boucher was the one that gave me
the information that he was frustrated
what was happening something to do with
the turnover within the incident command
team and and that his position was no
longer valid or valued enough but I
never got any more details than that
okay
uh Council for for the Ops also asked
you about your meeting on February the
9th at 9 15 a.m yes sir and he put you
some questions based on the notes of
deputy chief Ferguson and you commented
on the quality of her notes now we also
happen to have notes taken by Ms hanod
she's the general counsel for the Ops
and I want to take you to those notes
please Ops three zeros 14454
foreign
so can we go to page 130 please
go down please
so um do you see the
the notation that starts with very
little political support
to get us support or resources
we don't change that Dynamic we'll get
nothing
now they've sent their team to support
us
over 30 days
their political Masters don't think Ops
did their jobs and we won't bail out
they don't have a plan
I they then will go publicly
that and then
I guess as a equal signs with a slash so
that doesn't equal leadership and they
will take it from us
that's the best I can make from the fan
written notes now I want to ask you to
comment on the quality or the accuracy
of these notes
well Christian you know as many things I
don't know if she was ever trained on
being a scribe but she's certainly
capable of taking
a lot of notes and has proven so not
just in these events
um but just what particular are you
looking for no just uh because these are
notes of the same meeting that Council
for the Ops had asked you and uh your
answer to Mr majakovsky's questions were
based on your questioning of Deputy
Chiefs Ferguson's notes so I'm going to
take you to a different sets of notes
and ask you to comment on what happened
at that meeting do these note accurately
reflect what happened at that meeting
there's things that were said yes there
are more accurate Reflections or yes
okay those are my questions my colleague
Miss Rodriguez who have more
I can just sorry the portion of the
notes you just showed me are what I'm
referring to if you'd like me to adopt
the entire thing more fully than I'm not
sure if that's sufficient but no uh I
took you to this passage because I
believe that was the context in which uh
Council for the Ops asked you the
questions this morning thank you sir
hi Mr slowly again I do have some
clarification questions that arose from
your questioning um today
um I wanted to take you first to Ops
three zeros 14565
now Council for the city of Ottawa took
you to this document and asked you some
questions
and these are your notes of February 9.
and I want to take you to the fifth
um bullet point
sorry fifth from from the redacted
portion uh important for mayor to know
so this is now a phone call with the
mayor Steve kanilakis Serge arpan at
about 2 20 and this is uh your side of
the conversation as recorded by The
Scribe important for mayor to know until
this is fixed in Ottawa this will
continue in other areas in the province
if mayor hears anywhere that we don't
have a plan we have a plan they think we
have a too aggressive
too aggressive of a plan here so I
wanted to ask you about that part
my understanding is that 12 10 or so
there was a a meeting with respect to
the 3.0 plan and so when you say they
think we have too aggressive of a plan
here I assume that they in that sentence
is OPP and rscmp is that right the
integrated planning team that had
arrived yes sir yes ma'am and so I
wanted to ask why did you think that
their view was that the plan was too
aggressive
um I think we've heard in previous
testimony might have been Chief
superintendent Abrams or sorry Chief
superintendent party or superintendent
Abrams that there was a pretty healthy
and long discussion at the point where
superintendent Patterson started to
present our 24 to 72 hour priorities
operational priorities
again just for context or that was never
a presentation to be a tactical briefing
for commanders to pull apart a plan and
assess it that actually took place later
on in the evening
the superintendent Patterson wanted to
present a sense to the integrated
planning team that we
having just heard the overall plan from
acting Deputy Ferguson comments from me
that this was a demonstration that as
the operational lead he had a sense of
what the priorities were for the next 24
to 72 hours and what the resources would
be necessary for those types of
priorities it wasn't intended to invite
a detailed debate about the adequacy and
effectiveness of those priorities and
those plans a debate did ensue and
probably
in hindsight a healthy debate to have at
that point of forming storming norming
around a very new escalation in
integration
um
but the feedback as I was giving was
they might not like our plan but there
is a plan they might think our plan is
too aggressive but there is a plan and
if you hear from other sources that
there isn't a plan well there is a plan
that's the context around which I'm
giving that information
and was there anything in particular
that they thought was too aggressive
about the plan
again I think it was the concept of a
nighttime public order operation at one
of the sites there were other you know
you don't have enough Pou resources have
you have you used PLT all the way there
was a range of issues that were raised
and I think are documented in Chief one
or both of those OPP officers and there
was an intervention I Believe by an RCMP
officer that suggested we would need
some seven or eight hundred Pou officers
to carry that out and then a commitment
that they would get us some 500 or 516
public order officers to affect that
thank you now in response to a question
from my friend for CCF you indicated
that in a conversation with Minister
Blair you had indicated to him that you
had towed hundreds of vehicles when he
asked about enforcement and whether
enforcement had been considered you
recall
saying that I can't remember it was
hundreds of vehicles but I know the
document was on there and I I had given
some accurate numbers of vehicles that
we towed it wasn't in a document you
were relaying a discussion you had had
with Minister Blair in which you said to
him you know we've issued thousands of
tickets we've towed hundreds of vehicles
okay well there was a document that I
viewed earlier on but yes I did try to
give him the most accurate assessment of
the bylaw offenses that we had we had
issued and the number of vehicles and
the nature of vehicles that we took okay
um Mr testified that on the first
weekend 28 Vehicles were towed as a
result of uh essentially blocking
emergency lanes and so Towing was used
as a way to to clear emergency emergency
lanes
um he testified that that was
essentially the purpose of Towing to
maintain those emergency lanes and after
the first weekend there was generally
compliance with maintaining those
emergency lanes and therefore there
wasn't much Towing needed after that and
he agreed that there were about zero to
three vehicles towed thereafter after
the first weekend every day so many days
there were zero some days there were one
two up to three vehicles but in total
the number of vehicles towed was quite
low and there were never any heavy
trucks that were that were towed they
were all passenger vehicles so I just
want to understand where you uh where
you got that understanding that hundreds
of vehicles had been towed again I I
would need to see a document where I
said that I just recall seeing a
document earlier on today about hundreds
I felt I gave an accurate answer to a
minister player that have you considered
Towing any vehicles and I said we had
been Towing Vehicles since the beginning
I think that aligns with what you've
just said if I got the total wrong
that's a challenge of communicating
numbers and me will be able to remember
numbers but we were Towing Vehicles
heavily at the beginning and
consistently throughout where it was
safe to do so using the equipment that
we have and that was my substantive
answer to minister Blair when he said
have you thought about Towing Vehicles
okay so we can rely on Mr ayot's
evidence and the documents from the city
of Ottawa bylaw with respect to the
number of of uh I would prefer to rely
on The Incident Commander and the stats
that we kept overall because there may
have been other Towing operations that
Mr ayat was not aware of again I'm not
challenging Mr ayotte's Numbers I just
don't know if that is the single source
of Truth for all Towing activities in
the theater okay fair enough I want to
talk to you a little bit about a
discussion you had with Mr Miller about
crowd Dynamics and generally the risk of
harm
um in in enforcement efforts if I can
take you to Ops three zeros 14454
and this is again miss hino's notes
and I'll take you to page six which is
notes from January 31st and I believe
we've seen this
before if we can zoom in right
so if you see the uh third bullet
turning from demo to occupation
increasingly volatile and aggressive
and then it says police intervention to
remove massive risk which is underlined
injury loss of life
um and so
if we look further down after the list
of police forces that are there
it says operational arrest no safe way
to do this injury death
and then uh under that
avoided full-scale riots
so
I wanted to understand your basis for
understanding that there was no safe way
to carry out removals or arrests without
the risk of injury or death
what was the basis
for for saying that there was no safe
way to do arrests without risking injury
or death just to be clear clearly we did
do enforcement and clearly we did make
arrests
but to be absolutely clear I forget who
asked the question commissioner but was
this more like a family event or a
powder keg it was more like a powder
cake and no point ever more Powder Keg
than that very first weekend I had
experienced myself when I went on foot
patrol at Wellington in Rideau and
Sussex I had experienced it myself
I had seen it and felt it firsthand and
those efforts of swarming officers not
just an individual officer writing a
bile offense but sometimes officers in
twos or threes or more were swarmed
senior experienced officers we had brand
new recruits on the street
this was a regular occurrence
sometimes that serious injury or death
is not the death or the injury to the
officer it's that an officer being
swarmed and overwhelmed physically may
need to resort to
Serious injury or death to prevent
themselves from being overwhelmed so
it's a two-way issue not fair that the
officer is going to get hurt but the
officer may hurt or take the life of
someone who's trying to overwhelm them
and in every one of the instances that I
saw or I even attempted as a uniform
officer to gain compliance even the most
small compliance was aggressively
surrounded and intimidated and if I had
carried through on that or other offices
carried it through on the most basic
level of Engagement never mind
enforcement there was a risk of
escalation to violence and the crowd
dynamics that existed that weekend
it is only but for the grace of God that
something worse did not happen
right so you're telling me there was
enforcement and my understanding is no
police officers were ever assaulted
that's not correct I believe that we I
I've given an example on the
situational report from the night of
February 4th into February 5th inspector
day who talked about one of our
sergeants who was swarmed and assaulted
city workers in the same situation
report who were sworned now I don't know
whether or not a criminal code charge
was ever laid whether or not the officer
could identify who did it but as was led
earlier on not every incident of assault
or threat led to an actual charge but
those incidents occurred on a regular
basis on a 24 7 basis across that micro
theater that caused us so much harm and
Trauma in the city
and were you also then in in that
assessment
um that there was risk of injury and
death and that the crowd was volatile
were you receiving specific intelligence
about
um the the composition of some of the
people there that made that led you to
think that were you receiving
intelligence or information that led you
to believe that there was this risk
I could see it firsthand and yes I got
regular reports literally at every
single briefing cycle about the level of
volatility across the theater
and you were using that then to
determine when enforcement action should
be used and where no I didn't determine
when enforcement actions should be I set
a strategic level Direction use
discretion we don't want to cause a
bigger problem than we're trying to
solve make sure officer safety and
wellness is is there make sure we
understand that trying to do enforcement
in one area may be more risky than than
not so I never directed any particular
enforcement action if that's what you're
asking sorry by you I meant Ops
generally not you personally through the
incident command process yes okay
um
Miss tamman for the Coalition of
businesses and residents had asked about
closing access to the downtown core
prior to the Convoy's arrival and your
view that the charter precluded that
activity you recall that discussion you
had with her
um I think I put some Nuance into it but
the advice that I had got around full
closures of the downtown area were not
in alignment with that with that course
of action and did you ever consider the
distinction between an individual's
right to go down to Parliament Hill and
protest and the need for the trucks to
access to the downtown uh so that is did
you ever consider blocking access to the
trucks but not the individual protesters
I won't say there was no consideration
around that but the conveyance whether
it's a skateboard or a truck is what
brings a person to the location
okay sorry
this so but the skateboard is clearly
able to go into downtown there's no
restrictions to skateboards there are
established truck routes that allow only
certain types of vehicles to be on
certain roadways right and it's my
understanding that PLT tried to
negotiate around those truck routes and
to keep as many trucks out of the
downtown core as possible okay
uh so you also told Council for the city
of Ottawa that one of the opsb's primary
functions was to assist in getting the
resources that Ops needed do you recall
that exchange yes
now are you aware of the other primary
functions of the board during a major
event such as this one
during a major event was just the
primary functions of a board in general
uh well in setting priorities especially
when it comes to a critical incident or
a major event such as this one I'm not
aware of the board's ability to set
priorities during a major event they can
set priorities for the organization
overarching priorities strategic
priorities but I'm not aware if I stand
to be corrected that the board can set
priorities for any specific event okay
so I'll take you to the Morden report
which we've seen before com 50616
and I just want to make sure that we're
clear about the scope of the function of
the board that it's not limited to
getting resources at least not according
to the Morton report if you can go to
page 22
so there it talks about uh three
elements to the consultation protocol so
the first element is information
exchange between the board and the chief
of police
reciprocal information exchange must
exist and I'm going to kind of condense
it a little bit for time to ensure that
each obtain information relevant to
their respective roles the board will be
provided with operational information
that will inform its policy making
function and the chief of police will
have an opportunity to provide his or
her views on policy options the board is
considering with this exchange both
policies and operations may be adjusted
to address changing circumstances
and so so the first step is really
exchange of information now the critical
point is the second element which um
seeks specific operational information
from the chief of police where a
critical point arises and now according
to Morden this is specific policing
operations such as a gun and gang
operation events such as for example a
G20 or organizationally significant
issues and so I would put to you that
the events that happened in January
February of 2022 in the Convoy was a
critical point that the board should
have been involved with at an
operational level would you agree that
that's
contemplated in Morden no I wouldn't and
even with this information in front of
me I mean if if what Morton is
considering first of all Morton is a
report it is not a statutory Authority
Under the police services act so it's
informative but it's not instructive
secondly
um if what he refers to as a policing
operation is a gun and gang operation
if that is for instance what is
I'll go back to my Toronto police days
but Toronto police experienced
you know sometimes years in a row of
escalating guns and gang violence what
is Chief your approach to addressing gun
and gang violence in the city we'd like
to have some policy positions on that
for instance we are not going to use
Street checks and carding to
disproportionately stigmatize or
victimize black and brown populations in
the city check Morton's right
if what Morton is considering is that
Chief when you go to take down the
Bloods and the crypts operating between
31 and 23 division you need to make sure
that you have OverWatch capability uh to
make sure that none of our officers get
hurt sorry you've crossed the line you
shouldn't be there
I can't imagine in a thousand years that
Morton would consider that the board
would sit down with the chief of police
in the middle of the first weekend and
start to debate policy instructions
around a still unfolding National
Security event well maybe we should keep
reading so specifically I was
considering the point of event not an
opera a specific operation but an event
like an international Summit of world
leaders
a protest of this size I would put to
you is a significant event that would
trigger the second element that's
identified here no a planned event for a
visit of world leaders usually as a four
to five year cycle of planning and in
which case yes they would have plenty of
opportunity I gave information with Iran
commissioner about the planning that
went into the G20 that severed from
muskoko down to Toronto in five months
we had regular meetings regular
scheduled board meetings specially
scheduled board meetings where Chief
Blair and the command team which I was a
part of provided a lot of information to
the board around what we're planning for
the board had time to take tour of
facilities that we were giving we were
able to give very detailed updates even
though we were on an incredibly intense
timeline and the board could therefore
in those occasions Express policy
matters but not in the middle of the
weekend where the G20 burnt cars down in
our city where we're sitting down having
policy discussions with the board
so I'll take you to the third element
board collaboration in defining the what
but not the how of an operation so it
says the board should use the
operational information it obtains from
the chief of police to determine what
the Police Services overall objectives
and priorities will be for a particular
operation event or organizationally
significant issue so if I hear what
you're saying correctly you're telling
me that the protests in Ottawa was not
did not fall into any of these
categories is that what you're telling
me I I don't believe they did and even
if they did the ability for us to slow
the world down in order to have a policy
discussion I don't think would have been
practical with these established the
Toronto Police Service can create
specific operational plans that will
outline how the police policing missions
and objectives will be achieved the
Toronto Police Service must always
maintain its autonomy to make and
execute particular decisions during the
operation the board should review the
Toronto police services operational
plans to ensure they are consistent with
the mission or objectives stated by the
board
and that they have the benefit of an
adequate policy framework
so
if I'm understanding correctly your view
is that that doesn't apply to this
situation correct if I understand
everything that's in this paragraph and
where it fits into the larger structure
of the Morton report if I understand
that Morton is suggesting the board
should set the mission statement for the
incident command operational plan I
would have to reject that
okay fair enough
um and so it's fair to say that in this
case the board did not have an
opportunity to provide input on the on
the what as is contemplated here is that
correct
again based on my limited ability to
interpret this section in the regards to
the large report
okay
now during the February 5th Ops
Pia chair Dean's asked you to indicate
what you needed in order to bring the
demonstration to an end we've talked
about that and
today the fact that the answer was made
public has come up as something that was
potentially problematic
do you recall that being discussed
um so in your witness statement you say
Chief slowly publicly announced the
request for 1800 police resources during
a special city council meeting on
February 7th this was not his normal
course of action but the freedom Convoy
was unprecedented specifically Miss
Dean's asked Chief slowly in a public
opsb meeting to provide a detailed
report on that level of resources
required
um and then at page 43 you say
commissioner lucky expressed concern
that his public request for 1800
officers was creating officer safety
issues she slowly recalls defending the
decision as it had been made by his
board chair Miss Dean's at a public
meeting
um did chair Deans or the mayor consult
with you on whether to make the
specifics of the request public
the short answer would be yes there's a
lot of discussion back and forth as to
who would sign the letter when the
letter would be presented how it would
be presented quite frankly I left that
largely to the chair in the mayor to
sort out but in terms of them asking
whether or not the request should be
made public
in a public forum and to be released to
the public was that well the substantive
discussion was around the board's
ability to secure adequate and effective
resources for what we were dealing with
it was going to be a public document I
don't think there was discussion about
it probably wasn't a very long
discussion the intent was for one or
both of those individuals to sign a
public letter and send it to the highest
offices of the land provincially and
federally and did you ever ask that it
not be made public no I didn't
um
those are all my questions my apologies
I'm perhaps I've missed it is the fact
that the letter is made public just that
it's sent I just want to make sure I
understand the question
um no that the the numbers were not
provided in camera and that the letters
were made public and were not kept
confidential like sent on a confidential
basis
sorry that and apps I've just
misunderstood uh commissioner that the
letters were made public when they were
sent to the Prime Minister and this
listener Jenner and the premier and the
minister of Public Safety or that they
were otherwise made public yeah I'm not
sure we're gonna we we're going to be
giving evidence
if you want
the council to ask the witness further
question you might put it that way but
I'm not gonna
ask for
evidence from Council that was certainly
not my intention commissioner I'm just
trying to understand the basis for my
friend's question that's all I just I
don't understand what my friend means by
making the letter public I just I don't
understand and if the suggestion is that
the letter was made public otherwise and
by sending it to the politicians then I
question the basis for the question that
is all well the question stands what it
means is is something that the witness
can be asked what he understands from
the question but I it's not up to you to
cross-examine or question
the the the questioner if you want a
further opportunity to ask questions to
the witness that's fine
the question and answer is I have maybe
I've misunderstood but there was a
question and it was answered
is that am I wrong about that
sorry commissioner and I perhaps it's
late in the day and I'm I apologize if
I'm no one adding to the confusion I
certainly don't intend to cross-examine
my friend on her question that was but
no but go ahead what are you speaking I
don't believe I was commissioner with
and certainly I can assure you and my
friend that was not at all my intent the
reason I'm I'm the only reason I'm
speaking is I had understood Mr slowly
to say his witness sound for me and it
came out during his evidence and I put
it to him that he had made the number
public during the February 7th council
meeting my friend has asked him whether
the letter was made public and I didn't
understand that to have been the case or
that to have been in evidence up until
the moment of the council meeting so I'm
just asking what is meant so that I can
understand the basis for the question
it's not a cross-examination but of
course there has to be a basis for any
question put forward that's the only
clarification I was seeking if it's
confusing I'll leave it there I think
I've stayed in my concern for the record
and I'll leave it there I'm happy to
respond my question was whether the
request was ever made to keep the
request Pub um private not public it
wasn't about the letters it was about
the resource requests the numbers
whether that was ever it was ever
requested that the number of resources
required be kept confidential I wasn't
asking about the letters I was asking
about the number of resources but in any
event I'm more than content to leave it
there I just again maybe it's late in
the day I'm content to leave it there
okay well if everybody's content I'm
content
um and so you've completed that's those
are all my questions thank you thank you
I don't have much I really only have one
area I want to just touch base with you
on and that's following up a question
you answered deal it from Ms Rodriguez
towards the end and was something like
uh they I think referring to OPP and
RCMP
uh commissioners
might not like our plan but there is a
plan is that you remember that answer
that question yes uh commissioner um it
wasn't
so much the Commissioners wouldn't like
my plan but the representatives that
they had sent in the integrated planning
team might might not having had that
briefing
suggest that it was a sufficient plan or
the right type or tone of plan but there
is a plan we spent 24 hours discussing
our plan presenting our plan and there
was an agreement to move forward around
integrating around that the details
still to be resolved should you hear
from other services other sources sorry
that there is no plan there is a plan
and then I'm trying to understand a bit
big picture what that plan involved and
and I saw as we went through the
documents there was
reference to and I think this comes from
meetings with the the levels of
government but also from other documents
that there was for example bite-sized
uh plans to for example deal with the
Redo Center or the Rito and Sussex
problem and we we heard about the that
operational plan
I guess what I'm asking was
big picture was the plan as you saw it
at that time
that you would take bites out of the
whole demonstration starting with Rito
and then moving to other areas I think I
saw a reference to that and you would
take chunks out of it that was
a big picture the the plan you
conceived of at that time I I would add
to that sir um so that is a significant
portion of it two things that are
important that plan was based on on
February 8th when it was first presented
refined again on February 9th still
based on the level of resources that we
currently had and could reasonably
predict and based on that current level
of resources February 8th 9th 10th until
we started to really see the numbers go
up over the 12th 13th 14th the best that
we could Envision operationally is
taking
chunks or bites out of the Red Zone and
holding that moving on to the next part
removing what was in there and holding
that ground
if we were able to get the concept of
predictable resources in the thousand
thousand plus the majority of which
would be public order we could conceive
of an entire theater of operations
similar to the one that ultimately was
deployed at the back end of the fourth
week the 17th 18th and 19th
but given the resource amounts that we
currently had and could recently predict
for 72 hours out the best we could do
was prioritize a list of locations and
attempt each day to take one or more of
those out secure that area so people
couldn't come back in and move to the
next highest priority based on
intelligence based on the context of
that 24-hour period and based on the
resources available in that 24-hour
period take it because you did talk
about this 24 hour to 72 hour and I'm
just trying to understand was that in
essence the plan you were referring to
when you said we do have a plan or is it
another plan uh that is the one as you
say the big plan to take down everything
or
or were they separate plans I'm trying
to understand thank you I think it's
caused a lot of confusion for a lot of
people and and I'll try to do a better
job there was only ever one plan in my
humble opinion only ever one plan
February 28th pre-arrival plan that
pivoted after the first weekend into
January 31st that became the February
5th document that my my Council shared
with you sir earlier on that was the 2.0
version of it and going into the second
weekend and then going into the meeting
with the integrated planning unit
February 8 and 9. that became the 3.0
document
the concept of operations was I remember
it being an eight-point concept I
believe it was finally captured as a
seven point concept talked about things
like
a public order subplan that would take
and hold area talked about negotiations
it talked about officer member wellness
and and and uh and health and safety a
range of Frameworks around which the
overall operating plan
um was focused on the the take and hold
component the public order component
that I was previously answering I would
say that would be a sub plan that fed
into the larger plan it wasn't the plan
on its own that was present that wasn't
on its own the taken hold the
overarching plan that we were inviting
the integrated planning team to come in
and assist with it was our current
attempt with the current resources we
had to make a meaningful impact safe and
successful but meaningful impact in the
small way that our resources would allow
us at this current time
hope that clarifies things but there is
one overarching plan and several
sub-plans
that subplan of take and hold was
specifically explained to the integrated
team at the February 9th meeting and
they challenged that subplan I think
constructively challenged that subplan
but they weren't challenging the
overarching plan the framework of
operations
okay because I'm just I'm still having
some trouble understanding if you have
the taken hold
basically and and I think that's was
explained to the in one of the documents
to the uh the tripartite group I think
saying well that allows us to move and
it included I think moving to Wellington
so I'm trying to understand you don't
need a big plan if you've got the bites
that work but but I maybe have
misunderstood no and it again sorry it
it is hard to understand
that wouldn't be sustainable we we could
with the resources stretches we were we
were trying to take what we could in
terms of public order plans
but if we didn't get a significant
greater amount of resources we would run
out of steam very quickly it's not a
sustainable thing and bite-sized across
even the theater that we had
that would take weeks if not months and
we just couldn't sustain our operations
at that point without that massive extra
amount of resources that the larger
concept was requiring the 1800 or 17 and
90 change
so the concept of operations plan the
3.0 plan was for a massive amount of
resources to come in to do a significant
amount of activities while that was
happening we presented this sub-plan of
existing resources to take and hold
areas of the of the of the Red Zone but
that was not sustainable and that would
not have ultimately led to a safe
successful outcome it's the best we
could do at that time and that's what we
were presenting
okay so that may answer the question I
was going to ask you so your bite-sized
plan process you weren't asking or you
weren't complaining about this
lack of additional resources
by OPP and RCMP to fuel that subplan you
were focused on the big plan yes sir
okay thank you that's helpful so we'll
adjourn for the oh sorry oh yes there's
one further announcement to make I'm
sorry yes uh the the former Chief slowly
is the last uh witness we intend to call
from the Ops but I do want to note for
the record that the commission had hope
and intended to call Superintendent Mark
Patterson as a witness in these
proceedings
Council advised the commission that he's
unable superintendent Patterson is
unable to testify for medical reasons
the commission did its due diligence to
ascertain whether he could testify with
or without accommodation in these
proceedings that due diligence included
seeking and reviewing the opinions of
two medical experts bearing on his
health the commission is satisfied in
the circumstances that it would not be
appropriate to call him as a witness
thank you
with that further uh explanation of
witness not attending we're going to
adjourn for the day and tomorrow I think
we're going to start with some of the
witnesses uh respect who are involved in
the process protests themselves I
believe are organizing the protests so
till adjourn till tomorrow morning at 9
30. thank you
the commission is a journalism